Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan. Wir sitzen vor dem Salon. Ich muss dich aber zunächst fragen, hält die Koalition?
Ja, also, über Mande und Einflugsschneise suchen, würde ich sagen, in 17 Medien noch 317 Mal nachgefragt, dann nicht. Und falls nicht, dann doch.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, die adäquate Antwort, die man nach dieser Medienberichterstattung geben kann. Regierungskrise hieß es schon in der Bildzeitung. Da wurden nochmal schnell Podcasts am Abend nachgeliefert.
Ja, sowieso.
Weil man dringend nochmal drüber sprechen muss, ob es jetzt den ganz großen Krach gibt. Wir werden dieses Thema im Salon vertiefen. Ja, ich überrasche dich mit etwas. Ich verrate es auch schon. Ich habe dir vor wenigen Tagen geschrieben, hast du irgendein Programm, das du mir nennen kannst, mit dem man eine Audiodatei transkribieren kann. Dann hast du mir so gleich einen Link geschickt. Das habe ich dann auch verwendet, dieses Programm. Was habe ich transkribiert? Ich habe transkribiert, die Sendung Miosga spricht mit Friedrich Merz. Wir hatten hier vor einiger Zeit mal Clips gespielt aus Talkshows und haben nur die Fragen gespielt.
Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Und jetzt habe ich das Spiel ein bisschen weitergetrieben. Ich dachte mir, jetzt daraus Clips zu machen, ist eigentlich unsinnig. Man muss tatsächlich die Fragen von Caren Miosga einmal sich transkribieren lassen und wir werden sie lesen. Wir werden uns fragen, was stimmt eigentlich mit diesem Journalismus nicht, der die Gelegenheit hat, 60 Minuten lang mit dem Bundeskanzler zu reden und dann diese Fragen zu stellen. Es geht mir nicht darum, dass ich jetzt sagen will, Miosga hat nicht hart genug nachgefragt, sondern meine Argumente sind andere. Es ist hochaufschlussreich. Wenn man den Text so im Ganzen liest, könnte man auch sagen, ist vielleicht was für den Ingeborg-Bachmann-Preis, könnte man einreichen. Es ist hochaufschlussreich und erschreckend. Das gibt es jedenfalls von mir im Salon. Da gibt es natürlich auch die Frage, hält dann die Koalition?
Es hatte ja kleine Nachspiele, dass wir das schon mal gemacht haben, dass du das schon mal gemacht hast. Ich kann jetzt nebulös sagen, bevor ich höre, was sie fragt, dass meine Reaktion, da ich ungefähr in dem Alter bin, wie ihre Redaktion, ungefähr genau die Reaktion ist, wie die der Redaktion, während die selber backstage sitzen und sich die Sendung anhören. Denn da arbeiten ja Leute, die bereiten was vor und so. Und dann lässt sich Caren Miosga wissend aus den Tagesthemen, dass ihr Durchschnittsalter 71 ist, die Leute schon seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr im Beruf und so weiter und so fort. Also was eben bedeutet, das gehört zum Urlaub bis ans Lebensende, dass man nicht mehr so richtig teilnimmt an der Gesellschaft, wie sie ist, weil man es nicht muss. Und es ist natürlich blöd, wenn man unter diesen Bedingungen Fernsehen macht.
Und es ist ein fundamentales Missverständnis abzulesen hier im Verhältnis Politik-Journalismus. Denn kritisch nachfragen, ein bisschen bohren, bedeutet nicht gleich kritisch nachfragen in dem Sinne. Wenn man nicht bereit ist, über Inhalte zu sprechen, dann ist man eigentlich nicht mehr weit entfernt von Ben ungeskriptet, setzt sich einfach hin und hat einen Politiker da und der ist den vier Stunden lang quatschen.
Aber er möchte wissen, was das für eine Person ist.
Für ein Mensch.
Ja.
So, wir gratulieren natürlich Friedrich Merz erstmal zu einem überstandenen Jahr. Derzeit, es wird ja nicht so richtig abgerechnet. Ich will kurz rekapitulieren. Friedrich Merz trat ja mal als CDU-Chef an und hat gewonnen nicht. Dann trat er nochmal an und gewann nicht. Dann trat er nochmal an und gewann. Und dann wollte er Bundeskanzler werden. Er trat an und gewann nicht. Und dann trat er nochmal an und dann gewann er. Und es gab, ob in Alexander Erklärung darüber, wie die linken jetzt und überhaupt und so. Und in dieser Folge, die setzt sich halt fort mit. Und dann trat er an zu regieren. Und es gab halt bisher alle lange keine Abrechnung und so, ja. Aber wir wissen, egal, welche KPIs man jetzt nehmen würde, es gelang halt nicht. Ja. So. Es gibt aber auch keinen zweiten Versuch. Das ist halt das Blöde. Also Chef kann man erst mal werden. Und Kanzler auch. Aber danach ist man ja halt in der Verantwortung so. Und wenn man eine Geschichte des Verlierens und Losens und auch eine Geschichte der von außen herangetragenen Nacherzählung es an sich selbst gescheitert mit sich führt, dann sieht ein 70-jähriges Lebensalter halt genauso aus. Deswegen schicken wir Leute typischerweise und es ist nicht dispektierlich oder so. Aber denkt mal wirklich über den Gedanken nach. Warum schicken wir die über 65-Jährigen in Rente? Das ist schon eine Aussage hinsichtlich. Die Jüngeren können es besser. Du bist nicht mehr so leistungsfähig. Kümmer dich jetzt um dich. Wir geben dir die Freiheit dafür und Geld. Und Deutschland so, nee, wir geben einem 70-Jährigen die wichtigste Rolle des Landes. Und es ist absolut normal, da zu scheitern. Es ist halt nur einfach schade, weil es gäbe ja noch andere Kandidaten, die auch Kanzler sein könnten. Und die kommen halt jetzt gerade nicht zum Zug. Also sozusagen doppelt blöd. Nicht nur haben wir einen blöden Kanzler, wir haben auch keinen guten. Also muss man doppelt verrechnen. Und in deren Sicht sieht die Bilanz düster aus. Die Frage ist, könnte man im Journalismus nicht genau so darüber reden? Also man kann ja durchaus bedauern, dass ein, jetzt hat er die Altersgrenze 66, aber er ist doch so eine Koryphäe in was weiß ich Forschung und so. Aber die Professur ist halt trotzdem vorbei. Und deshalb kann es dann nicht so. Und dafür müsste man eigentlich ehrlich, ernsthaft, wahrhaftig. Und ich würde sagen, man kann auch schön darüber reden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt die 70-jährigen, man kann ja von denen auch viel erfahren und viel lernen und so weiter. Also es ist ja, wenn man ihnen halt den Ort gibt und die Rollenbeschreibung und da auch wohlwollend mit umgeht, kann das ja alles gelingen, aber es gelingt halt gerade nicht.
Nur ist es so, dass du sagen würdest, dass ein 40-jähriger Friedrich Merz besser gewesen wäre? Ich habe da meine Zweifel. Also das Alter bringt natürlich einige Dinge mit, die es schwieriger machen zu regieren und sich anzupassen auch an neue Gegebenheiten. Und jetzt ist Friedrich Merz ohnehin nicht für besondere geistige Flexibilität bekannt, was dann alles noch hinzukommt. Aber ein 40-jähriger Friedrich Merz, ich meine, ich habe sein Buch gelesen, was er so veröffentlicht hat mit etwa 50 zum Thema Sozialstaat und Deutschland und wie er das so alles sieht, da wird einem genauso Angst und Bange wie bei dem 70-jährigen Friedrich Merz.
Das stimmt. Und diese Pointe ist gut. Ich möchte sie mit einer Pointe kontern. Wenn wir jetzt vergleichen, der 50-jährige Joe Biden gegen den 70-jährigen, dann sehen wir andere Reden, andere Leistungsfähigkeit, andere Termindichte. Da wäre einfach mehr los. Und dasselbe gilt für Donald Trump. Und jetzt gilt für Friedrich Merz dasselbe wie bei Donald Trump gilt. Trotz allem, was ich eben gesagt habe, schließe ich jetzt an mit, zum Glück ist er 70 und nicht 50.
Ja, ich weiß, was du sagen willst.
Jeder denkt sich jetzt selber den Teil. Miriam Lau war gestern im Deutschlandfunk und ließ sich interviewen zum Thema Merz, ein Jahr Merz. Und ich habe gedacht, es kann, also es geht einfach alles nicht. Es ist so, wir wissen alle, wie Merz behandelt wird. Das große rhetorische Talent, leider mal wieder gescheitert, aber da er gerade an seiner eigenen Rede gescheitert ist und beim ersten und beim zweiten Mal und beim ersten Kanzlerwahlgang und nichts geklappt hat, betonen wir einfach immer wieder, eigentlich ist er ein rhetorisches Talent. Also durch das Scheitern kommt überhaupt erst der Nimbus zustande, weil der Journalismus, der das beobachtet, bescheuert ist. So, also es ist einfach eine Fehlspezifikation im System.
Ja, also für die Leute, die Mariam Lau nicht kennen, Mariam Lau ist bei der Zeit und sie hat auch ein Buch über Friedrich Merz geschrieben. So.
Und lässt sich gerne einladen, um der Alten Republik nochmal zu erklären, von wem sie regiert wird.
Bin gespannt.
Und sie macht hier folgenden Spruch zum Thema, ja, aber hat ja Merz sich nicht sehr oft im Ton vergriffen.
Das wäre besser, wenn er seine Stimmung besser nachrecherchieren würde. Also wie ist das mit der Zahnbehandlung? Zuwanderer, Asylbewerber können die sich wirklich die Zähne machen lassen auf Kosten der Krankenkassen, Beitragszahler. So. Und dann hätte man schon mal einen Ärger weniger. Aber wie gesagt, trotzdem glaube ich...
Blablabla. Wie ist das jetzt? Hätte er mal seine Stimmung durchrecherchieren sollen? Und ich meine, der Bundestag hat schon einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst. So eine Art Klot-Recherche-Werkzeug in menschlicher Form. Wie sich der Papst es wünscht, wie wir heute lernen werden. Das Bundeskanzleramt ist selbst ein wissenschaftlicher Dienst. Mehrere Referate, die themenspezifisch dem Bundeskanzler zuarbeiten. Jetzt sagt sie, hätte er da nicht mal, und ich würde sagen, kurz drüber nachdenken können. Antwort, ja. Hätte man von der öffentlichen Kommunikation als Bundeskanzler grundsätzlich seine Referate fragen müssen. Antwort ist natürlich, ja natürlich, was sonst. So, all das passiert nicht. Und jetzt kommt sie mit, naja, hätte er da mal ein bisschen nachrecherchiert bei seiner Stimmung, wie ist das jetzt, wenn ein Migrant das Wartezimmer eines Arzt, eine Arztpraxis betritt, müssen dann alle anderen sofort raus, weil jetzt plötzlich ein VIP reingekommen ist. Die Antwort ist natürlich nein. Und sie sagt, hätte er darüber mal kurz nachgedacht, hätte ein Ärger weniger. So, das mit dem ein Ärger ist so ein bisschen problematisch, wenn es ganz viele ein Ärger gibt. Ja, also die Paschas völlig vermurkste Wahlkampfreden. Ich stelle mich als Kandidat vor, ich habe gar keinen Skript. Ach so, ach damit überzeuge ich ja niemanden. Ach so, ja gut, dann versuche ich halt dreimal hier gewählt zu werden. Also reden, die komplett misslegen. Jede einzelne Botschaft vor der Öffentlichkeit völlig misslungen. Sitz bei Lanz, sagt irgendwas die kleinen Paschas, redet was vom Stadtbild, drei Tage später bringt er seine Töchter rein. Jedes Mal wird es schlimmer. Also wir haben ja auf gar keinen Fall mal so ein Ärger. Hätte mal über... Mittlerweile ist ja so, wenn hier sie redet über Zahnärzte, bei Friedrich Merz und Zahnärzten weiß man gar nicht, um was geht es jetzt eigentlich? Geht es noch um seine Aussage, dass die Migranten da irgendwie die Zahnarzttermine weggehen? Oder geht es schon um seinen CDU Wirtschaftsrat, der sagt, wir brauchen gar keine Zahnärzte mehr? Also man kommt ja völlig durcheinander mittlerweile.
Das liegt ja mal daran und deshalb auch immer wieder der Rückgriff auf das große rhetorische Talent, das man von 1997 mal offenbar so irgendwo gehört hat, ist, dass sie ein Ideal des Kanzlers haben, dem er bitte zu entsprechen habe. Und wenn dieses Bild einmal von ihm unterlaufen wird und dann auch hundertmal unterlaufen wird, dann sagen sie ja, das hätte er da und dort so wohl nicht machen können. Bitte, errichte uns wieder das Idealbild, das wir uns mal 1997 von dir gemacht haben.
Ja, es ist einfach völlig großartig.
Es ist der Kanzler jetzt, der da ist. Es ist nicht der Kanzler, der Idealkanzler, der regiert und dann gibt es leider schon mal den, der kurz ausschert. Es gibt nur den Kanzler.
Genau, da fühlst du dich schon auf den richtigen Weg, denn ich finde es ja selber quatschig die ganze Zeit, G-Jack hier und blau und so, aber wir kommen jetzt um das Phantom. Wir haben Rediker angesprochen, das Phantasmer, G-Jack, um, wie ich sage, virtuelle Sachen nicht herum. Diese Journalisten leben in ihrer eigenen Traumwelt, in der sie so Bibi Blocksberg gehört haben und ihr Bild vom Bundeskanzler, vom dortigen Bürgermeister ableiten, wie er vorgestellt wird. So, ja. Direkt nach diesem Spruch, ja, würde er sich über die Zahnärzte ein bisschen mehr informieren, hätte ein Ärger weniger, sagt Miriam Lau folgendes.
Es ist immer irgendwie was Wahres dran und darauf kann man sich auch ruhig mal einlassen.
So, es ist ja angeblich, sagt sie, immer was Wahres dran. Bei Friedrichs Merz Botschaften ist nirgendwo etwas Wahres dran. Man kann gar nicht beschreiben, wie weit in Phantasma wir hier sind. Diese Zeit, die im März jetzt Deutschland, sagen wir mal seit 2018, er kommt zurück, er möchte da noch antreten, Merkel ist weg und wie auch immer, sie sagt, sie will nicht mehr. So, nur in den Themen, bei denen ich mich auskenne. 2015 darf sich ihn wiederholen, weil es ist jetzt seit zehn Jahren der Satz. 2015 ist das einzige Jahr, in dem sich die deutsche Bevölkerung mal verjüngt hat. Wer genau bei diesem Jahr sagt, das darf sich nicht wiederholen, hat einfach einen kompletten Knall. Und da ist auch nicht was Wahres dran oder so.
Und wir lesen heute ein ganzes Buch, das das noch mal sehr deutlich unterstreicht.
In dem, in dem...
Von Frank-Potollo.
Ja.
Na, der sagt ja schon mit Migration, wie viel Netto und Zuwanderung...
Migration spielt eine große Rolle, genau, es ist, ja, stimmt, absolut....
benötigt würde, um...
Ja, genau. Genau, wir kriegen nachher eine gute Migrationsanlage.
Wir kriegen auch ein anderes Buch, das das nicht so beschreibt, ja.
Genau, ja, stimmt, das zweite ist, ich bleibe mal bei meinem Thema. Wir haben Migranten in Deutschland. Wir liegen achtfach über dem Durchschnitt des Migrationsanteils der Länder der Welt. Achtfach. Das ist ein Wert, den erreicht nicht mal die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika. Wir sind das heterogene Land, nicht Amerika. Man hört immer hier Chinatown da, irgendwas da. Und dann machen die alle so, nee, Deutschland ist das. Banusviertel, Offenbach, selbst ostdeutsche Dörfer haben einfach Migration. So. Und wie man da einen Migrationsdiskurs führt, indem man einfach sagt, also einer, der sich richtig gut macht in der Regierung, ist der Innenminister. Der hält sich sowohl mit Söder als auch mit Merz total ausbalanciert und alle finden ihn gut. Der Typ schickt für 20.000 Euro am Tag oder so Hubschrauber in den Wald, damit da irgendwelche in Soldatenkluft mit Waffen behangene Polizisten, Migranten abwehren, die da gar nicht sind. Das ist die Politik. Und wenn hier irgendwer irgendwas dazu sagt, dann ist da gar nichts wahres dran. Da ist nichts wahres dran. In diesen Sprüchen, die wir aus der CDU hören, ist nichts wahres dran.
Es ist auch nichts wahres dran, wenn Friedrich Merz glaubt, dass die wirtschaftliche Schwäche Deutschlands gerade darin begründet liegt, dass viele Leute gerne eine Work-Life-Balance hätten und von einer Vier-Stunden-Vier-Tage-Woche träumen. Denn diese ist nicht Realität. Sie ist sehr weit weg und diese Debatte darüber verändert noch nicht das BIP. Das ist völliger Unsinn. Wenn man hier jetzt sagt, ja, dumpfes Gefühl haben wir immer alle zu allem irgendetwas und das ruft Friedrich Merz ab und das identifiziert man dann als das Wahre, das da dran ist. Ja, dann ist man aber so schiefgewekelt, dann macht man wirklich nur noch das Leben ein Traum, dann macht man eine virtuelle Berichterstattung über eine virtuelle Politik.
Die Realität ist, ja, es gibt Messerstecher, die dann auf Kindergartengruppen einstechen und wir haben durchaus kleine Kinder, die sich walden wie Paschas. So, dass das nicht zwingend mit Migration zu tun hat, wissen wir auch. Also wenn Gewalt irgendwo zu suchen ist, dann ja wohl in der bio-deutschen Ehe, kurz vor Renteneintritt. Oder weil man einen Pflegefall oben im Dach geschlossen hat und so langsam die Geduld verliert. Nur aktuelle Zahlen ja. In Sachen Migration, die migrantische Bevölkerung, erste Generation, also Leute, die wirklich im Ausland geboren sind und in Deutschland jetzt leben und arbeiten. Und wie wir wissen, 7.000 Euro pro Nase in die Sozialkasse einzahlen. Deshalb wir viel mehr Einwanderung in die Sozialkasse bräuchten, weil sonst keine Sozialkasse mehr. Die sind im Schnitt fast zehn Jahre jünger als die bio-deutsche Bevölkerung. Die bringen also genau den Puffer mit, den wir brauchen, um die jetzt ins Rente kommende Boomer zu finanzieren. Nimmt man deren Kinder noch hinzu, also Kinder, die schon wieder in Deutschland geboren wurden, aber von ausländischen Eltern, dann liegen die sogar elf Jahre unter dem deutschen Schnitt. Elf Jahre klingt gar nicht so viel, ist aber bei einer 47-jährigen Bevölkerung im Schnitt 20 Prozent. Das sind genau diese Puffer, die wir brauchen. Was haben wir für einen Diskurs? Also da ist nichts wahres dran. Kannst du eigentlich deutlich knub sagen. Es ist überhaupt gar nichts wahres dran, wenn aus der CDU jemand öffentlich kommunizieren. Vor allem nicht in spontaner Gefühlsregung. So, Miriam Lau zur Koalitionslage. Wir haben ja Friedrich Merz, Lars Klingbeil. Jetzt hören wir die ganze Zeit. Die verstehen sich ja nicht so gut, wo ich mir denke. Also die Arbeiten im Metier der Politik. Da gilt einfach 50% plus X, Mehrheit besiegelt. Dass man das historisch hintereinander verketten und deswegen der Kompromiss, so eine Zauberkraft erringt. Okay, gut. Man muss sich halt abstimmen. Kennt man ja. Aber wir sind trotzdem in der Politik. Da regieren zwei verschiedene Parteien, bei denen wir uns drüber lustig machen, wenn die eine im Podcast sagt, ja, dann kann man doch bei dem Thema mal die Grünen wählen oder so. Absurd. Es regieren SPD und CDU. Da sind zwei unterschiedliche Parteien. Miriam Lau zum neuen Verständnis dieser beiden.
Also eine Zeit lang war das so, jedenfalls meine Beobachtung, dass dieses Scharnier Kanzler, Vizekanzler, Merz Klingbeil, das hat sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Auch deshalb, weil man sich ideologisch eigentlich nicht so wahnsinnig fern ist.
Ja, das ist aber ein Problem, wenn das die Diagnose ist. Ja, das ist das Problem.
Nicht so wahnsinnig fern ist. Also beide wollen Wachstum, schlicht und ergreifend.
Und welcher Politik will kein Wachstum?
Wirklich, das ist so grotesk. Beide wollen Wachstum. Ja. Ich würde mir ja wünschen, dass der eine sagt, ich will Wachstum, wir müssen sofort Panzer kaufen, jeder Panzer bringt so viel BIP und so weiter. Und dann wird das nächstes Jahr verrechnet. Und dann will ich eine andere Partei, die sagt, ich will auch Wachstum, wir investieren in Kinder, jedes kriegt sieben Euro pro investiertem Euro zurück, aber erst in elf Jahren. So, das ist beides Wachstum. Aber das kann man doch nicht unter einem Nenner. Ja, eigentlich sind die sich voll nah und überhaupt, da gibt es gar keinen Grund für Konflikte. Was ist denn das für ein politischer Journalismus, den man dazu macht?
Vorausgesetzt wird hier, dass jede sozialdemokratische oder gar grüne oder linke Maßnahme, die ergriffen wird, per se wachstumsfeindlich ist, weil damit der Sozialstaat aufgebaut wird. Und wenn der Sozialstaat größer wird, dann schwächt das das Wachstum. Das ist ja die Prämisse, die dem zu Grunde liegt, die falsch ist. Deshalb ist alles, was uns, also den Arbeitnehmern etwas zumutet, was auch nötige, aber auch harte Reformen bedeutet, das bedeutet immer Wachstum. Und wenn jetzt Klingbeil harte Reformen ankündigt und der Herr sagt, genau das wollen wir auch, dann sieht das für Mariam Lau so aus, als seien die auf einem Wachstumsfahrt, während alle anderen, die sagen, wir müssten zum Beispiel mehr investieren in Bildung, als die Idioten dastehen, die ja keine Ahnung von Wachstum haben. Das ist aber einfach eine Verblendung bei besagter Journalistin.
Absolut. Ich will auch eine kleine Transferleistung anbieten, einfach nur beim drüber nachdenken, also reine Heuristik jetzt. Wir erleben gerade, dass die Coupling, Wirtschaftswachstum ohne das der CO2-Ausstoß im gleichen Maße steigt. Also Elektrifizierung, was auch immer.
Um das gleich zu sagen, kein absolutes Decoupling, weil wir sonst gleich eine E-Mail bekommen, aber wir erleben das. Ich will das auch deutlich unterstreichen. Mehr als wir gedacht haben, dass das möglich ist.
Genau. So. Das sehen wir aber vor allem, weil in Amerika eine Doktrin vorherrscht. Ich muss Krieg im Iran führen wegen dem Öl oder Wildezuehler oder was auch immer. Mit der, kann man jetzt flapsig sagen, unintendierten Nebenfolge, dass wenn Trump sagt, also wenn ich keinen Öl von den Iraner kriege, gar keiner, dass die ganze Welt sagt, ach so, ohne Öl jetzt. Ja gut, dann fahren wir jetzt erstmal nach China und kaufen einen. So. Also dieses Decoupling wird nun zufälligerweise genau von denen herangetrieben, wo ich mir denke, ja, also wenn der Habeck Weg nicht geht, es versöhnlich zu machen, machen wir es halt einfach über kurz vor Weltkrieg. So, aber der Effekt ist derselbe. Was aber bedeutet, es gibt ja eine Alternative. Also wir könnten auch, wer mir diese Kompetenzunterstellung bei der CDU letztens ausformuliert, die CDU betritt die politische Bühne und sagt, wir müssen jetzt alle leiden. Denn wer schön sein will, muss leiden. Wer reich sein will, muss leiden. Und ich denke mir, nö, das kann man ja auch dekappeln. Also man kann genauso ohne so eine fetischistische, sadistische, wir müssen jetzt alle leiden. Also es muss ja kein Krebstumor aus dem Gehirn ausgerupert werden. Wir wollen ja einfach nur Wachstum. So, ja, also müssen jetzt alle leiden. Und ich würde sagen, nee, man muss jetzt nicht Oma Erna noch mal davon überzeugen, nur weil der Arzt gesagt hat, oh, das wird jetzt kurz pieksen, dass der Kanzler nur dann kompetent ist, wenn er sagt, oh, das wird jetzt kurz pieksen. So, aber gut, wärme jetzt diesen Weg nicht. Ich möchte nur holistisch anmerken. Also das wäre durchaus möglich. Wir können doch einfach den Habeck Weg gehen. Wir hätten jetzt wahrscheinlich sogar weniger Wärmepumpen gerade im Verkauf, weil das, was Trump da veranstaltet, also Wärmepumpe ist gerade das Ding in Deutschland. Einfach mal kein politischer Diskurs, sondern einfach nur jeder Einzelne, der sich kurz durchkalkulieren will, was bringt mir eine Wärmepumpe? Und dann sagen die, ja, kostet 20.000 mehr, aber rentiert sich ab Jahr drei. Zack, kaufen die Leute eine Wärmepumpe. Oh, Wunder, ja? Also, das ist schon verrückt. So, jetzt, Miriam Lau zum Vierten. Eigentlich könnte man sagen, hier gibt es nichts mehr zu kommentieren. Alles versteht sich von selbst. Also, damit möchte ich sagen, ich weiß, liebe Hörer, ihr seid unser Publikum, ihr seid wahnsinnig klug. Wir müssten jetzt nichts dazu sagen. Aber Wolfgang wird diesen Clip jetzt hören. Und natürlich haben wir einfach Lust, was dazu zu sagen. Also, wir hören jetzt Miriam Lau zum Vierten.
Wie ist ihre Einschätzung? In welche Richtung sollte er als Erstes nachbessern?
Wenn man sich mal erinnert an diese eine Ansprache, die Angela Merkel, die ja auch ein eher verschlossener Typ war, mal gehalten hat, während der Corona-Krise. Es ist ernst, nehmen sie es auch ernst. So eine Art von Ansprache wünsche ich mir. Ich glaube, ich würde dem Land gut tun, einfach alle mal zusammensammeln, so ein kleines politisches Lagerfeuer entzünden und sagen, wir brauchen euch alle.
Ja, eine schöne, wärmende Volksgemeinschaft brauchen wir. Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun? Merkel hält eine Rede angesichts einer Pandemie. Wir wissen noch nicht, wohin die Reise geht. Ein Virus, ein Problem muss gelöst werden. Wir können noch nicht sagen, genau wie. Wir müssen uns jetzt erst einmal zurücknehmen, damit das Virus nicht sich weiter ausbreitet. Jetzt stehen wir in Deutschland vor sehr verschiedenen wirtschaftlichen, demografischen und sonstigen Herausforderungen. Wie soll dieses Lagerfeuer-Forderung etwas bringen? Weil bei Merkel war ja nicht ein Lagerfeuer, sondern sie sagte ja, wir bleiben jetzt mal zu Hause und schauen dann, wie sich das entwickelt. Das geht dann runter, die Inzidenzen. Dann fängt man an zu schauen, wie man damit umgehen kann. Masken, Impfungen und so weiter. Hier kann man ja nur eine Wir-gehören-alle-zusammen-Rede, was immer die größte Lüge der Welt ist, halten. Bei der aber danach nichts anderes entsteht, außer zu sagen, naja gut, aber jetzt hat sich trotzdem mein Portemonnaie nicht verändert. An der Tankzäule sieht es immer noch genauso aus. Nichts verändert sich dadurch. Was Mariam Lau hier eigentlich einfordert, ist das, was die Journalisten immer sich wünschen, dass so ein großes Wir beschworen wird, einfach nur damit sie sich in Berlin gut fühlen. Aber davon können wir uns leider hier in Frankfurt, Copens und sonst wo nichts kaufen.
Also Friedrich Merz ist ja, wie wir wissen, ein rhetorisches Talent. Ich glaube, die Transferleistung wäre von ihm zu schultern. Zu sagen, Momentchen mal, die Mariam Lau, die hat eigentlich recht. Merkel hat ja damals bei einem Virus gesagt, es ist ernst, also nehmen sie es ernst. Was ist eigentlich mein Virus gerade? Okay, die Krise besteht darin, dass wir wieder so Inflationssprünge haben, weil uns Rohöl fehlt, alle Angst haben, wie auch immer. Die Ursache dafür, also was ist das Äquivalent des Virus? Ah ja, Trumps Dummheit. Und ehrlich gesagt, ja, Mariam Lau, ich wünsche mir eine Rede von Friedrich Merz zum Thema. Trumps Dummheit ist so gefährlich wie das Coronavirus. Bitte erinnern Sie sich. Nehmen Sie es selbst. Das Problem ist nur, Friedrich Merz war ja in der Einschulklasse und hat dort quasi gesagt, also Trumps Dummheit. Da kommen natürlich gleich wieder drei Robin Alexander Podcasts, die uns erklären, das verstehe ich gar nicht. Merz muss doch wissen, dass er immer als Kanzler spricht, auch vor Schülern und so. Ja, und es wird gleich wieder eingehegt.
Wir kommen jetzt auch da nochmal bei Viosga, da kommt natürlich auch noch zu sprechen.
Aber ich bin total dafür zu sagen, halt mal bitte eine Rede zum Thema, das ist ernst, nehmen sie es ernst, und dann wird das aber ausformuliert. Was ist hier gerade so ernst?
Ja, und dann können wir über die Industrialisierung sprechen. Wir können mal darüber sprechen, dass die EU sinnlose Zölle gegen China verhängt, sodass die wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen zu China schlechter werden. Wir können darüber reden, dass das Reich alles torpediert, was die Klimatransformation vorantreiben könnte und damit auch Wachstum schaffen würde. Über all das könnte man mal reden. Da braucht man aber kein politisches Lagerfeuer, sondern da muss man dann tatsächlich mal das ansprechen, was der Fall ist. Das wollen diese Journalisten ja nicht. Sie wollen wirklich nur ein Gefühl. Also eigentlich suchen sie ja ein Papst. Wir haben heute einen im Angebot. Also eigentlich suchen sie ja jemanden, der ein paar gute Worte für einen hat. Aber der Papst spricht halt klüger und politischer als das, was die Journalisten eigentlich vom Kanzler erwarten. Es ist so dramatisch eigentlich dieser gesamte deutsche Politikbereich, Berichterstattungs- und Meinungsjournalismus, dass man es, also ich kriege es ja auch nur noch in geringen Dosen mit. Dann setze ich mich so in einem Miosga-Gespräch von einer Stunde aus, habe da schon das Transkript, streiche dann die März-Antworten raus und habe das dann vor mir und denke mir, das ist eine solche Verblödung, die da stattfindet. Wir müssen wirklich über nichts mehr diskutieren mit, wie können wir irgendwie Social Media beschränken oder so. Also das hier ist eine Verblödungsmaschine, das kriegt keinen Algorithmus hin.
Ja, der Papst ist so klug. Ich möchte eine Pointe schon mal vor die Paywall ziehen, damit ihr hört, wie klug es immer hinter der Paywall zugeht. Der Papst, Leo XIV., wir haben aufgeklärt, er ist nicht der 16., der 14. hat beim Welttag für Social Media oder so vor Jugendlichen eine Rede gehalten. Und in der formuliert er, ich will jetzt nicht sagen die Gefahren vor der KI, denn er möchte es versöhnlich gestalten. Aber er sagt, eine Bedrohung heute im zwischenmenschlichen Beisammensein sind nichtgedachte Gedanken. Im Sinne von, da hat kein Mensch in Einheit von Geist und Leib und so im Antlitz eines anderen einen Fortschritt im Dialog gesucht, wodurch Gedanken entstehen, sondern es gibt jetzt nichtgedachte Gedanken. Profane Menschen würden jetzt sagen, die KI Halluziniert oder sowas, ja. Und ich sehe das im Journalismus aber auch. Wir haben es hier von Miriam Lau zum Beispiel mit wirklich nichtgedachten Gedanken. Und das sind nicht nur einfach undurchdachte Gedanken oder so, sondern das sind nichtgedachte Gedanken. Miriam Lau unterstellt Merz, er habe bei öffentlicher Kommunikation nicht so richtig nachgedacht und sich dadurch Ärger eingehandelt. Und meine Frage ist, wie viel Denken steckt denn in den geäußerten Gedanken von Miriam Lau zu diesem Sachverhalt? Und die Antwort ist Null. Also der nichtgedachte Gedanke ist jetzt eine echte Gefahr. Und es hat gar nicht mehr nur mit KI zu tun.
Und wenn man ernsthaft sagt, egal auf welcher politischen Seite man steht, aber wenn man ernsthaft als Journalist sagt, wir brauchen ein politisches Lagerfeuer und die Ansprache muss sein, wir brauchen euch alle, dann weiß man, dass das Demagogie ist. Und das muss man auch genau so benennen. Es geht in der Politik immer um Interessen. Und wenn man die Interessen der anderen besser findet und die eher vertritt und sagt, nein, wir wollen aber den Reichen noch mehr geben, dann kann ich damit klarkommen. Dann weiß ich, das ist die Position, meine ist eine andere. Aber wenn mir jemand gegenüber sitzt und sagt, ich will jetzt mal, dass der Kanzler zu mir sagt, wir brauchen euch alle, dann ist das die größte Lüge der Welt, die man einfordert vom Kanzler, die er machen soll. Es ist Unsinn. Und deswegen haben wir einen Parlamentarismus, weil es dieses euch alle verkörpert von einer Person nicht gibt. Dann muss man sich einen König auserkürren. Dann muss man schauen, ob man Angebote bei den Reichsbürgern oder sonst wo findet. Aber das findet man nicht in einer parlamentarischen Demokratie.
Ja, die ist nicht dafür da. Der Kompromiss erfordert sowohl Servien abfeuern, eine Konfliktlage.
Ja.
Diese Miosgasache ist Salonlektüre oder?
Das ist Salonlektüre. Also das ist wirklich ein Highlight, verspreche ich. Wir sprechen über Miosga. Wir sprechen aber vor allem über zwei Bücher, die unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten. Und zwar sprechen wir über Das knappe Gut Arbeit von Florian Butollo. Er ist Arbeitssoziologe hier in Frankfurt, und er sagt, ja, es gibt eine Automatisierung, es gibt KI, aber es gibt einen strukturellen Arbeitskräftemangel und der wird sich noch verschärfen. Die KI wird diese Probleme nicht lösen. Möglicherweise gibt es eine Ausdiffenzierung und Komplexitätssteigerung, die eher dazu führt, dass wir noch sehr viel mehr Leute brauchen. Und wo werden wir sie dann hernehmen? Denn sie sind de facto nicht vorhanden. Es ist ein sehr intelligentes Buch, das sich damit auseinandersetzt.
Also da du es jetzt als intelligent, ich möchte anmerken, ich trage das Ergebnis mit, aber der Rechenweg gefällt mir gar nicht.
Ja, das habe ich mir fast gedacht, dass das etwas ist, was bei dir Widerspruch erregt. Wo wir uns wahrscheinlich einig sind, und trotzdem ist es sinnvoll, darüber zu diskutieren, ist das Buch, das die Leute aus dem Nios-Verlag herausgegeben haben. Es heißt links, deutsch, deutsch, links und soll ein Wörterbuch sein, um die Linken und ihre Sprache zu verstehen und zu entlarven.
Es ist ein Wörterbuch nach Optik. Das können wir eher sagen.
Richtig. Also wir haben LEMMATA.
Danach geht es drunter und drüber.
Begriffe wie zum Beispiel Femizid, Flächenbrand, Fachkraft, Erinnerungskultur, Experte, Desinformation, Demokratische Mitte. Wir können hier an diesen Beiträgen, bei denen wirklich nicht ein einziger Gut ist.
Doch, einer.
Ja, okay. Ich bin sehr gespannt, welcher das dann sein wird. Aber sie gehen alle am Ziel vorbei. Also es ist, oder sagen wir dann fast alle, es ist wirklich beeindruckend, beeindruckend, wie denkfoul Menschen sein können und das dann noch in ein Buch reinschreiben. Aber was wir hier sehen, es ist, würde ich sagen, so eine Art Gründungsdokument. Sollte es eine schwarz-blaue Koalition geben, dann wird das ja keine Höcke-Koalition sein. Davon darf man ausgehen. Es wird auch keine sein, die sich gegen den Transatlantizismus stellt. Es wird keine sein, die russlandfreundlich ist, weil das jetzt immer wieder gesagt wurde. Nein, es wird eine solche Koalition sein, wie sie hier in den verschiedenen Beiträgen nachzusehen ist. Also in gewisser Weise ist das schon so ein Wahlprogramm für eine schwarz-blaue Koalition. Vielleicht dann auch noch mit der FDP dabei. Wolfgang Kubicki jedenfalls kommt hier in diesem Büchlein ja auch vor. Es ist insofern aufschlussreich, aber ganz deutlich hier gesagt, nicht zum Kaufen empfohlen. Wir sprechen so drüber.
Wir sprechen so drüber. Jetzt habe ich gesagt, ein Text davon ist gut, aber halt aus Versehen, was nur wieder zeigt, wie dumm das Buch angelegt ist. Also man hat wirklich gar nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Ja, genau, das ist interessant. Ich bringe noch Musik mit, nämlich neue Musik, eingespielt von Anne-Sophie Mutter, grandios. Dann eine Novelle, die sich mit KI-Fragen auseinandersetzt und Autor schafft. Kann man anhand eines Textes wirklich Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen, daraus ziehen, um welche Person es sich handelt? Also wir haben Profiler, die so etwas machen. Was ist, wenn man da als Lektor irgendwann, wo KI schon sehr weit fortgeschritten ist, einen Text erhält und dieser Text, so klingt es fast, stammt von einer einstigen Liebe. Dem geht Philipp Schönthaler nach. Um Liebe geht es auch in dem Roman von Thomas Hettche. Der ist so kühn und hat seinen Roman einfach Liebe genannt. Da steht nur als Titel Liebe. Das muss man erstmal bringen. Wird ein Roman dem gerecht? Ja, dieser wird dem. Darüber werden wir sprechen.
So was darf nur der Vatikan. Wir lesen heute Vatikan-Sachen. Und zwar gab es zum einen diesen großen Text zum Verhältnis künstlicher und menschlicher Intelligenz. Als ich ihn durchgelesen hatte, war ich zum einen fasziniert, wie man den Vatikan formuliert. Man bezieht sich ausschließlich auf eigene religiöse Autoren. Weshalb mir gar nicht auffiel, sondern erst in der letzten Zeile nach 20.000 Worten, dass das natürlich noch Franziskus 2025 war.
Ach so.
Was dem Text aber, da ich ja das, was ich eben gesagt habe, gilt, den könnte man jetzt auch in drei Jahren noch spielen. Deswegen spielen wir ihn heute. Aber erst nachdem wir uns über Leos Ausführungen beim Welttag der sozialen Kommunikationsmitteln auch zum Thema KI, also wir haben durchaus Publikationen, weiter perpest du jetzt zum Thema KI. Dann schon angesprochenen Podcast, die Maskulinisierung of Populations Reverses Sex Difference Infertility. Erstmals die Zäsur aus 2024 bekommen die Frauen mehr Kinder als die Männer. Jetzt kann man alle ein bisschen darüber nachdenken, wie ist das gemein und so, aber die Aufklärung wird einfach. Und wir eröffnen das Lesen einer enzyklopädischen Arbeit, die hier im Büro entstand. Mary-Jane hat sich um das Infermezzo als Grundbegriff gekümmert.
Infermezzo?
Infermezzo. Es ist also aus zwei Worten zusammengebaut. Aufklärung dazu gleich im Salon. Denn es ist ein Problem, das ich auch kenne. Das ist ein Problem, das Butollo nicht kennt. Weil Butollo über die KI schreibt, aber anscheinend nicht so viel mit ihr arbeite. Und beim Thema mit der KI arbeiten, ist das Infermezzo. Also jeder wird sofort verstehen, um was es da geht, wenn wir in diesen Text eingehen.
Und wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, am 22. August sind wir in Frankfurt zu erleben. Dann gibt es den Sommer Live-Podcast mit uns beiden. Jetzt erstmal viel Vergnügen beim Salon.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ist Florian Butollo ein Nachfolger von Karl Marx?
Er knüpft an ihn an, geht aber dann eine sehr andere Richtung.
Was hast du als Marxist hier rausgelesen? Wir können ja kurz diese Klammer schließen.
Er bezieht sich mehrmals auf Marx und das ist auch sehr sinnvoll, denn Marx hat sich ja im Maschinenfragment, aber auch an anderen Passagen, an anderen Stellen seines Werkes mit der Automatisierung beschäftigt und auch der Frage, ob es möglich sein wird, dass die Maschinen unsere Arbeit übernehmen und wir immer weniger arbeiten müssen. Das ist also ein Gedanke, der bei Marx schon da ist. Bei dem Maschinenfragment hat man es mit einem Fragment zu tun. Es geht also nicht darum, dass Marx jetzt das Ausbuch stabiert hat, wie die Zukunft sein wird. Darauf bezieht er sich mitunter und macht auch mit Marx deutlich, dass das so einfach nicht ist aufgrund von Konkurrenzverhältnissen, aufgrund von der Frage, ja, wie ist eigentlich Arbeit zu verstehen und von welcher Arbeit sprechen wir da? Denn es ist ein bisschen kompliziert bei Marx, aber ich will vielleicht diese Ausführung gerade machen. Zunächst mal könnte man ja sagen, technischer Fortschritt bedeutet, Menschen können weniger arbeiten, weil ja mehr produziert werden kann durch Automatisierung. Bei Marx könnte man so etwas auch finden, was ja auch überall in der Realität anzutreffen ist. Wenn wir aber Unternehmen haben, die sich konkurrenzhaft gegenüberstehen, ist das ja nicht etwas Statisches. Das heißt, man kann nicht sagen, als produzieren wir ja einfach mehr, dann ist ja gut. Sondern man muss ja sehen, der Konkurrent tut das auch. Wenn der Konkurrent mit Maschinen plötzlich doppelt so schnell produzieren kann, wenn irgendwann diese Maschinen verbreitet sind, dann können alle ja schneller produzieren. Max würde dann wieder sagen, deshalb wird Wert nur durch die Arbeitskraft hergestellt. Also Maschinen schaffen keinen Wert, sondern Menschen schaffen den Wert. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt beispielsweise ein Unternehmen hast, das spart Zeit dadurch, dass diese Maschinen sehr schnell arbeiten, dann kann man kurze Zeit, wenn man das erste Unternehmen ist, das diese Maschinen hat, sich einen extra Profit einfahren damit. Weil man ja den anderen überlegen ist. Aber die Konkurrenz wird aufholen. Um das mal an einem Beispiel zu machen, das für uns naheliegend ist, weil du hier viel erzählt hast von Homepage bauen. Es war eine Zeit Ende der 90er Jahre, wenn als das Internet aufkam und plötzlich jeder eine Homepage haben wollte, da konnte man, wenn man so ein bisschen Know-how hatte, sehr viel Geld mit verdienen, weil man einen Wissensvorsprung hatte. Ja, einen konnte diesen technischen Vorsprung für sich nutzen. Wenn dann plötzlich alle in etwa wissen, wie man eine Homepage bauen kann, also die ganze Konkurrenz, dann fällt der Preis. Wenn wir jetzt bei den KI sogar so weit haben, dass die auf Knopfdruck in Windeseile eine Homepage erstellen können, dann kann ja nicht ein Unternehmen einfach sagen, wir nehmen den alten Preis von früher, wo wir noch zehn Leute dran gesetzt haben, die designt haben. Folglich müssen entweder die Homepages jetzt mehr können, wo doch wieder menschliche Arbeitskraft benötigt wird, die man dann auch abrechnen kann. Oder man hat halt einen totalen Wertverfall und sagt, niemand gibt mehr Geld für eine Homepage aus. Und das ist eigentlich ein Prinzip, das sehr runtergebrochen jetzt Marx beschreibt. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich über die Arbeitskraft reden als wertschaffend. Und das macht interessanterweise Butollo kaum. Also er spricht über diese Werttheorie von Marx nicht, was mich wundert, weil das sehr gut zu seiner Argumentation passen würde. Sein Marx-Bezug ist ja vor allem zu sagen, ja, Marx hatte auch schon über Fortschritt und all das nachgedacht. Aber er geht eigentlich dann mehr nur von den Konkurrenzverhältnissen aus, aber nicht so sehr, dass wirklich die Arbeitskraft den Wert schafft.
Genau. Du sagst jetzt, das findet man bei Butollo so nicht. Ich denke, ja, ich bin jetzt nicht der allergrößte Marx-Leser. Aber für das, was du jetzt gesagt hast, gibt es ja ein sehr gutes Buch von Dietmar Datt, 100 Seiten Marx, in dem genau dieses, ah ja, der Kapitalist macht mit seinen Arbeitern nicht nur Arbeit, sondern es findet auch einen gewissen Fortschritt in Sachen, kennen wir ja, Fließband und so weiter. Also, dass dann solche Sachen kommen. Und der steht dann aber gesellschaftsweit zur Verfügung, weshalb in der ganzen Marx-Ausarbeitung auch ein historisches Fortschrittsmodell, Gesellschaften erreichen immer Stufen, auf denen dann auch der Arbeitskampf ganz anders aussehen muss. Weil wir können uns zwar heute immer wieder darauf besinnen, zu sagen, naja, die Leute fordern jetzt eine Viertagewoche, aber sollten sie nicht nochmal abfeiern, dass ihnen damals der Samstag als Fünfter erkämpft wurde und so. Da muss man halt dann sagen, nee, auch in Marx steckt drin, dass man schon gerade auf seiner eigenen Entwicklungsstufe in Kampf führt. Und nicht ständig immer nur in der Geschichte. Was bedeutet? Wir können für dieses Buch hier zwei Sachen markieren. Zum einen, ja, es gibt einen gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt, der von Unternehmen vorangetrieben wird. Weshalb, und ich habe schon mal die Pointe gemacht, dass wir Marxisten finden, wo wir sie nicht vermuten. Zum Beispiel bei der CDU. Jeder Unternehmer, der argumentiert, nein, ich kann mein Geld nicht dem allgemeinen Steuertopf zur Verfügung stellen, weil ich das für meine Investitionen brauche, macht im Grundsatz ein Marxistisches Argument. Das begegnet uns so halb, wie du angedeutet hast. Ich finde auch, das ist eigentlich wichtiger, denn wir haben jetzt KI und stellen uns diese große Frage. Die größte Investition aller Zeiten in Amerika, steht jetzt eigentlich nur Unternehmen zur Verfügung oder uns allen. Selbst solange sie nur, silo gedacht, nur Unternehmen zur Verfügung steht, das Homepage bauen können wir jetzt trotzdem alle selber machen, ohne dass wir Mitglieder von Open AI, Anthropic oder sonst so weiter sind. Also die beuten es nicht nur für sich aus. Und uns wird hier wieder, und das müssen wir aber dann ein bisschen verdrehen, wenn wir an der entsprechenden Textstelle sind, die Volgärmarxisten der CDU begegnen uns wieder, denn der Begriff Sockelarbeitslosigkeit, wird hier eine große Rolle spielen, wenn die Demografie erstmal entfaltet ist. Ja. Oder halt auch gleich am Anfang. Also wir können ja gleich hier oben einsteigen. Er markiert das Problem gleich auf Seite 11. Was ist aber, wenn nicht die Massenarbeitslosigkeit, sondern dauerhafte Arbeitskräfteknappheit, zu einem Strukturmerkmal kapitalistischer Entwicklungen wird. Also das sehen wir jetzt gerade über demografische Zäsuren. Sind wir ja hier gut aufgeklärt. Im Podcast machen wir ja in der Herde sogar nochmal. Und seinen Lösungsvorschlag gleich am Anfang. Und das ist die Pointe, auf die es dann auch hinausläuft. Während ich mit der Verfügung Gewalt über die Arbeitskraft einen konstitutiven Aspekt kapitalistischer Herrschaft in Frage stelle, greife ich auch konkrete Ansatzpunkte für eine Neuordnung von Arbeit auf. Nur wenn das Gemeinwohlauschlaggebend für die Art und Weise wird, wie Arbeit verausgabt wird, so die Essenz meines Plädoyers, ist ein progressiver Ausweg aus unseren von multiplen Krisen gekennzeichneten Gesellschaft denkbar. Dieses Buch stellt sich also eine große Aufgabe. In dem Moment, wo menschliche Arbeitskraft knapp wird, möchte er sie gleichzeitig noch, obwohl der kapitalistische Kampf um sie so groß ist, sie genau aus dem kapitalistischen Kampf herauslösen.
Richtig.
Und ich finde aber die Argumentation dahin, wäre sehr viel klüger, wenn er sagen würde, weil die KI so clever ist, die kapitalistischen Aufgaben zu erfüllen, können wir uns das leisten, die menschliche Arbeitskraft jetzt neu zu verurteilen. Aber genau das macht er nicht. Sondern wir lesen jetzt ein Buch, in dem die KI nochmal sozusagen...
Das wäre die Theorie, die du vorgeführt hast mit dem Philosophen Ule?
Genau, ganz genau.
Die du jetzt vorgeschlagen hättest, zu sagen, die KI löst jetzt also Aufgaben, die früher die Menschen machen mussten. Das war die kapitalistische Verwertbarkeit dort. Jetzt haben die Menschen mehr Zeit für anderes. Also auch für sinnvollere gesellschaftliche Aufgaben, die da wären im Nahbereich vor allem. Ja, das meint sowohl Gastronomie wie Arbeit am Patienten, Arbeit mit anderen Menschen zusammen in Sachen Bildung, was auch immer. Er sagt, ja, so einfach sei das nicht. Also das ist durchaus ein Schritt, den er begrüßen würde. Aber er bezweifelt sehr, dass die KI das tatsächlich umsetzen wird. Wenn wir uns jetzt mit diesem Buch beschäftigen, müssen wir erst einmal diese Diagnosen ernst nehmen, die aufgestellt werden, die, glaube ich, bei den meisten Leuten nicht so präsent sind, nämlich dass hier ein Autor sehr gut mit Zahlen belegen kann, dass wir es nicht mit der Situation zu tun haben, dass wir jetzt bald eine große Arbeitslosigkeit erleben. Das ist etwas, dem er widerspricht. Wenn man sich sehr viele Tech-Podcasts anhört, dann wird man laufend hören, bald sind sowieso ein Großteil arbeitslos. Wahrscheinlich brauchen wir deshalb schon ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, um das irgendwie zu kompensieren. Das ist ja auch etwas, was im Silicon Valley sehr vorangetragen wird. Und jetzt gibt es selbstverständlich Branchen, die platt gemacht werden von der KI. Das wird definitiv der Fall sein. Aber Butollo sagt, im Ganzen werden die Arbeitskräfte knapp und sie werden immer noch viel knapper werden. Er geht dann verschiedene Modellierungen durch, die es gibt für die kommenden Jahre und Jahrzehnte. Da würde einem Angst und Bange. Das heißt also, wer reich ist und sich schon immer mal Personal leisten wollte, könnte in den folgenden Jahren Schwierigkeiten bekommen, um das schon mal vorwegzunehmen. Und das ist ja erstmal eine Diagnose, die ganz dem widerspricht, was wir zum Beispiel jahrelang von Richard-David-Precht gehört haben.
Genau, er nennt ja konkret die LKW-Fahrer.
Der sagte, da sieht man es deutlich, er beginnt ja folgendermaßen, einer breitrezipierten Studie zufolge werden Fernfahrerinnen bald durch fahrerlose LKWs ersetzt. Parallel dazu liest man von einem quasi leergefägten LKW- und Busfahrermarkt. Etwa 80.000 Fernfahrerinnen sollen derzeit in Deutschland fehlen, sodass laut dem Bundesverband Spedition und Logistik die Grundversorgung im Transportwesen mittlerweile ernsthaft gefährdet ist. Mit diesem Widerspruch steigt er ein. Er hat dann einen ähnlichen Widerspruch aufzudecken, bei den Verwaltungsangestellten, wo man auch sagt, bald werden die ersetzt werden. Sagt er aber, ja, momentan oder beziehungsweise bis 2030 rechnet man damit, dass 200.000 Angestellte in der Verwaltung fehlen werden.
Ja. Hier, also er hat Recht. Und man muss trotzdem anmerken, der LKW-Fahrer ist ja so ein spezifischer Fall, weil eine Person, also das ist ja schon hochgradig automatisiert im Sinne von, es ist nur noch ein Fahrer, der aber 40 Tonnen bewegt. So, es ist ja nicht mehr 40 Leute und dann jeder eine Tonne, sondern man schafft schon eine pro 40 Tonne. Und der letzte Schritt ist jetzt, in dieser Automatisierungsgeschichte den letzten übrig gebliebenen pro 40 Tonnen auch noch rauszubringen. Und das ist eine ganz oder gar nicht Sache. Während ich bei Bürojobs einen ganz graduellen Einfall von KI in die Arbeitswelt habe. Also da wird nicht sozusagen der eine an seinem eigenen Computer einfach ausgetauscht, sondern so ganz langsam, kann auch zehn Jahre dauern, shiftet das, bis man dann feststellt, also das, was einer heute schafft, haben vorher 17 Leute gemacht. Von da ist der LKW-Fahrer, da wir ja in Deutschland sowieso schon so eine krass hochgradig automatisierte Fertigung und Transportwesen haben, ist nicht so das beste Beispiel dafür, finde ich.
Jedoch kann man am Fernfahrer ja sehr gut ablesen, wie sich die Gesellschaft auch verändert hat, deshalb, weil wir heute mehr Pakete denn je uns zustellen lassen. Also wir haben in den 90er Jahren Phänomene gehabt, da haben die Leute Quelle und Neckermann-Katalogie gehabt und haben sich in Gruppen zusammengetan und haben Sammelbestellungen aufgegeben, damit sie Versandkosten sparen. Wenn ich dir heute sagen würde, lass uns das gemeinsam bei Amazon bestellen, dann sparen wir irgendwas, dann würdest du sagen, ob ich verrückt geworden bin. Geschweige denn mit irgendwelchen Leuten aus der Nachbarschaft noch. Und dann bekam man einmal im Monat das Paket und das war dann der große Jubel, dann drehte der halbe Häuserplock durch.
Für Amazon ist das ja eine Sammelbestellung, weil die, wenn die hier ins Bahnhofsviertel fahren, in unseren Paket bringen, in derselben Straße, im Umkreis von 50 Metern.
Richtig. Aber das bedeutet, dass alles laufend auf der Straße ist, weil wir jederzeit irgendetwas bestellen, was wir uns liefern lassen und früher war, ich habe mir da mal was bei Quelle bestellt, das soll nächste Woche kommen. Und jetzt ist einfach so, es klingen fünfmal am Tag und irgendjemand bringt was.
Und da muss man sagen, es gibt Automatisierung, die sehen wir schon gar nicht mehr, wie zum Beispiel diese Sammelbestellung, die jetzt einfach so läuft.
Die aber zugleich dafür sorgt, und wir sprechen heute viel über den Rebound-Effekt, dass mehr gefahren werden muss, denn je. Ja, beziehungsweise ist es nicht weniger geworden, wie man ja vermuten könnte, dass man sagt, ah ja, jetzt wird das alles automatisiert. Ja, es wird ganz viel automatisiert, aber die Automatisierung macht es dann erst möglich, dass ich mir jetzt für 12 Euro was bei Amazon bestelle und es kommt versandkostenfrei hier an.
Ja, also unsere Gesellschaft ist eine Informationsgesellschaft, die alle Papierproduktionen europaweit mittlerweile von Zeitungspapier auf Verpackungsmaterialen umgestellt hat, um uns elektronische Geräte nach Hause zu schicken, die uns dann Informationen anzeigen. Ja, das stimmt, diese Pornen stecken überall drin. Er macht diesen großen Bogenschlag, du hast es ja schon angesprochen, Marx Maschinenfragment 1860, 1930er Jahre, Kien, Technologische Arbeitslosigkeit, also im Begriff steckt es im Grunde drin, 70er, dann eher historisch gedacht, die Roboter kommen, Neunziger, die Computer kommen, also kurzes Zeitalter, wir haben es ja bei Ule auch, und dann 2010er Künstliche Intelligenz. Was mir immer wieder auffällt, ist, dass gerade Professoren, die typischerweise mit einem Sekretariat arbeiten, also die nicht so diesen Handlungsdruck haben, Bürosachen zu automatisieren, dass die noch nicht so richtig, ich erlebe das bei meinen eigenen Professoren, mit denen ich noch in Kontakt bin, dass sie es nicht so richtig wahrnehmen, was eigentlich passiert.
Ja.
Auch nicht wie sehr ihre eigene Büro-Mitarbeiterinnen Sachen schon automatisieren. Sondern für die ist halt Inbox Outbox. So, und dann legt man Sachen hin und dann kommen die bearbeitet zurück. Das machen wir normalerweise ja mittlerweile auch, nur halt ohne den Schritt, dass wir es der Sekretärin auf den Tisch legen, sondern wir tun es direkt in die Inbox, die das dann verarbeitet. So, und ich möchte auch schon mal vorweggreifen, der Papst wird, also Franziskus schon, ja, letztes Jahr, wird in seinem hohen Alter nochmal anerkennend sagen, dass Menschen Götzen anbeten ist nicht neu, aber dass die Götzen reden, das ist neu. Also der Papst sieht hier eine Unterscheidung, die Butollo und viele andere deutsche Professoren nicht sehen, wenn sie einfach eine historische Linie von, naja, es gab ja immer Automatisierung und jetzt ist halt einfach nur eine weitere Automatisierung.
Ich will ja schon aber ihm rechtsgebend zu sagen, wir hatten immer diese Debatten, jetzt wird alles anders. Und dabei zeigt sich dann, ja, es wird auch tatsächlich sehr viel anders. Und ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass das Buch leugnet, wie disruptiv die KI sein kann. Aber was tatsächlich in Frage gestellt wird, ist, dass dadurch generell Arbeit gemacht wird und zugleich nicht neue Arbeit dazukommt, die wieder den Menschen erfordert. Das ist ja die These, die er hat, um das zu vervollständigen, weil manche jetzt sich denken werden, aber was reden die denn da? Ja, Arbeitslosigkeit ist zugleich ein Problem. Wir werden über Mismatch auch reden. Also wenn Arbeitskräfte und Arbeitsplätze nicht zusammengehen, so ist auch hier gleich auf Seite 9 zu lesen. Seit Anfang 2024 sind monatlich mehr als 10.000 Industriearbeitsplätze abgebaut worden. Ein Verlust der Technologieführerschaft in Schlüsselbereichen der deutschen Industrie ist möglich. Das heißt, diese Art der Deindustrialisierung kann durchaus weiter fortschreiten. Da sehen wir schon, es werden Leute plötzlich wieder auf den Arbeitsmarkt gebracht, die jetzt sich Arbeit suchen sollen, die aber nicht in ihren Bereichen eine Anschlussverwendung finden können, von denen man aber auch jetzt nicht einfach sagen kann, naja, dann werden die jetzt Pfleger. Denn so einfach ist das nicht. Und das hängt auch mit regionalen Bezügen zusammen. Wo war das Unternehmen, das geschlossen hat? Mit ganz vielen anderen Dingen. Das heißt, beides geht. Wir haben ja diese Debatte hier eigentlich seit Beginn des Podcasts. Haben wir einen Fachkräftemangel oder nicht? Maurice hat ja immer wieder in seinen Videos deutlich gemacht, wir haben gar keinen Arbeitskräfte- und Fachkräftemangel und hat ja auch immer sehr stark auf die Arbeitslosenzahlen verwiesen.
Das ist aber auch schon länger her, da hat er es oben geschwenkt haben.
Du warst da ja sowieso immer sehr skeptisch. Und hier bekommen wir auch nochmal gesagt, ja, es gibt über eine Million Menschen, die sind langzeitarbeitslos, das heißt länger als ein Jahr arbeitslos. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass die dort matchen, wo man sie benötigt. Zudem gibt es sehr viele Felder, die jetzt gerade neu entstehen, also Problemfelder, wo Leute gebraucht werden. Und auch da sind die Arbeitskräfte nicht zu sehen.
Genau. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, eine Million, dann muss man einfach sagen, ja, das ist so ungefähr der Wert. Und das sind halt bei 43, 44, 45 Millionen Beschäftigten so ungefähr zwei, drei Prozent. Das heißt, in Sachen Ausbeutung von Erwerbspersonenpotenzial sind wir schon ziemlich Weltspitze. Also jetzt noch aus dem letzten Prozent was rauszuquetschen, da wird es halt auch therapeutisch, sage ich mal. Also da gilt, was er später dann im Buch sehr ausführlich, wir werden sehr ausführlich behandeln. Es gibt einen Rebound bei diesen Berufen am Menschen. Weil die sind da einfach erforderlich. Wir haben ja diese eine Zahl. Wie kriegt man die Needs in den Arbeitsmarkt? Naja, ein Jahr eins zu eins betreut. Und dann 40 Jahre Sozialkasse Input. Aber wenn man das ein Jahr nicht investiert, ist halt nicht. Und er beschreibt ja dieses Phänomen, um Arbeit zu haben, muss man Arbeit investieren. Arbeit muss Arbeit erzeugen. Er macht das hier. Er schreibt, Wer das Verhältnis von technischem Wandel und Arbeitsmarkt verstehen will, darf also nicht nur damit, sich nicht nur damit befassen, welche Arbeit verschwindet, sondern man muss in den Blick nehmen, wo und warum Arbeit neu entsteht. Wenn also ein ganzer Bürokomplex auf elektrische Sonnenenergie umstellt, damit die da mehr arbeiten können, muss jemand die Photovoltaikanlage da oben installieren. Und genauso haben wir eben völlig neue Berufe. Er nennt sogar die Influencer, wo man sich sagen muss, Anna, ein Glück hat er sie jetzt nicht dispektierlich übergangen oder so, sondern Selbstunterhaltung ist ein relevanter Beruf. Auch wenn wir uns selber andere wünschen. Und dann kommt seine Fragestellung. Damit ist das Problem umrissen, von dem dieses Buch handelt. Es soll ergründen, warum trotz Jahrzehnten, ja eigentlich Jahrhunderten der Automatisierung, eher mehr Arbeit entsteht, als dass das Arbeitsvolumen abnimmt. Da würde ich sagen, hier könnte man jetzt wirklich noch einmal all in Marx diesen Entwicklungsstufen reingehen. Hallelein nicht gemacht.
Marx spricht ja vom Werwolfsheißhunger nach Mehrarbeit. Um zu sagen, da sagt dir nicht der Unternehmer wunderbar, dann macht er alle um 14 Uhr Schluss. Sondern sagt er, hm, könnte noch eine Stunde länger arbeiten, wenn das so gut läuft.
Und mit dem Warenfetisch evoluieren eben auch Bedürfnisse. Also nicht nur die Produkte.
Bei Branko Milanovic haben wir das gelesen, dieser auch abstrakte Hedonismus. Man hat eigentlich schon lange genug, aber es wäre doch schön, noch ein bisschen mehr zu haben.
Die gängigen Erklärungen dieser Beobachtungen sind unzureichend, denn sie enden meist in einer Art, und jetzt kommt ein Zauberwort, Fatalismus. Die Automatisierung werde schon nicht zu Massenarbeitslosigkeit führen, so das Argument, weil ja immer neue Arbeit entsteht, schließlich sei das bisher stets so gewesen. Er hat es jetzt also als Phänomen markiert und sagt aber selber, das ist Fatalismus und zwar in beide Richtungen. Also zum einen zu sagen, die KI fressen die Jobs, als auch zu sagen, naja, die Automatisierung bringt schon irgendwie neue Arbeit mit. Denn beides führt uns ja in eine ungewisse Zukunft. Man muss auf jeden Fall hier jetzt politisch drüber nachdenken. Und man muss vor allem investieren. Also hier ist Steuerungsbedarf.
Neben dem Investieren geht es wirklich um Steuerung. Er spricht ja von Reallokation von Arbeit. Das heißt, Arbeit muss anders verteilt werden. Das heißt, es muss politisch entschieden werden, was ist relevanter und was ist weniger relevant. Das den Marktkräften alleine zu überlassen, wäre falsch. Das ist ein ganz, also weil du am Anfang gefragt hast, steht der in der Tradition von Marx oder ist er jemand, der marxistisch operiert? Dann würde ich sagen, ja, mit so etwas auf jeden Fall.
Also er fordert hier planwirtschaftliche Eingreife in den Lauf der Dinge. Das sind die Pointen, auf die dieses Buch hinauslaufen wird. Da würde ich auch sagen, ja, also zwingend. Denn wir können jetzt nicht alle einfach nur KI-Rechenzentren bauen, weil irgendein Milliardär eine Hoffnung hat, dass irgendein Publikum später mal irgendeinen Bedarf hat oder so. Also das läuft ja mittlerweile alles.
Und 300 Euro fürs Abo im Monat zahlt oder so.
Das läuft ja drunter und drüber.
Das Buch ist jedenfalls, auch wenn du jetzt gleich einige Widersprüche anmelden wirst, was ja auch richtig ist. Ich habe auch das eine oder andere. Es ist, finde ich, sehr gut strukturiert in seiner Art, wie es aufgebaut ist. Es fängt damit an, dass gefragt wird, warum überhaupt neue Arbeit entsteht? Das ist das erste Kapitel. Da wird gesagt, ja, kapitalistisches Wirtschaften muss sowohl von der rationalisierenden Seite gesehen werden. Das heißt, man versucht, Prozesse zu beschleunigen und effizienter zu gestalten. Zugleich muss man aber auch die expansive Seite des Kapitalismus betrachten. Um ein einfaches Beispiel zu wählen, das auch später im Buch kommt, hätte man sich an Henry Ford gehalten und hätte Autos einfach immer nur optimiert im den Sinne, wir machen das Auto von Ford effizienter, dann hätte man sagen können, ja klar, man braucht jetzt nur noch die Hälfte der Zeit oder ein Viertel der Zeit, um ein Auto zu produzieren. Ja, es gibt den Spruch, den er zitiert von Ford, wir können Autos in jeder Farbe liefern, solange es schwarz ist. Ja, also hätte man sich quasi an diese Reduktion gehalten, der Produktion, dann könnte man natürlich optimieren, aber da ja das nicht statisch zu sehen ist, geht es natürlich um eine große Ausdifferenzierung, die damit dann ja geht und auch um eine expansive Seite, dass man sagt, wir versuchen in diesen Markt noch zu drängen, versuchen das noch zu erreichen. Das heißt, diese Rationalisierung ist das eine zugleiche, aber gibt es immer eine Expandierung, bedeutet auch Produkte und Gesellschaften erlebene Ausdifferenzierung und damit eine einhergehende Komplexitätssteigerung. Und worum es ihm dann geht, ist die Rebound-Effekte der Automatisierung zu beleuchten. Das entlehnt er eigentlich aus der ökologischen Debatte, nämlich zu fragen ist ja, wenn wir Energie sparen können, sparen wir dann wirklich Energie oder sagen wir, ach, das ist ja gut, dass die so günstig ist. Jetzt kann ich den Strom ja noch viel mehr nutzen, weil er fast nichts mehr kostet. Er bringt das Beispiel LED-Beleuchtung, dass man mit dieser Technik sehr kostensparsam arbeiten kann.
Aber man macht hundertmal mehr Lichter an.
Ja, man macht überall Lämpchen an und alles muss jetzt leuchten. Oder was ja auch ein interessantes Phänomen ist, dass man jetzt sehr viele LED-Leuchten kaufen kann. Also Lampen kaufen kann, wo die LED-Leuchten schon drin sind. Man kann sie gar nicht mehr auswechseln. Man muss also dann die ganze Lampe wegwerfen, wenn es dann nicht mehr funktioniert. Was er jetzt als Beispiel für einen Rebound-Effekt bringt, ist, wenn wir über die Vollerwerbsgesellschaft reden. Denn wir wissen, alle Parteien, nenne ich alle Parteien, aber sehr stark SPD und Union, wollen ja, dass weniger Teilzeit gearbeitet wird. Die Grünen auch im Prinzip wollen es fast alle. Das heißt, man möchte eigentlich hin zu einer Vollerwerbsgesellschaft. Das hat aber dann zur Folge, dass man sich ja fragen muss, momentan sind die Leute ja nicht einfach so gerne zu Hause und liegen auf der Couch rum und arbeiten deshalb Teilzeit, sondern die leisten ja Sorgearbeit. Wenn jetzt alle eine Vollerwerbsarbeitzeit hätten, dann würde das bedeuten, wer macht die Sorgearbeit dafür? Gut wäre, man könnte sich dann jemanden leisten, der sich um die Sorgearbeit kümmert. Das heißt, Kitas sind länger geöffnet, man hat möglicherweise jemanden im Haushalt, der hilft und andere Annehmlichkeiten, damit man die Vollerwerbszeit ausnutzen kann. Damit braucht man aber wieder Arbeitskräfte, die da einspringen und so ist also die Vollerwerbsgesellschaft zugleich eine, die auch wieder den Arbeitskräftemangel verschärfen kann.
Gut, bevor wir die Rebound-Effekte einzeln durchgehen und da kommen wir zu dieser Sorgearbeit, die sich eben nicht so gut automatisieren lässt, ausführlich zu sprechen, hat er in der Einleitung noch eine These formuliert, die wir diskutieren müssen, also die ich dir jetzt sozusagen vorlege und du machst dann ein Marxistisch aufgeklärtes, denn wir haben ja zum einen eine Marxistische Idee und dann eine Realität. Und da wir zur sehr guten Marxistischen Theorie hier 250 Jahre Praxis und Empirie haben, kann man ja durchaus mal darüber diskutieren, wie er das hier schreibt. Denn die Demografie kriegt ihr eigenes Kapitel, aber hier in der Einleitung fügt er sich schon mal an. Wir haben einen Fachkräftemangel, einen demografischen Vorzeichenwechsel. Ich kann dir mal vorlesen, wie er das schreibt. Wir kennen es natürlich. Aktuelle Erscheinungen des Fachkräftemangels, so die im Folgenden entfaltete These, sind nur die Vorboten einer Entwicklung. Also das, was wir sehen, die Renten, die Boomer, also das sind noch nicht die großen Jahrgänger. 2029, der große Jahrgang geht an den Renten. Das heißt, noch sehen wir nur die Vorboten, die sich angesichts des demografischen Wandels drastisch verschärfen werden. Die Personalangpässe der Gegenwart sind noch nicht einmal Ausdruck dieser demografischen Verschiebung. Da würde ich gern sagen, ich habe jetzt auch viel über Demografie gesprochen. Ich mache es auch immer sehr drastisch und alarmistisch. So deutlich wie bei ihm selten gelesen, also finde ich sehr gut. Und dann leitet er aus folgende These ab. Anders als oft angenommen, verfügen Beschäftigte damit heute auch über eine gestiegene Marktmacht, die zwar nicht unmittelbar Verbesserungen bewirkt, aber wesentlich günstigere Bedingungen für eine Aufwertung der Arbeit bietet, als dies in den Jahrzehnten des Arbeitskräfteüberschusses der Fall war. Diese Deutung widerspricht Diagnosen einer langfristigen Erosion der Beschäftigtenmacht und einstigen Erzählungen eines sozialen Abstiegs des Lohnarbeiters. Haben wir also mit dem Vorzeichenwechsel in der Demografie einen Vorzeichenwechsel im Arbeitskampf?
Das ist eines der größten Rätsel. Mich beschäftigt das auch schon eine Weile, diese Frage. Denn es ist ja vollkommen klar, wenn Leute fehlen, dann sind die, die noch da sind, in einer machtvolleren Position. Wenn man ein großes Heer von Arbeitslosen hat, kann der Arbeitgeber quasi signalisieren, du willst mehr Lohn? Nein, bekommst du nicht. Werd hier nicht rebellisch? Guck mal da draußen, stehen schon zehn vor der Tür, die würden gerne kommen.
Die Reserve-Armee.
Interessanterweise führt das aber momentan nicht dazu, dass die Löhne steigen. Die Löhne steigen etwas, das will ich jetzt nicht leugnen und die Gewerkschaften erringen auch. Und die Inflation steigt mehr. Aber die Inflation steigt mehr, sodass wir dann sagen, jetzt haben wir vielleicht mal wieder so die Reallöhne wie 2019. Also eigentlich, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, Angebot und Nachfrage, da muss man noch gar nicht bis hin zu Marx gehen, müsste doch klar sein, dass jetzt die Löhne entsprechend steigen. Was wir vielleicht erleben, ist, dass die Mentalität sich etwas ändert. Und zwar ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass wir relativ hohe Krankheitstage in Deutschland haben. Es ist ja auch tatsächlich so, dass viele Leute für sich in Anspruch nehmen würden, dass es nicht nur so eine LinkedIn-Community, sondern generell zu sagen, ich bin mir jetzt mal gerade wichtiger als mein Arbeitgeber und so etwas, dass diese Mentalität, die da entsteht, durchaus auch auf der Grundlage entstehen kann, dass man weiß, naja, so einfach bin ich ja gar nicht mehr ersetzbar. Aber da wir so eine starke Granularisierung haben, in der Weise, dass wir nicht mehr starke große Gewerkschaften haben und nicht eine Arbeiterpartei SPD haben, also so eine breite Sozialdemokratie, organisiert sich das nicht. Das heißt, es gibt so einen individualistischen Klassenkampf mitunter bei Leuten, die vielleicht sagen, morgen gehe ich mal nicht, morgen ist blauer Montag. Ich nehme mir das jetzt einfach mal raus, dass das wahrscheinlich als Phänomen sogar zunehmen könnte oder zugenommen hat. Es ist sehr schwer, das jetzt zu bemessen. Diese ganze Quite-Quitting-Debatte ist natürlich auch ideologisch von Konservativen sehr überformt worden. Mag sein, aber im Ganzen können wir das noch nicht sehen, obwohl eigentlich, und da hat der Butollo ja völlig recht, die Grundlage besser ist, als sagen wir vor 20 Jahren oder vor 25 Jahren, als wir Agenda 2010 und all das hatten. Da gab es ja eine hohe Sockel-Arbeitslosigkeit, die dann auch dazu führte, dass die Leute diese Gängelung erstmal hinnehmen mussten, denn die Alternative war die Arbeitslosigkeit. Heute sieht es anders aus. Ich sehe es tatsächlich noch nicht so richtig. Vielleicht auch. Wir haben das Phänomen hier mal behandelt. Ich weiß, meine Antwort ist lang, aber ich will trotzdem noch sagen, dass man mitunter denkt, dass Unternehmer selbst gar nicht so richtig wissen, wie man unternehmerisch handelt. Nämlich, dass man zum Beispiel sagt, okay, es scheint wohl jetzt drei Euro mehr zu kosten, wenn ich jemanden in der Gastronomie haben will. Aber es ist doch besser, jemanden in der Gastronomie noch mehr zu haben, weil ich dann mehr Getränke verkaufe. Ein letztes Beispiel dafür. Ich war mit Ole, Lensy und noch einem Bekannten in Hamburg nach unserer Show. Wir sind in ein Hotel gegangen, ein Vier-Stern-Hotel mit einem großen Bar und einem großen Café voran. Freitagabend. In dieser Bar 40 Gäste, ein Barkeeper, mehr nicht. Keine Chance, noch etwas zu trinken zu bekommen. Dann gehen wir nach vorne in diese Lounge, wo es auch Getränke gab. Alles voll. Es gab noch einen freien Platz. Da sind wir hin. Dann sagte man uns, es war 11.20 Uhr, letzte Runde. Weil kein Personal dann dafür da ist. Und dann denke ich mir, das kann sich ja niemals rechnen. Selbst wenn die den Leuten das Doppelte zahlen würden, ist das ja bei, du weißt ja, wie Hotelpreise sind, wenn du da ein Glas Cocktail oder ein Glas Champagner bestellst, was da dann ausgegeben wird. Es ist unternehmerische Dummheit auch.
Also ja, vielleicht hat sich der Unternehmer auch viele Mühen gemacht. Steht aber, wie Butollo schreibt, vor einem epochalen Folgen des Arbeitskräftemangels, der eben nicht einfach abzufedern ist. Da es für seine Finale dann so entscheidend ist, lese ich mal seinen Wunschdenken vor, denn ich sehe es ein bisschen kritischer als du. Ich glaube doch, dass wir hatten im Silicon Rally in der Fernsehserie, diese Pointe wird schon in Folge 1 abgehandelt, mehr habe ich da nicht geguckt, dass sich dort die Mitarbeiter immer auf dem Dach treffen, weil sie gerade nichts zu tun haben und sie stellen alle fest, wir werden ja eigentlich nur vom Markt weggekauft, so als Softwareentwickler, also Reservearmee in-Haus, weil sie es die Unternehmen leisten können. Während wir jetzt aber gerade erleben, dass die KI-Unternehmen doch oder die Softwareunternehmen sehr viele Leute entlassen, die sich mit Software auskennen und jetzt gerade wieder Versuche machen, die doch wieder einzustellen. Also es ist eine völlige Unbestimmtheit, was eigentlich gerade so gängige Managementmethode ist und Butollo schreibt, Auf Grundlage aktueller Arbeitsmarktprognosen argumentiere ich, dass es Anzeichen für eine Entwicklung in Richtung eines Arbeitskräfte-Arbeitsmarkts gibt. Damit ist gemeint, die Arbeitnehmer bestimmen jetzt, indem die Arbeiter von Arbeitskraft mehr Gestaltungsmacht für die Kondition der Arbeit bekommen, wenngleich diese Machtposition in verschiedenen Feldern der Arbeitswelt unterschiedlich ausgeprägt ist. Bei solchen Sachen wünsche ich mir, und das ist hier nicht das erste Mal, es wird im Buch auch noch ein großes Problem, Empirie. Dann muss man sich die Mühe machen, abgesichert durch einen Lehrstuhl zu sagen, ich gehe jetzt in die empirische Analyse. So, wir haben es hier jetzt einfach nur mit Studien aus dem Bücherschrank zu tun. Und darunter leitet das Buch sehr, muss ich sagen. Denn er wirft ja genau die Frage auf, von der wir denken, wenn du die jetzt nicht beantwortest, wer sonst? Also dafür haben wir das Universitätssystem mit Forschung und Lehre in Deutschland. Und dann können wir jetzt hier nach der Etablierung seine Einleitung in diesen ersten großen Blog, der zweite ist ja dann zur Demografie und zur KI, aber diese Rebound-Effekte. Er ist sehr ausführlich. Ich weiß nicht, das hätte man pointierter schreiben können. So insgesamt, würde ich sagen. Das Buch ist jetzt sowieso nicht sehr ausufernd, aber gut. Der erste Rebound-Effekt der Automatisierung. Das Umweltbundesamt definiert den Rebound-Effekt als Differenz zwischen der theoretischen, zu erwartenden Einsparung durch eine Effizienzmaßnahme und der tatsächlichen Einsparung. Das Umweltbundesamt ist da sehr präzise und sagt, Rebound-Effekte sind, wenn durch die Effizienzmaßnahme verursacht und nicht nur parallel läuft. Beispiel, dass die Autos einfach größer werden. Also man macht den Motor effizienter. Und weil die Motoren ja effizienter sind, baut man das Auto größer. Und plötzlich ist man doch nicht beim 3 Liter Auto. Er möchte das als Idee übertragen auf alle möglichen Formen der Automatisierung oder sonstiger Effizienzsteigerung, dass sie im Schlepptau immer diesen Rebound mitbringen. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist erstmal nicht verkehrt. Er macht das dann in verschiedenen Stufen.
Erlebst du das, würde ich jetzt gleich mal fragen wollen, nicht auch bei dir. Du hast jetzt immer schon mit viel Elan dich mit technischen Dingen beschäftigt, du hast auch selbst dafür gesorgt, dass du eine Homepage hast. Aber du merkst doch jetzt auch bei dir einen Rebound-Effekt, dass du sagst, ach so, es ist ja nicht so, dass du auf deinem Stand der Homepage von 2017 stehst und sagst, toll, das kann ich jetzt mit KI machen. Sondern du beschäftigst dich jetzt intensiv, sogar intensiver vermutlich damit, die Homepage zu optimieren oder eine Präsentation zu optimieren. Du hast mir heute, bevor wir aufgezeichnet haben, eine neue Präsentation von dir gezeigt, was du damit Daten verschieben kannst. Da war einfach vor Jahren nicht dran zu denken. Bedeutet aber auch, du musst viele Stunden jetzt damit schon zubringen, um eine solche Präsentation herzustellen, während du die alte Präsentation, wie du sie vor sechs Jahren gehalten hättest, heute sicherlich per Knopfdruck in, sagen wir, eine halbe Stunde machen könntest.
Genau. Also ich habe Wolfgang eine Präsentation gezeigt, in der den Vortrag habe ich gestern Abend gehalten, während wir heute Morgen Salon machen. Also ich hatte quasi nur eine kurze Nacht, um beides abzuhandeln, was sehr viel Arbeitslast für diesen Moment bedeutet. Und trotzdem ist die Präsentation, also man hätte sie nicht raffinierter machen können. Ich konnte live das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial über die Demografie einfach hinwegschieben per Slider in meiner Präsentation. Und es wurden pro Jahr, die ich das verschoben habe, live die Sterbefälle in die Demografie eingerechnet und das Verhältnis aus Beschäftigung und Rentnern durchgerechnet. Das ist eine visuelle Raffinesse, die man live anwenden kann, die das Statistische Bundesamt noch nicht kann. Aber ich mit Klo schon.
So. Und das zeigt ja Komplexitätszunahme.
Genau, das zeigt extreme Komplexitätszunahme. Jetzt würde Butollo sagen, ja, aber das erfordert ja auch dann doch. Also klar, die Präsentation ist hundertmal raffinierter. Und das geht mit mehr Arbeit einher. Aber, und jetzt will ich es kurz beschreiben. Ich bin ja hier in einem Büro, in dem sehr wenige Menschen sehr viel mit KI machen. Und ich habe ja ein Tischnachbar, Human, den ich immer wieder bremse. Also wir sind in der Sache ganz unterschiedlich, dass wenn OpenClaw veröffentlicht wird, installiert sich das Human sofort. Und ich denke erst drüber nach, kann es irgendein Problem, das ich habe, lösen oder ist es nur eine Spielerei? Und ich stelle nach drei Sekunden fest, es ist eine Spielerei. Ich arbeite mit MCP-fähigen N8N Workflows, auch wenn alle sagen, das ist doch schon wieder outdated und steuer die mit Claude. Ich kann also für mich sagen, da ich auch sehr viel drüber nachgedacht habe, wie ich das organisiere, ich habe jetzt endlich wieder mehr Freiheit, mehr Zeit. Ich kann mehr lesen, ich kann mir mehr Gedanken machen. Wir kommen nachher auf das Problem des Infermezzos zu sprechen. Das ist ein ganz konkretes Problem, mit dem man zu tun hat. Aber ich führe tatsächlich ein entspannteres Leben als vorher. Schon allein, weil meine Skripte, die mir Claude hilft, für die Bücher zu erstellen, sehr viel übersichtlicher sind, weil ich sehr viel mehr Raffinesse da reinbringe, ohne dass es mehr Arbeit bedeutet. Also ich habe sozusagen ein bisschen gemanagt.
Das würde ja Butollo gar nicht leugnen, dass das geht und wir alle werden das in der einen oder anderen Weise ja feststellen. Nur bist du ja nicht in einem direkten Konkurrenzverhältnis.
Genau. Ich kann das mit Claude alleine klären und es gibt jetzt...
Deine Hauptaufgabe wäre, nur Präsentationen zu gestalten, gar nicht Vorträge zu halten. Also du wirst ja gebucht, weil du Stefan Schulz bist und nicht, weil man sagt, das ist der PowerPoint-Experte oder so. Wenn du aber jetzt derjenige wärst, der einfach nur Präsentationen für andere erstellt, dann müsstest du jetzt sehen, dass du in diesem Konkurrenzkampf durchhältst, weil jetzt hast du vielleicht gerade den Vorsprung, dass du mit Slides arbeiten kannst, die so noch keiner kann oder kaum einer kann. In drei Monaten sieht das möglicherweise schon anders aus. Dann musst du sehen, was du dann wieder dir drauf schaffen musst.
Genau. Ich bin in keiner Verantwortung, billable hours abzurechnen. Und die Gefahr haben wir beim letzten Mal betont, dass diese Anwälte jetzt gar keine ruhigen Momente mehr haben, sondern nur noch im Kundenkontakt überhaupt Rechnung stellen dürfen. Und von daher, ja, das Buch beschreibt es genau richtig. Er erweitert ja diesen Rebound die Definition noch mal in seinem Sinne. Also im Gegensatz zur Interpretation des Umweltbundesamts schreibt er, gehe ich daher im Folgenden von der These aus, dass Rebound-Effekte nicht primär durch die Wirkungen der Technik selbst bedingt sind, sondern durch die Einbettung in einen spezifischen, ökonomischen und gesellschaftlichen Kontext. Was bedeutet? Diesen ökonomischen und gesellschaftlichen Kontext habe ich nicht, weil ich kein Management über mir habe, das sagt, also jetzt wo wir gesehen haben, wie gut du Salons vorbereiten kannst, mach den doch jede Woche statt nur einmal im Monat. So, aber ich weiß natürlich, dass die Arbeitswelt jenseits meiner Bürotätigkeit genauso funktioniert. Von daher hat das Buch voll recht. Aber da du mich gefragt hattest, wollte ich sagen, ich habe mir meinen Freiraum erkämpft.
Und das ist ja ganz wichtig, dass man das immer unterscheiden kann zwischen den individuellen Anforderungen, die man erfüllen kann dadurch und denen, die vom System abverlangt werden. Es geht auch um die Innovationswettläufe. Die sind ja auch oft nicht linear. Er verweist auf das Handy. Da gab es lange Zeit einen Wettbewerb. Wer kann das kleinste Handy produzieren? Dann kommt das Smartphone auf und plötzlich geht es zwar auch noch um Größe, dass man nicht den Laptop in der Tasche mit sich herumträgt. Vor allem aber geht es ja darum, dass man eine Komplexitätssteigerung erfährt. Dass das Smartphone plötzlich ein Computer sein soll, der alles kann, so gut wie mein Computer oder sogar besser. Er schreibt über diese Open Innovation. Es steht auch dafür, dass Innovationssysteme zu komplex und vielschichtig geworden sind, um sie unter dem Dach eines Unternehmens zu bewerkstelligen. Du hast das Buch hier mal vorgestellt, Apple in China. Ich lese das gerade. Das ist genau das. Ja, dass die Ideen da sind, aber wer setzt sie alle um und wo findet man die Leute?
Eine Million Menschen in China, genau.
Es ist unglaublich, das zu lesen. Ähnliche Beispiele dafür wie Wettläufe, um Neuerungen im Zusammenspiel mit der Digitalisierung an Fahrt aufnehmen und aufwendiger werden, ließen sich viele anführen. Die Entwicklung der Modeindustrie zur Fast Fashion und jüngst zur Ultra Fast Fashion basiert auf einem Wechselspiel von Influencerinnen, Personalisierter Werbung und dezentralen, enorm responsiven Produktionssystemen. Auch hier werden umfassende Ressourcen an Kommunikation, Kreativität, Produktions- und Marketingarbeit und nicht zuletzt Rohstoffen ins Feld geführt, um in der Produktkonkurrenz vorne zu bleiben. Das heißt selbst für die großen Marken und Chanel war ja interessanterweise der Vorreiter mit Karl Lagerfeld, war es klar, wir können es uns nicht mehr leisten, zu sagen, wir haben hier die Frühjahr-Sommer-Kollektion und dann haben wir noch die Herbst-Winter-Kollektion und vielleicht noch einmal was dazwischen. Sondern die Schlagzeit wurde nicht nur verdoppelt, sondern zum Teil ja vervierfacht. Ja, also Lagerfeld war ja der erste, der fast Fashion gemacht hat. Und zwar für drei Modehäuser gleichzeitig. Und heute ist das aber Gang und Gebe geworden, dass so agiert wird.
Genau, also wir haben Rebound-Effekte, die parallel indirekt direkt miteinander verzahnt sind. Wenn man dem Buch hier folgt, dann versteht das sofort. Man muss es nur nennen. Also bei Rationalisierung. Was bedeutet durch Automatisierung haben wir plötzlich ganz neue Produkte, ganz neue Prozesse, es werden ganz neue Märkte erschaffen. Dann kommt die Regulierung wieder rein. Das muss auch wieder in den Unternehmen als Bürokratielast reguliert werden. Also ganz neue Jobs werden erfunden. Plötzlich hat man es mit neuen Automatisierungen zu tun. Da müssen also Anlagen konfiguriert werden, Modelle müssen trainiert werden, Daten müssen kuratiert werden. Systeme müssen permanent gepflegt werden. Das ist auch eine Sache, die mich so krass wundert. Man hat eine Software und die installiert man auf einem Server. Dann lässt man den ja laufen und guckt mal nach, ob da irgendwas ist und es ist ganz schön viel. Also das sind wirklich lebendige Systeme irgendwie. Man denkt sich so, aber es ist doch immer noch dasselbe. Ah ja, da gab es so ein kleines Update des Servers und was auch immer. Plötzlich muss man die ganzen Zahnräder nachjustieren. Kann man jetzt mit Claude einfach sagen, hier kommt es nicht sehr kompliziert und es ist auch keine innovative Software, sondern es soll einfach nur das und das machen. Macht das mal. Aber man muss es halt wirklich regelmäßig machen. Und auch in der Reproduktion erwähnt das oben schon, kommt aber unten nochmal ausführlicher. Das ist eben in Deutschland ein großes, großes Thema.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz nur die Zahl noch bringen, weil sie so interessant ist. Es geht da um das Generative AI Paradox, also wie schwierig es eigentlich ist, KI zu implementieren. Und Software, weil du das jetzt gerade genannt hast, es kommt auch hier eine Zahl, die ich doch erstaunlich finde. Die IT-Branche, die heute in Deutschland über 1,5 Millionen Beschäftigte zählt, ist erst in den letzten Jahrzehnten überhaupt als beschäftigungsrelevantes Feld entstanden. Seit 2013 ist sie um etwa 600.000 Beschäftige gewachsen. Doch die Arbeit an der Automatisierung ist nicht nur auf IT-Abteilungen begrenzt. Also 600.000 Menschen plus seit 2013, also innerhalb von 13 Jahren. Das ist gigantisch. Wenn wir jetzt gerade sehen, wie die Deindustrialisierung schrittweise vonstatten geht, dann kann man sehen, und zugleich im IT entsteht eine solche Fülle. Da ist dann die Frage, wie viel bleiben davon oder wie entwickelt sich das da?
Also selbst in, wo wir denken, das ist Maschinen- und Anlagenbau, das Herzstück Deutschlands, diese Unternehmen generieren ihren Unternehmenswert durch die Software, die sie herstellen. Der Rest ist halt Werkbank, China, was auch immer. Aber es ist vor allem der Softwareanteil. Also Autoindustrie schon zu Schirrmachers Zeiten, also die digitale Debatte bei der FAZ, also vor über zehn Jahren war einfach gang und gäbe zu sagen, ja, also bei BMW ist 40 Prozent des Magenwerts einfach die Software, die BMW herstellen. Und das ist natürlich, das betrifft dann einfach alle. Und dann muss man sich halt, und das war dieser dritte Punkt hier, bei der Reproduktion, den er oben schon mal anmerkt und unten dann ausführt, wenn wir am Computer arbeiten und Software schreiben, dann ist Infermezzo eins dieser Probleme. Der Mensch ist nicht wirklich dafür da, Maschinen zu überwachen. Also diese Konzentration ist einfach psychisch extrem belastend. Ist mittlerweile ein großes Ding, dass Leute immer so Promz schreiben und dann müssen sie so drei Minuten warten und dann kommt der nächste Prompt und in diesen drei Minuten ist der Geist aber schon wieder woanders. Und so plus, das kennen wir ja auch, auf der anderen Seite der Welt, ja so viel die KI da auch macht, die Daten müssen strukturiert werden. Also haben wir diese ganzen Click-Worker, die die ganze Zeit sich mit Sachen befassen, die überhaupt nicht mit irgendwie zusammenhängen. Also mehr Entfremdung geht dann gar nicht. Geschweige noch, da kommt irgendwie, was ist Kinder-Pronografie und was nicht und so. Da muss man so eine Entscheidung noch treffen den ganzen Tag. Das ist ja auch alles. Und da ist menschliche Arbeit vonnöten. Und da wissen wir, um diese menschliche Arbeit herum, gibt es ganz schön viel andere menschliche Arbeit an menschlicher Arbeit. Ja. Also von den ganzen therapeutischen bis hin zu psychotherapeutischen, medizinischen Sachen, die da zu einer Rolle spielen. Er kommt mit einer, es ist wahrscheinlich nicht von ihm geschöpft, aber ich habe es jetzt zum ersten Mal so gelesen, ich hätte mir was anderes darunter vorgestellt. Aber er spricht relativ früh noch von einer säkularen Tendenz, die diese Rebound-Effekte einbringt. Du kannst mir mal sagen, ob das auch so eine Marx-Idee ist. Mir klingt es jedenfalls so. Denn wir haben es mit einer säkularen Tendenz zur Komplexitätssteigerung zu tun, die als ein Wesensmerkmal kapitalistischer Entwicklung, also nah an der Marx-Idee, die aber hier nicht aufgegriffen wird, gelten kann und die der zu zeitgleich stattfindenden Tendenz zur Komplexitätsreduktion durch Rationalisierung zuwiderläuft. Da würde ich zum einen sagen, das muss man nicht immer so verhexen. Also jede Komplexitätsreduktion bringt wieder Potenzial für Komplexitätssteigerung mit sich. Da würde Nasehi drei Stunden lang Vortragsporten draus stricken, aber es ist jetzt im Grunde kein großer Zauber. Mit Säkularisierung ist sie aber nicht einfach weltlich gemeint, wie wir es sonst immer verstehen, sondern einfach in die Geschichte sozusagen einprogrammiert. Jahrhunderte wirkend. Also er macht hier, finde ich, ein bisschen illegitimerweise nochmal Theorie Magie, um mir umso mehr später auszureden, dass die KI eine echte Zäsur bedeutet. Ich werde einen Vorschlag machen nachher, indem ich das einfange und sage, doch es ist eine echte Zäsur und es gibt Worte, die das beschreiben können. Aber er kommt hier einfach mit einer säkularen Tendenz, im Sinne von war ja immer so und die KI ist hier wieder mal nichts besonderes. Aber du hast wahrscheinlich säkularen Tendenz so auch noch nicht.
Mir ist das so nicht geläufig.
Also da ist er irgendwie in so einem Theorie Modus, wo ich mir aber auch denke, ja das ist ganz toll, hier Marx, Weber, Dürkheim, Luhmann, Schiemann, Habermas, Beck zu nennen. Und die bringen natürlich alle ihre eigenen Ideen mit. Also die Reservearmee und die Akkumulation, die Bürokratie und die Rationalisierung, Arbeitsteilung und Solidarität. Jetzt sehen wir schon das eine mal Weber, das andere mal Dürkheim, Luhmann natürlich, Subsysteme, Komplexität. Bei Schiemann, ganz interessant, Funktional differenzierte kapitalistische Gesellschaft. Ich halte Uwe Schiemann für einen ganz klugen Soziologen. Und ich finde es auch ganz klug, das so zu machen. Aber es ist natürlich ein klarer Widerspruch, zu sagen, nee, die Subsysteme haben kein Primat. Wir sagen nicht einfach, Geld regiert die Welt, sondern ohne Gesundheit ist alles nichts und so. Also wir können durchaus da unterscheiden. Schiemann aber einfach, nee, wir haben die Funktional differenzierte kapitalistische Gesellschaft. Ist natürlich vollgerichtig, wenn man hier mit Marx und der Bürokratisierung nach Weber anfängt. Selbst Habermas und, also Beck sowieso, die Reflexivität der Moderne und die Risikobeobachtung, aber selbst Habermas, die Koevolution aus Ökonomie und Institutionen, wird hier nochmal eingebracht. Und trotzdem habe ich nicht den, also finde ich es nicht sehr überzeugend, dass ich glaube, dass der Professor Butollo mal selber eine KI bedient hat. Also der Text ist hier leider, also so außergegriffig er ist, was die Theorie angeht, aber sehr schwach in seiner Plausibilität, in seiner Traktion, um es mal so zu sagen.
Aber wo er doch die konkreten Beispiele aus den Beschäftigungsverhältnissen, wie sie sich über die Jahre entwickelt hat, bringt, wird das doch deutlich. Naja, wenn wir über die Automobilindustrie sprechen, da redet er über Japan, USA, Deutschland. Da stellt man fest, da gab es extreme Automatisierungswellen, aber seit den 1990er Jahren ist doch eigentlich der Anteil der Beschäftigten mehr oder weniger konstant geblieben. Das ist ja erstmal etwas, was verwundert, weil wir ja alle sofort die Fabriken vor Augen haben, wo noch so drei Leute überwachen. Wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Ja, aber Toyota und VW bauen halt auch 10 Millionen Autos und nicht nur uns.
Richtig, ja, aber daran zeigt sich ja, dass also eine solche extreme Automatisierungswelle nicht dazu geführt hat, dass man sagt, da sind jetzt generell nur noch die Hälfte der Leute beschäftigt. Man kann das erst mal feststellen, dass das so nicht stimmt, auch wenn das gerne so seit Jahren in den Debatten, das war ja von Bertelsmann damals so unglaublich viele Studien diese Richtung, und dann kommt die Massenarbeitslosigkeit, dass das ein Diskurs ist, der auch schon in den 90er Jahren wahnsinnig gut verfing und der aber jetzt nicht mehr funktioniert. Und jetzt kommt ja noch die demografische Krise hinzu.
Aber wir haben es hier mit einem Text zu tun, der das, was du jetzt genannt hast, kurz nennt, im globalen Panorama. Und dann mit so Feinheiten kommen für, wie er glaubt, soziologische Feinschmecker oder was auch immer, die nochmal von der Dialektik von Rationalisierung und Komplexitätssteigerung argumentieren, Dialektik von Dualität unterscheiden und, und das muss ich mich kurz drüber lustig machen, nach allen Soziologen, die ich gerade genannt habe, auf Aminasehi zu sprechen kommen, um ihn insbesondere zu würdigen.
Ja, das hab ich auch nicht verstanden.
Gönne mir, dass ich mich kurz darüber lustig mache.
Bitte, unbedingt.
Also, Butollo schreibt, Insofern ist man geneigt, dem Soziologen Aminasehi zuzustimmen, wenn er in seiner Theorie der digitalen Gesellschaft argumentiert, dass Komplexität das zentrale Bezugsproblem der Digitalisierung sei. Und ich denke mir so, vielleicht gebe ich Ihnen recht. Die Digitalisierung lässt uns Komplexität als spezifisches Problem, genau genommen Bezugsproblem, ach was, zentrales Bezugsproblem, verstehen und bewältigen. Dafür brauchen wir eigentlich eine Theorie, genauer genommen eine Theorie des digitalen, ach was, eine Theorie der digitalen Gesellschaft. Können wir den Herren mal, ja. Nächster Sprung.
Da würde ich sagen, das kann KI wirklich bald selbst erledigen, so Sachen zu produzieren.
Einfach ein Superlativ und dann noch mal, davor noch ein Superlativ und dann noch mal ein unterstützendes Superlativ und noch mal einen zustimmenden Satz, ja. So, zweiter Satz hier. Doch so richtig diese Erkenntnis ist, so vernachlässigt sie doch, ja. Dass die Digitalisierung zugleich ein Treiber von Komplexität ist. Also jemand, der die ganze Zeit schon davon spricht, dass es immer Folgeeffekte gibt, dass man mit einer größeren Maschine nicht einfach nur größere Produkte herstellt, sondern auch ein bisschen Raffinesse dazu kommt, dass Mehrwert entsteht, dass neue, also, die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die die. Wir können jetzt mal ein Management einführen. Die Maschine ist so geil. Was können wir noch damit herstellen? Und plötzlich kommt irgendein Kaffeehersteller drauf, jetzt Drohnen zu machen oder wie auch immer. Diese ganzen Ideen hatten wir ja zu überall. Da muss man echt sagen, das ist wirklich seitenlange Dualität, Dialektik, Koevolution, Bedingungsverhältnisse, bla, bla, bla. Das Bauchgeschale ist auch gar nicht. Was soll das?
Mir geht es wirklich darum, dass er Zahlen präsentieren kann. Und da wird es dann interessant. Wenn wir da bei dem dritten Rebound-Effekt, der sozialen Reproduktion sind, dann stellen wir ja erstmal fest, dass sich beim Arbeitsmarkt doch enorm viel verändert hat. Erstmal die Schreckensnachricht. Der Anteil des produzierenden Gewerbes an der Gesamtbeschäftigung in Deutschland ist nach Zahlen des Statistischen Bundesamts von 28% auf 23% zurückgegangen. Und zwar im Zeitraum von 2000 bis 2024. Zugleich aber wird der Anteil des Dienstleistungssektors etwa um dasselbe Maß gewachsen sein, können wir dann nachvollziehen. Nämlich von 69,7% auf 75,5%. Heißt also, es werden nicht weniger Arbeitskräfte im Ganzen benötigt, sondern in dem einen Bereich deutlich weniger, in dem anderen Bereich deutlich mehr. Dann kommt er auf das schon von mir angesprochene Paradox mit der Care-Arbeit zu sprechen. Er sagt, dass wenn sich das Zwei-Verdienermodell durchsetzen würde, beide arbeiten, niemand ist mehr zu Hause, auch nicht Teilzeit zu Hause, dann bedeutet das, dass für die private Sorgearbeit nicht mehr so viel Zeit übrig ist. Was heißt das? Fällt diese einfach aus? Nein, das wird sie vermutlich nicht können. Man braucht zum Beispiel externe Betreuungsangebote. Bedeutet, diese Idee, den Arbeitskräftemangel dadurch zu besiegen, dass alle Vollzeit arbeiten, heißt auch wiederum, es braucht mehr Stellen, die dann diese Betreuungsarbeit verrichten. Und da ist die Frage, ob wir es nicht wieder mit einem Rebound-Effekt zu tun haben, sodass wir zwar dann sehen, es wird mehr gearbeitet, es wird aber, weil mehr gearbeitet wird, mehr Arbeitskraft benötigt und die fehlt dann dennoch.
Genau. Lass uns darüber mal ausführlich reden, aber ich will ein Fundament vorlegen. Also die Fragestellung, die du jetzt aufgeworfen hast, ist genau die richtige. Und er behandelt sie ja auch mit einem eigenen Kapitel. Der Rebound, dass wir mehr soziale Berufe brauchen, die sich aber dann nicht automatisieren lassen. Also die Automatisierung bringt Berufsfelder mit, die sich nicht automatisieren lassen. Eine der zentralen Herausforderungen für unsere Gesellschaft. Jetzt haben wir aber, bis wir zu dieser Stelle im Buch gekommen sind, es mit sehr viel, finde ich, zu viel theoretischen Abhandlungen und so weiter, bis hin zu Nasehi-Verherrlichungen und so, ja. Aber der eigentliche Punkt wurde übersehen. Und das ist, und ich bin jetzt mal seine Theoriausarbeitung dazu auf einen Nenner. Er kommt mit Max, er kommt mit Luhmann, er kommt mit Max Weber, wie immer. Und das ist ja bei dir ein großes Thema. Soziologie zu ihrer Zeit gemacht haben. Die soziale Frage, Bürokratie, was ist das eigentlich? Max Weber beschreibt irgendwas, ja. Und dann Politik, Dicke Bretter, dicke Bretter und die ganzen Pointen, die wir so kennen. So, Luhmann, sieht dann sozusagen, die Funktional- differenzierte Gesellschaft, kommt mit dem ganzen Völefanz. So, was bedeutet? Wir haben es hier ausschließlich mit Theorierarbeiten zu tun, die auf eine soziale Wirklichkeit reagieren. Ja. Und diese soziale Wirklichkeit ist immer eine Co-Evolution aus einer sozialen Frage und einer technologischen Antwort. So, also wir haben diese Verelendung durch menschliche Arbeit, weil einfach so viel menschliche Arbeit gebraucht wird, beutet man sie richtig aus. Acht Stunden auf zwei Quadratmetern Schlaf wird ihr noch zugestanden, der Rest ist Arbeit, Arbeit, Arbeit. Dann kommt die Dampfmaschine, die erlöst so ein bisschen von Arbeit, aber bringt neue Arbeit mit sich. Dieser ganze evoluierende Prozess. So und jetzt kommt aber, nachdem wir jetzt bis zum Personalkomputer, der auf jedem Schreibtisch steht und Christian Ulle dann sagt, das ist ein ganz neues Phänomen, aber es nimmt alle in Beschlag. Alle sitzen vorm Computer und tippen darum. So und jetzt kommt die KI. Und ich möchte gern behaupten, die KI fällt nicht in diese Ko-Evolution hinein. Sie nimmt weder Rücksicht auf die sozialen noch auf die technologischen Vorarbeiten und Entwicklungen, die da stattfanden. Sie ist nicht einfach ein nächster Entwicklungssprung, sondern wie Jeff Bezos sagte, sie ist eine Entdeckung. Sie hat eine rücksichtslose Raffinesse auf die Gesellschaft, in der sie plötzlich da ist. Also anders als bei, naja, der Kapitalist kauft sich so eine hochgradig spezialisierte Maschine und niemand außer Helene Fischer kommt auf die Idee, sie noch dafür zu verwenden, auf einer Bühne ein paar Stunts zu machen. Der Roboter Arm, an den sie sich da anschnallen lässt oder irgendwas. Also wir haben es mit sehr nicht-universellen Maschinen zu tun, die ein ganz bestimmtes Problem einfach lösen. Und der Personalkomputer braucht er halt immer, damit er überhaupt lösen kann, einen Typ, der ihn bedient. So, und die KI nimmt darauf gar keine Rücksicht. Sie ist jetzt einfach da und sie bringt sehr viel mehr Sinnüberschuss mit als die anderen Maschinen. Also mit einem Webstuhl kann ich nicht mehr machen als einen Teppich weben. Und dann so ein T-Shirt noch. Und mit einem Roboterarm kann ich halt eine Tonne heben. Aber ich bräuchte schon eine Tonne. Also wenn mein Arbeitsverhältnis was anderes ist, ich muss keine Tonne heben, also brauche ich keinen Roboterarm.
Was heißt das aber jetzt für die KI?
So, die KI bringt ein generatives Potenzial mit, bei dem zum einen immer wieder Überraschungen auftauchen, welche Branchen jetzt gefährdet sind. Die Juristen hätten das vor drei Jahren nicht geglaubt, dass jetzt ihre Textproduktion einfach die KI macht. Und diejenigen, die die KI benutzen, ich zum Beispiel, du ja zunehmend auch, und deswegen ja auch meine Unterscheidung zu Humann. Humann fragt sich die ganze Zeit, was könnte die KI noch alles für mich machen? Und Humann kommt auf extrem viele Ideen. Und ich sehe das dann und sag mir, das Spiel mache ich nicht mit. Ich löse nur die Probleme, die ich wirklich habe. Bevor ich die KI benutze, frage ich mich, ist das wirklich jetzt gerade ein Problem, das wir lösen, oder will ich einfach nur eine Spielerei? Und das stellt man sich bei keiner dieser anderen Entwicklungen, über die ich gerade sprach. Niemand kauft sich ein LKW und denkt sich, und damit kann ich auch in den Urlaub fahren oder so. Das findet einfach nicht statt. So und dieser Unterschied zwischen einer Entwicklung und einer Entdeckung und dass die Entwicklung, die technische Entwicklung, dem naturwissenschaftlichen Fortschritt entsprechend einer Fragestellung, die sich aus der Sozialität ergibt, antwortet. Und diese Entdeckung aber nicht. Die Juristen haben nicht darum gebeten, jetzt unter Druck gesetzt zu werden, dass die Billebille-Auers nur noch, dass der Rückzugsort, Bibliothek, Tabu ist, nicht mehr bezahlt wird. Da haben die Juristen nicht darum gebeten. Das muss man einfach, also hier ist einfach etwas ernst zu nehmen, das auch in diesem Buch wieder nicht ernst genommen wird.
Findest du, dass es nicht ernst genommen wird?
Nee, dass die neuen KI's, die kommunizieren, ohne dass sie einen Charakter haben, das wird hier nicht ernst genommen.
Er spricht ja über das Gesamterwerbs-Personen-Potenzial. Das heißt, er sieht selbstverständlich, dass es Bereiche gibt, wo das auch in diesem Extrem zuschlagen wird. Und wir sind da eigentlich immer in Bereichen, die wir als Textproduktion bezeichnen können. Ob das Berater sind, Juristen sind, Marketing, das ist alles Textproduktion im engeren oder weiteren Sinne. Das heißt aber, dass wir ganz viel haben, was nicht Textproduktion ist. Und das geht weit über die sozialen Berufe hinaus, bei denen man sagt, und was macht die KI da jetzt?
Genau, und da würde ich ja sagen, überbordende Textproduktion ist ja vor allem in Form von Handreichung für Sekretariat, Handreichung für Research & Development. Also, das Management sitzt da, produziert Text, damit irgendwelche anderen Abteilungen da mit was machen. So, und das Szenario heute ist ja, dass drei Architekten einer Software-Idee ein Gespräch führen, das später automatisiert transkribiert wird, und das Transkript wird in Software übersetzt. Die Software wird aus dem Gespräch heraus hergestellt. Und das ist halt neu. Und jetzt kann man sich fragen, wo kann man das anwenden? Und man denkt sich so, wow, wo kann man das eigentlich nicht anwenden?
Nein, ich denke, dass es eben sehr viele Berufe gibt, dass wir eigentlich von einem Bereich sprechen, also mir fällt in der KI-Debatte auf, und du hast es jetzt quasi wieder bestätigt, dass eigentlich so ein bisschen OMR ist. Ja, dass also immer über über so anderthalb Millionen Menschen in Deutschland gesprochen wird, wo das richtig disruptiv ist. Aber in den anderen Bereichen eben nicht. Und ich finde, dass das Butollo sehr gut aufzeigen kann, dass wir, wenn wir auf das Gesamterwerbspotenzial blicken, feststellen, mag sein, dass da irgendwo die Anwälte nur noch halb so viel gebraucht werden oder was weiß ich. Aber das ist ja nicht ausschlaggebend für die gesamte Volkswirtschaft in der Weise, dass man sagt, okay, und jetzt, wo bringen wir die zehn Millionen Anwälte unter? So viel gibt es dann aber nicht. Und wenn jetzt irgendwelche Marketingleute da keine Verwendung mehr finden und sich entscheiden, Lehrer zu werden, dann werden die Lehrer. Die können mit Text umgehen, als Lehrer muss man mit Text umgehen, also werden sie Lehrer, Punkt. Das heißt, diese Bereiche jetzt mal zu sehen, das finde ich eigentlich sehr gut, weil wir, ich glaube, wir haben einen, wir kritisieren beim Journalismus zurecht, dass das Leute sind, die in Berlin leben, die ganze Zeit nur irgendwo mit Journalistenfreunden sitzen oder sich mit Politikern treffen im Borcherts und dann noch mal sagen, wir brauchen mal wieder ein gemeinschaftliches Wir, warum kann es der Kanzler nicht machen? Ich habe den Eindruck, bei der KI-Debatte sehen wir Leute, die im Marketing sind, in der Beratung sind oder im IT-Wesen tätig sind, die sich auf Konferenzen wie der OMR treffen und die da plötzlich jetzt den KI-Diskurs prägen. Aber ich sehe um mich herum zum Beispiel in meinem Bekanntenkreis, dass es hier so außerhalb der... Marketing- und Beraterleute. Sehe ich einfach gerade nicht, dass da eine große Disruption durch KI stattfindet. Ich sehe, dass jeder so KI bisschen nutzt, bis hin zum Onkel, der sagt, das kannst du doch mal mit Checi Biti verhandeln. Aber nicht, dass das den Beruf dieser Leute radikal verändert und diesen diesen Fokus darauf zu legen, auf das Gesamte, was Butollo hier macht, finde ich erst mal sehr lohnt.
Ja, also das Buch ist hier sehr schwach, denn wir gehen natürlich jetzt als nächstes in dieses...
Aber du wolltest noch was zu den sozialen Berufen sagen.
Genau, wir gehen jetzt zu den sozialen Berufen, wo sehr viel Geld von dem, was du jetzt schon gesagt hast. Nur Deutschland ist halt ein Bullshit-Jobland. Und das beginnt zum Beispiel bei der Frage, wer trifft Entscheidungen und wie viel menschliche Arbeit ist von Nöten, um einen Supermarkt morgens mit Material zu bestücken.
Lass uns was mit den Bullshit-Jobs, das kommt ja am Ende nochmal ganz zitiert ja direkt.
Also sehr gut ist natürlich jetzt wirklich dieses Kapitel Rebound-Effekte bei sozialen Reproduktionsberufen. Das sind ja genau die, über die sich Elon Musk lustig gemacht hat. Und da würde ich sagen, ich stimme mit dem Buch voll überein. Wir haben zum einen diese Demografie, die uns da reinschlägt. Und zum anderen der Papst, der völlig zurecht sagt, in der Bildung darf der menschliche Lehrer niemals ersetzt werden. Dasselbe gilt in der menschlichen Pflege. Beim Kümmern ums Haustier, also alles, was da genannt wurde. Und ja, was soll man sagen? Also das ist halt einfach an der Stelle richtig. Und es ist vor allem mal richtig zu betonen, dass wir krasse Steigerungen in diesen Sektoren haben. Pflege, er nennt hier 2000 bis 2023 plus 85 Prozent. Also fast eine Verdopplung in diesen Problemberufen, sagen wir es so. Legalwesen, 57 Prozent plus. Erzieherinnen in Kitas, 51 Prozent plus. Und immer noch zu wenig. Gesundheitswesen, 31 Prozent plus. Von zweieinhalb auf fast dreieinhalb Millionen Menschen. Das sind beeindruckende Zahlen in der Gesamtwirtschaft. Sechs Millionen mehr Beschäftigte in diesem Zeitraum. Vor allem durch diese Steigerung. Das ist natürlich, ja, und außer, dass die KI Protokolle führt und vielleicht bei der politischen Steuerung wirklich sehr hilfreich beraten kann, müssen sowohl die politischen Entscheidungen von Menschen getroffen werden, als auch die ausführende Pflege ist halt vor Ort. Also sehr viel Verwaltung findet da ja nicht statt. Da gibt es ja nicht jetzt großen Telefondienst oder Sonstiges. Das ist ja alles schon reduziert auf Uber-Style. Die App organisiert und schickt dich halt wohin.
Und wenn wir diese dramatischen Zahlen lesen, verstehen wir auch, warum er eine Reallokation von Arbeitskräften fordert, Planung fordert. Denn der Kapitalismus jetzt, wie er beschaffen ist, nimmt permanent Fehlallokationen vor. Das heißt, Leute werden für was ausgebildet, was eigentlich gar nicht benötigt wird. Wenn wir über Systemrelevanz reden, dann gilt das doppelt. Wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass wir noch eine Arbeitslosigkeit haben und trotzdem gibt es diesen Mangel? Oder wenn wir jetzt mal europaweit blicken, man muss ja nicht nur immer in den nationalen Grenzen fahren. Wir haben immer noch eine dramatische Jugendarbeitslosigkeit bei gleichzeitigem Fachkräftemangel in all diesen sozialen Berufen. Das heißt, hier findet ein erhebliches Mismatch statt. Deshalb auch, weil nicht vernünftig geplant wird. Die Bildung wird nicht vernünftig geplant. Und man lässt es zu, dass Berufe, die kurzzeitig Profit bringen, sich immer weiter ausbreiten können. Aber sie werden andererseits dann fehlen dort, wo man es eigentlich braucht. Nämlich, du hast diese Zahlen genannt, in der Pflege.
Genau. Und es macht gar keinen Sinn, den Pflegeberuf als Tätigkeitsfeld notgedrungen dann zu ökonomisieren. Weil das bedeutet einfach, dass der Pflegeplatz 4.000 Euro pro Monat kostet. Also, es funktioniert einfach nicht. Von daher sehr gut. Ich stimme da voll überein.
Kommen wir zu dem Kapitel von Massenarbeitslosigkeit zu struktureller Arbeitskräfteknappheit. Du hast ja heute eingangs schon nochmal uns in Erinnerung gerufen, wie alt der Kanzler ist. Wir wissen, er ist ein Kind der 90er Jahre. In dem Sinne, dass er in den 90er Jahren wirkte und dort populär wurde. Er hat diese Zahlen auch offenbar noch alle im Kopf. Und auch die Paradigmen haben sich seitdem wenig geändert. Aber es hat sich radikal etwas geändert. Nämlich, in den vergangenen zwei Jahrzehnten hat das Arbeitsvolumen in den meisten OECD-Ländern auffallend deutlich zugenommen, während für die Erwerbslosigkeit das Gegenteil zu verzeichnen ist. Auch der Beschäftigungseinbruch durch die Corona-Pandemie wurde mittlerweile überkompensiert. Der Beschäftigungsstand in den OECD-Ländern ist 2025 um rund ein Viertel höher als im Jahr 2000. Das heißt, es wird mehr gearbeitet. EU-Gesamtheit der Arbeitsstunden von 2014 bis heute um über 10 Prozent zugenommen. Das heißt, diese Warnungen von 2000, die Massenarbeitslosigkeit wird kommen, jetzt noch mal schnell Niedriglohnsektor werden, damit wir das Schlimmste verhindern können. Das stimmt nicht. Es wird mehr gearbeitet. Und das hat man eigentlich auch schon in den Nullerjahren wissen können, dass sich es in diese Richtung entwickelt. Aber man war nicht bereit, das zu sehen. Und da sagt er auch, ja, weil man nicht bereit ist, über Demografie zu sprechen. Die OECD prognostiziert einen Rückgang der Bevölkerung im erwerbsfähigen Alter in den OECD-Ländern um 8% bis 2060. In einigen OECD-Ländern, Südkorea, Litauen, Polen, Lettland und Italien, kommt es zu einer radikalen Abnahme der Erwerbsbevölkerung um über 30%. Auch in Deutschland ist der prognostizierte Rückgang mit über 20% überdurchschnittlich.
Das Buch ist an der Stelle jetzt sehr drastisch und ich möchte mich kurz darüber lustig machen, wie wenig es aber empirisch belegt, was nicht bedeutet, dass es nicht stimmen kann. Der folgende Satz hat mich wirklich stutzig gemacht. Er schreibt nämlich, bestehende Engpässe auf dem Arbeitsmarkt sind bislang nicht die Folge eines aufgrund des demografischen Wandels verringerten Arbeitskräfteangebots, also noch nicht die Demografie, sondern eines aufgrund der Rebound-Effekte zur Automatisierung steigenden Arbeitsvolumens. Also er sagt, dass wir jetzt schon die Knappheit haben, ist geschuldet, dass wir schon die Automatisierung nicht richtig gestalten und die Demografie kommt jetzt erst noch. Aber, und dann muss man sich halt, ich hab es immer mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassend aus verschiedenen Texteilen, also lass dich nicht verunsichern. Die Satzbausteine sind immer so, dass irgendwo so ein paar Forderungen und hier und da und dann vermessen, hierauf schon eine endgültige Antwort zu geben im Sinne von, ich habe mir die Forschung nicht zugetraut oder war faul oder wie auch immer. Blablabla, es ließen sich noch weitere Beispiele aus der Programmierung, der Gastronomie, der Kindertagesstätten, der Handwerke, der zahnmedizinischen Assistenz finden. Es werden immer so nebulöse, diffuse Dinge in den Raum gestellt. Und es gibt ein Beispiel, das will ich mal vorlesen, auf Seite 172. Das ist übertriebener. Also es betrifft nicht das ganze Buch, aber es ist sehr aussagekräftig in Sachen Redundanz. Denn man könnte natürlich materiell begründen, was man theoretisch argumentiert. Oder man wiederholt einfach immer nur denselben Satz, der einem entgegenkommt, aber der genau nichts an Belegen mitbringt. Und innerhalb eines Absatzes kommt viermal dieselbe Formulierung vor. Ich lese vor. Obwohl die Möglichkeiten der Digitalisierung so dargestellt werden, als könnten sie den Widerspruch zwischen Überlastungssituationen und Entlastungswünschen befriedigen, werden sie weniger dazu beitragen können, die Beschäftigten substanziell zu entlasten. Das ist eine These. So wünscht man sich ein Argument. Was stattdessen kommt, ist dieselbe These nochmal. Einfach paar Sätze später. Derartige Erwartungen gehen aber von denselben irrigen Annahmen bezüglich der Substituierbarkeit von Arbeit aus, die seit Jahrzehnten zu vollkommen fehlerhaften Prognosen über die Arbeitsmarktentgiftung geführt haben. Wieder eine These, ohne Argumentation. Mit technischen Lösungen wird man dem Problem der Arbeitskräfteknappheit kaum beizukommen sein. Wieder eine These, ohne Argumentation. Und dann noch ein viertes Mal im selben Absatz. Sie können bisweilen entlastend wirken, sind aber aufgrund der Rebound-Effekte zur Automatisierung nicht mehr als ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein. Also er hat in seinem Rebound-Kapitel, in dem er seine Theorie-Studien vorgelegt hat, für sich selber ein Fundament gelegt, um einfach immer wieder diese These zu wiederholen. Aber mir fehlen die Belege, mir fehlt auch Anschau- lichkeit, mir fehlt der direkte Blick und deswegen Grapper, richtig ranzugehen und sich anzuschauen, was da passiert. Und vielleicht sogar, und das ist ja einer der großen Sprünge von David Grapper, eine Definition zu finden, die man aus der Empirie selbst ableitet. Ein Bullshit-Job macht jemand, der von sich selber behauptet, ich mache hier einen Bullshit-Job. Davon sind wir hier ganz weit entfernt.
Finde ich eben nicht. Ich finde, das eher präziser ist als David Grapper. Denn bei David Grapper ist ja das Problem mit den Bullshit-Jobs, dass diese Definition ja für dich empfunden so sein kann, wie viele Leute behaupten, ich mache hier gerade was Sinnloses. Aber nur weil sie nicht erkennen, worin der Sinn besteht, heißt es ja nicht, dass es keinen Sinn gibt.
Also ja, mutig.
Er schreibt, also dann nehmen wir jetzt die David Grapper-Diskussion vorweg, bevor wir zu dem anderen noch kommen. Er sagt, die Diskussion der Rebound-Effekte zur Automatisierung legt eine andere Deutung nach. Bullshit-Jobs sind durchaus funktional und trotzdem sinnlos aus der Perspektive des Gemeinwohls. Das Problem liegt weniger in systemischen Ineffizienzen und organisationaler Irrationalität, sondern darin, dass aus der Wachstums- und Beschleunigungsdynamik des Kapitalismus übermäßige Komplexität entsteht, die Arbeitskapazitäten in einem immensen Ausmaß bindet. Die Tätigkeit von Influencerinnen, Beraterinnen, Verwaltungsangestellten und Entwicklerinnen, die im Konkurrenzkampf um Innovationsvorsprünge teils redundante Anwendungen entwickeln, statt zu kooperieren, sind durchaus funktional im Sinne kapitalistischer Konkurrenz. Für die gesellschaftliche Reproduktion ist der Nutzen ihrer Tätigkeit jedoch zweifelhaft, zumal ihre Intelligenz und ihr Können an anderer Stelle dringend gebraucht würden. Das ist doch erstmal eine These, der man zustimmen kann.
Ich stimme dem mal zu. Denn, heuristisch, analytisch klar. Also man kann jetzt immer sagen, jemand der von sich selbst behauptet, ich mache eigentlich nur so einen blöden, was weiß ich, Marketing-Newsletter schreiben oder so, kann ja trotzdem für ein Produkt sein, das den Leuten hilft, also wo Marketing sinnvoll ist, wie auch immer.
Oder im Sinne des Unternehmens einfach sein. Also ob man da selbst eine Sinnhaftigkeit drin sieht, ist ja erstmal nicht so wichtig. Jetzt hat ja David Grabban darauf abgezielt, dass offenbar in Unternehmen Strukturen entstehen, in denen Jobs dann geschaffen werden, die nicht mehr irgendeine direkte Funktion zu haben scheinen. Und das wird nicht nur den Beschäftigten klar, sondern das glaubt er, dass er das auch so belegen kann. Ich finde, dass er da oft auch die Belege nicht liefert, die da sind. Denn was man ja erstmal sagen würde, in der kapitalistischen Logik versucht, jedes Unternehmen so effizient zu arbeiten wie möglich. Das heißt, nur so viele Mitarbeiter anzustellen, die man braucht. Niemand stellt drei Sekretäre ein, wenn am Ende nur einer benötigt wird. Aber was man sagen kann, ist, dass durch diese Komplexitätsreduktion natürlich ganz viele Dinge plötzlich dazwischen geschaltet werden, wodurch das gar nicht mehr anders geht. Also ich hatte vor einer Weile ein Gespräch mit jemand, der für YouTuber arbeitet und da ging es darum, dass ich sagte, wieso haben die alle so viele Mitarbeiter? Und dann sagte er, ja, weil die Werbekooperationen haben und das muss sehr aufwendig ausbalanciert werden, wie sie werben und wie sie sich mit den Agenturen dann verhalten und die Agenturen kommunizieren wieder mit anderen Agenturen. Das heißt, da sind so viele Leute dazwischen geschaltet, dass man nicht einfach sagen kann, ich mache Werbung für euer Produkt, ich nehme das dann morgen auf, sondern da müssen zig Leute, Telefonate und all das führen. Das heißt, das ist zwar irrsinnig in dem Sinne, weil man sagt, woanders fehlen Kita-Mitarbeiter und hier redet ihr darüber, wie organisiert ihr eine Podcast-Werbung. Aber in einer kapitalistischen Logik ist es absolut sinnvoll, dass es so läuft. Und ich glaube, auf diesen Remount-Effekt hinzuweisen, ist sehr wichtig, dass diese Automatisierung nicht gleichzeitig meint, mehr freie Zeit und weniger Arbeitsplätze werden gebraucht.
Ja, absolut, ist auf jeden Fall in der Argumentation voll plausibel. Ich möchte aber auf der KI-Seite jetzt auch noch zwischen den Zeilen ein Angebot machen, was im Buch so explizit nicht drinsteckt, was aber für mich, und das ist für viele, die vielleicht im Alltag dasselbe Probleme haben wie ich, dass sie immer ein bisschen überschwängig dann auch über die KI reden und reflektieren wollen. Und dann kommen wir irgendwelche im Gespräch und sagen so, nee, ist alles blöd wie auch immer, so kennt man ja. Und das Angebot, das ich hier machen würde, und das auch das Buch so ein bisschen auf ein anderes Fundament dann setzt, vielleicht beobachten wir mal KIs nicht immer unter diesem, wie klug sind sie, sondern wir nehmen einen neuen Grundbegriff, den wir alle kennen und schätzen, wir bewerten ihren Fleiß. Also da sieht wirklich die Welt anders aus. Denn jeder würde von sich sagen, naja, ich bin schon klüger als die KI. Die KI kann nicht, was ich kann. Wie auch immer, man dann seinen nicht-bullshit-Job definiert. Aber beim Thema Fleiß sagt jeder, das sieht anders aus.
Was er ja sagt, es gibt die epistemische Kluft zwischen Lernen und Entscheidungen. Das heißt, dieses fleißige Lernen kann die KI viel besser. Entscheidend wiederum kann sie nicht.
Genau, aber man muss so textisch, wie du sie jetzt genannt hast, schon selber dann entsprechend zwischen den Zeilen reformulieren, um das so rauszufinden. Ich hätte mir aber gewünscht und ich wünsche mir grundsätzlich, kein Vorwarnungsbuch direkt, dass man über den Fleißcharakter der KI einfach zu sagen, gehen die Mediathek des Bundestages und suche mir alle Reden von Gregor Gysi zum Thema raus und schreibe mir die Pointen zusammen. Das ist eine Fleißarbeit, die man als guter Chef auch seinem Sekretariat nicht zwingend zumutet, wenn es nicht wirklich nötig ist. Ich weiß es noch, bei der FAZ damals hatten wir so ein ganzheitliches Ding auf der Sportseite und brauchten einen Fußballer. Wir wollten den Text so drum rumlaufen lassen. Um diesen Fußballer in seiner Ich bin hier gerade im Schuss und so. Was bedeutet, jemand in der Grafik musste, da wir ihn sehr groß gedruckt haben, diesen Fußballer, musste den freistellen, also den Hintergrund rausschneiden. Das war damals eine krasse Arbeit. So, und man hat sich wirklich viele Gedanken in der Redaktion gemacht. Wollen wir die Seite wirklich so bauen? Man hat den Text schon mal auf den Hintergrund gelegt und erst final hat man dann gesagt, okay, jetzt geben wir das in die Grafik, weil da sitzt jetzt jemand eine Stunde lang und bereinigt diese Pixel. Das würde man heute natürlich ganz anders machen. Also hier bringt die KI nicht einfach nur eine Fähigkeit mit, sondern auch ein Fleiß, wo man sich denkt, wir als Redaktion müssen nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, sondern wir sagen jetzt einfach, mach mal den Hintergrund weg, fertig ist. Jaja. Und da kommen so neue Sachen.
Diese Rationalisierung ist ja auf jeden Fall so.
Ich würde sie halt wirklich auf den Fleiß mal runterbrechen. Ich hatte immer hier KI, KI.
Ich habe ja ein Beispiel heute dabei. Wenn ich jetzt nachher die Fragen von Caren Miosga vortrage, dann war das ja eine Arbeit einer KI von vier Minuten. Dann hat sie mir diesen Text erstellt. Erstmal die gesamte Talkshow. Leider konnte diese KI nicht unterscheiden zwischen wer spricht da.
Oh, doch, das kann sie. Das kann man anklicken.
Siehst du, das ist ja...
Gerade wenn Frauen und Männer...
Ja, das ist das Thema, was Butollo auch anspricht, nämlich die Implementierung. Also das heißt, die Technik ist da, aber sie ist bei Wolfgang noch nicht angekommen. Das siehst du dann da. Ich kann dann auf den Link klicken, habe aber das nicht gemacht. Also was habe ich gemacht? Ich habe also nochmal selbst Arbeit investiert, habe in doppelter Geschwindigkeit mir die Sendung angehört und habe dann immer die Sätze, die Merz spricht, rausgelöscht. Aber dann war ich doch innerhalb von 30 Minuten mit dem Ganzen fertig. Hätte ich mich jetzt hinsetzen müssen und die Sendung komplett transkribieren mit den Sachen, wäre das eine schöne Tagesaufgabe geworden und ich hätte sie wahrscheinlich nicht verrichtet.
Was übrigens bedeutet, diesen kleinen Einwurf noch, die Nachtkritiken, die zu meiner Zeit einfach 6 Uhr morgens auf der Seite erschienen, müssen heute wie im Fußballspiel zum Ende der Sendung da sein. Die Leute müssen 23 Uhr lesen, was sie 21.15 Uhr im Fernsehen gesehen haben. Das ist natürlich auch ein Rebound-Effekt. Du hast doch das Transkript der Sendung, baue doch schnell den Text zusammen. Da hat man keine Zeit mehr darüber nachzudenken.
Aber sprechen wir nochmal über diese ganzen anderen Zahlen. Wir haben ja eben schon gesagt, es ist doch komisch, dass wir keinen Arbeitskampf erleben, obwohl die Situation doch eigentlich ganz gut ist. Aber offenbar scheinen wir so eine Stagnation zu haben. Es scheint ja fast eine Decke zu geben, die jetzt da ist, was Löhne anbelangt, was Arbeitszeit anbelangt, dass da gar nicht dran zu rütteln ist. Also eher geht man in den Untergang, als dass man mehr Lohn zahlt. Es ist also eine Stagnation in einer ganz anderen Weise, noch mal, als man jetzt sagte, es ist eine wirtschaftliche Stagnation, sondern generell scheint es ja so verfestigt, alles zu sein, dass, obwohl die Macht auf Seiten der Arbeitnehmer so groß ist, sie nicht ausgespielt werden kann. Das ist ja für mich wirklich das Paradoxe eigentlich, dem wir jetzt hier noch mal in Zahlen begegnen können.
Das interessante ist jetzt, aber ich kann mir die Investigation dazu eigentlich nicht vorstellen, aber nur als Buchidee. Man geht durch die Arbeitswelt und schaut sich an, wie sehr Beschäftigte schon Automatisierungen nutzen, die sie ihren eigenen Kollegen und dem Management nicht sagen.
Aber dann reden wir jetzt wieder von diesen Bürojobs.
Das sagst du jetzt so, aber ich wünsche mir da wirklich eine Empirie, weil vielleicht sind es nicht nur die Bürojobs.
Ja, aber lass uns mal über Jobs sehen, wo es garantiert nicht so ist.
Also im ganzen Bereich Soziale, Pflege, alles, haben wir das nicht. Supermärkte ist das nicht das Thema. Gastronomie ist nicht das Thema. Draus, ob Bauarbeiten, Handwerk und so weiter. Also wir haben in diesen ganzen Bereichen kommt hin und wieder auch mal ein bisschen KI vor, aber das ist nicht nennenswert, bislang zumindest. Wir haben aber einen Mangel, haben aber nicht entsprechende Lohnentwicklung. Das finde ich interessant. Also man hat eine Macht der Arbeitnehmer, die aber nicht zum Tragen kommt, weil sie offenbar auch selbst vielleicht nicht um ihre Macht wissen. Es ist eine ganz verfahrene Situation, wie ich finde. Wir haben diesen Abbau des Sozialstaats und auch den Rückbau der gewerkschaftlichen Rechte und auch der Zulauf, der dann zurückbrennt bei den Gewerkschaften. Der geht ja einher damals mit einer wirklichen Krise und auch einer Massenarbeitslosigkeit, die schon in Teilen da ist oder drohte zu kommen. Und jetzt haben wir genau das Gegenteil und die Demografie spricht Bände und wir erleben es nicht.
Ja, dass so viele Fragen offen bleiben, halte ich ja für eine methodische Problemlage des Buches.
Nee, wir können das selbst nicht, finde ich, beantworten. Also ich finde, mir kann es bislang, hat mir noch keiner so sagen können, warum ist nicht diese Mobilisierung da.
Ich will mal gegenüberstellen.
Der große Streik.
Ja, ich will mal gegenüberstellen. Also zum einen, am Anfang des Buches habe ich dir ja vorgelesen, was drin stand. Seine große Beobachtung. Jetzt kommt der Arbeitnehmermarkt und so weiter und so fort. Und dann waren wir ja skeptisch. Jetzt ist er selber skeptisch. Denn diese individuelle Lösung, dass jeder für sich einfach zum Management geht und sagt, ich möchte jetzt doppelt so viel. Wir haben das kurz gesehen bei Corona, als die Lkw-Fahrer in England einfach gesagt haben, ich möchte jetzt doppelt das Gehalt. Und alle so, ja, kommen wir jetzt nicht drum rum. Kriegste. So. Das erleben wir aber jetzt nicht. Genau. Er glaubt selber nicht an seine Einstiegsthese. Und schreibt dann unten, seit der 172, und da steigt er ins Finale des Buches ein, daraus ergibt sich eine fundamentale gesellschaftliche Weichenstellung, weil der Einzelne macht diesen Arbeitskampf offenbar nicht. Denn wenn die Subjekte weniger arbeiten wollen, während es gleichzeitig weniger Erwerbstätige gibt, dann kann dieses Dilemma nur durch eine Reduktion des Arbeitsvolumens gelöst werden. Die Frage, wofür wir arbeiten wollen und welche Arbeit wir aufgeben wollen, wird zu einem wegweisenden Thema der gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung. Also er nimmt hier den einzelnen Arbeitskämpfer komplett aus seinem Bild wieder raus, gibt sich seinem eigenen Vorschlag geschlagen, hält der Empirie nicht stand.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Er schlägt ja damit vor, er sagt, wenn man sich darauf einigt, dass man sagt, also wenn man sagt, wir wollen mehr Beschäftigte in Vollzeit, wir aber zugleich merken, dann wird aber die Care-Arbeit nicht mehr geleistet werden können, ist der Vorschlag und den findet man in dieser Weise auch bei Frascha und anderen, dass man sagt, Vollzeit könnte ja weniger als 38 Stunden bedeuten, sagen wir 32 Stunden. Wenn beide Mann und Frau 32 Stunden arbeiten, hat also jemand, der vorher in Teilzeit war, möglicherweise jetzt sechs Stunden Arbeit mehr, zugleich aber derjenige, der in Vollzeit war, bislang mit 38 Stunden, ist jetzt in Vollzeit mit 32 Stunden. Das heißt, da ist mehr Zeit für diese Person wiederum, Care-Arbeit zu verrichten. Und das wäre dann über die Arbeitszeit gespielt, eine Umverteilung, die stattfindet. Die Sache ist jetzt, ob das durchsetzbar ist, denn wir haben ja ein Problem. Und deswegen will ich mir auf diese vielen Fragen, die ich jetzt schon aufgerufen habe, auch selbst eine kleine Antwort zumindest geben. Nämlich, was wir ja sehen, ist, dass die Marktmacht der Beschäftigten zwar hoch ist, aber wir erleben kein Wachstum. Wir haben Stagnation nach Stagnation. Es sieht nicht danach aus, als würde sich das groß bessern. Wir haben keine Regierung, die bereit ist, groß zu investieren. All diese Sachen, die wir hier schon 100 Mal mit MMT und so weiter besprochen haben, kommen nicht, sind weiter weg, als wir den Podcast hier begonnen haben, würde ich fast behaupten. Obwohl der Diskurs ist weitergekommen, aber die politische Realität sieht düsterer eigentlich aus als zu Beginn dieses Podcasts. Wenn dieses Wachstum nicht eintritt, dann gibt es also auch nicht mehr, was zu verteilen ist. Das heißt, der Kuchen ist nicht größer geworden. Deshalb ist also das, was verteilt werden kann, dann nur noch vielleicht über die Arbeitszeit herzustellen. Aber wenn nicht mehr Wert entsteht, dann werden sich die Löhne auch nicht dahin entwickeln. Das bedeutet, dass wir so eine ganz eigenartige Stagnation erleben mit einer potenziellen Macht der Arbeiter, die aber nicht realisiert werden kann, weil die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung nicht so ist, es sei denn, man würde zu einem wirklichen Klassenkampf übergehen mit Enteignung, Vergesellschaftung und all dem. Das wäre ein anderer Weg, den will ich hier auch ganz deutlich nennen, den gibt es. Aber sonst werden wir das erleben. Das bedeutet ja dann auch in solchen Branchen wie zum Beispiel den Zulieferern DHL oder bei Amazon oder so, dass die mal noch einen Euro mehr oder so anbieten, aber jetzt auch da eigentlich nur noch disponieren, was können wir dann da und dort machen? Können wir die vielleicht mit dem Bus alle einsammeln, unsere Arbeiter und wieder nach Hause bringen am Abend? Vielleicht ist das nochmal ein Anreiz, dass die eher zu Amazon gehen als zu DHL, aber viel Spielraum ist da nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist auch schade, dass dieses Buch uns hier nicht aufklärt, obwohl es das müsste, denn du hast jetzt das Panorama geschildert.
Ja.
Und das Zauberwort lautet Stagnation, kein Wachstum. Derzeit ist es so, dass über eine Million Menschen in Rente gehen und weniger als 700.000 in den Arbeitsmarkt einsteigen. Das ist eine echte Diskrepanz. Eigentlich ist hier Stagnation schon ein echter Gewinn. Wird aber nicht so verbucht, weil wir haben Panoramablicken. Wir haben Branchen in Deutschland, die verdoppeln sich jedes Jahr, mindestens. Und da sind auch die Einstiegsgehälter enorm. Wir haben aber auch Branchen, die so nach und nach zurückgebaut werden müssen. In der Summe ergibt sich Stagnation. Im Detail haben wir es mit einem krassen Strukturwandel zu tun. Also richtig rasanter Strukturwandel. Nur den muss man beobachtbar machen. Und da ist das Buch ganz schwach. Hier wird einfach nur aufgezählt. Es gibt so diese Berufe und diese Berufe wie auch immer und so. Und dann gibt es so das große Feld der sozialen Arbeit. Und dann gibt es die, die mit Maschinen arbeiten und wie auch immer. Hier hilft uns das Buch leider gar nicht weiter, weshalb ich, obwohl ich total zustimme, sage, die These am Ende, nämlich die Disposition, über die Zuteilung von Arbeit in unserer kapitalistischen Vergesellschaftung jetzt wirklich zu thematisieren, ist ja völlig richtig. Nur, ich habe mir diesen Kommentar drangeschrieben, er kommt aus der Richtung, die KI hält gar nicht, was sie verspricht, Automatisierung ist auch immer ein Problem, bitte beachtet die Rebounds Effekte und deswegen müssen wir jetzt über die Zuteilung neu nachdenken. Und ich denke mir, nein, wir müssen über die Zuteilung vor allem neu nachdenken, weil die KI genau umgekehrt so krass leistungsfähig ist. Und wenn wir sie richtig implementieren, haben wir sogar die Rebounds ein bisschen im Griff, weil wir könnten nämlich wirklich heute nicht alte Organisationen umbauen, sondern neue Organisationen bauen und von Anfang an ohne Bullshit-Jobs denken.
Wenn man die Wirtschaft plant, das ist die Voraussetzung jetzt, die du gerade...
Genau, und da kommen wir nämlich wieder zusammen. Wenn man die Wirtschaft plant und die menschliche Arbeit als knappes Gut wirklich neu disponiert, da stimme ich voll mit ihm überein. Aber dieser ganze Weg dahin, diese Argumentation und hier nochmal über die sich die KI lustig machen und so weiter, denke ich mir, warum denn?
Er schreibt, wo Profite winken, wird investiert. Und wo investiert wird, entsteht Arbeit unabhängig von ihrem gesellschaftlichen Nutzen. Das ist das Entscheidende, unabhängig vom gesellschaftlichen Nutzen. Der Rohstoffextraktivismus und die Werbeindustrie werden nicht zurückgehen und schrumpfen, nur weil an anderer Stelle mehr Geld in kritische Infrastrukturen investiert wird. Elon Musk wird nicht aufhören, Tausende Expertinnen für sein SpaceX-Programm zu beschäftigen, nur weil das Personal in Kindertagesstätten aufgestockt wird. Das stellt ein gewichtiges Problem für progressive Ansätze zur Reallokation von Arbeit dar. Denn selbst wenn viele Menschen gerne für gesellschaftlich sinnvolle Zielsetzungen arbeiten würden, können Anbieter von Bullshit-Jobs oft wesentlich bessere Konditionen anbieten als öffentliche Einrichtungen. Das heißt, es wäre nur mit einem expansiven, stark investierenden Staat möglich. Oder sogar, das wäre das askexianische Modell, oder sogar mit wirklich einer Vergesellschaftung und einer zugleich geplanten Wirtschaft. Danach sieht es nicht aus. Von daher werden wir einen Arbeitskräftemangel erleben bei gleichzeitiger Stagnation der Lebensverhältnisse von den Arbeitnehmern, obwohl sie potenziell eine größere Macht haben. In einigen Bereichen gibt es dann tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr. Die Logistik ist so sehr an der Wand stehend, dass die da jetzt schon sagen, gut, dann geben wir halt den Euro-Stundenlohn mehr. Und man hat, als man noch eine Fülle von Arbeitskräften hatte, ja gesagt, wir haben jetzt hier eine Plattformökonomie aufgebaut. Das heißt, wir können einfach auf Kontingente von Arbeitskräften immer zurückgreifen. Amazon sagt, jetzt ist Weihnachten, wir stellen doppelt so viele an, danach entlassen wir die wieder. DHL geht auch so vor. Und dann sagt er, das funktioniert bald nicht mehr. Da sieht man schon, diese Kontingenz-Arbeitskräfte werden zum Nachteil, weil man dann nicht mehr so viele Leute hat, auf die man zurückgreifen kann. Deswegen arbeiten diese Unternehmen jetzt immer mehr auch damit, Leute zu entfristen und bieten andere Vergünstigungen an. Aber im Ganzen werden es nicht mehr Leute und wird auch nicht jetzt eine extreme Lohnsteigerung sein. Die Amazon-Arbeiter werden nicht bald ihren Lohn verdoppeln. Und damit sind wir eigentlich in einer sehr festgefahrenen Situation, die hier gezeigt wird. Das heißt, das knappe Gut Arbeit könnte eigentlich ein revolutionäres Potenzial haben. Aber momentan sieht es eher nach der Reaktion aus, die, wenn ich das noch zum Schluss sagen darf, ja verschärft werden wird. Je rechter Deutschland regiert wird. Wenn noch mehr Migranten davon abgehalten werden, nach Deutschland zu kommen, sagt er hier, eigentlich brauchen wir einen Nettozuwachs von mindestens 200.000, wenn man es konservativ rechnet. Wenn das alles noch weiter unterbunden wird und danach sieht es ja eher aus, dann wird sich diese Knappheit verschärfen und wird die Stagnation eher eine Rezession führen.
Also mein Fazit zu diesem Buch, ich stimme ihm ja inhaltlich komplett zu. Aber ich kann aus allergischen Gründen leider, Stefan, du musst, er wohnt ja in Frankfurt.
Vielleicht kannst du Florian Butollo mal hier einladen ins Büro und dann zeigst du ihm zusammen mit Humann mal acht Stunden lang die wundersamen Welpen der KI.
Und dann gehen wir hier in diesen Raum und reden darüber. Genau. Das Problem mit diesem Buch ist, so sehr ich inhaltlich zustimme, darum geht es ja gar nicht. Denn wir können uns alle unsere Kumbaya-Sitzkreise raussuchen, dahin gehen und uns richtig wohlfühlen, weil Wellenlänge alle sind sich einig. Nur wenn ich am Ende einen Appell brauche, weil meine eigene Argumentation nicht ausreicht und ich wie so ein Politiker fordere, dass wir jetzt planwirtschaftlich den Arbeitsmarkt umbauen, dann muss ich das Buch leider noch mal zurück auf mein Schreibtisch legen, statt es dem Verleger zu geben. Und was ich mir gewünscht hätte, ist, dass man das Potenzial der KI nicht einfach so schnell wegwischen. Der Papst hören wir nachher, macht das ganz anders und da stimme ich auch voll zu. Dass man noch mal an eine Debatte anschließt, die wir ja schon hatten. Ich erinnere an das Buch über zehn Jahre alt. Constanze Kurz-Frank Rieger mit dem wunderbaren Titel Arbeitsfrei. Nicht arbeitslos, sondern arbeitsfrei. Genau. So und jetzt müsste man diesen Wunsch aber formulieren, ableiten, zu sagen mit Hilfe von künstlichen Intelligenzen, die sich, ganz wichtig, vor allem dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie die Aufgabenstellung, die wir ihr geben, verstehen und extrem fleißig sind. Also dass wir keine Rücksicht nehmen müssen. Wir können rücksichtslos jetzt diesen Fleiß einfordern. Dass man dieses Potenzial zur Befreiung von sehr vielen Tätigkeiten, es geht mir nicht um ganze Berufe, sondern wirklich Minute für Minute sich einen Arbeitsalltag angucken und sich fragen, kriege ich das eigentlich in eine Fleißmaschine übersetzt? Und die Antwort ist ganz oft Ja. Dass man diese Befreiungsmomente nimmt und daraus, aber eben aus der Empirie, eine politische Forderung ableitet. Und das ist eigentlich nicht so kompliziert.
Solange aber die Verhältnisse so sind, wie sie sind, wirst du das für dich individuell so lösen können und dir mehr Freizeit durch die KI verschaffen. Für die anderen und auch für die, die im Büro mit Text arbeiten, bedeutet es, ich habe es in Corporate Therapy ausgeführt, Arbeitsverdichtung. Und darauf laufen wir dann eher hinaus.
Und deswegen ist das ja ein wichtiges politisches Sachbuch im Potenzial.
Wir alle erinnern uns an die Vorträge von zum Beispiel Richard David Precht, der sagte, wir gehen einer großen Arbeitslosigkeit entgegen durch den technischen Fortschritt. Auch jetzt, wenn über die KI debattiert wird, heißt es wieder, die Massenarbeitslosigkeit wird bald kommen. Wir brauchen vielleicht dringend noch ein BGE, damit das einigermaßen kompensiert werden kann. Dem widerspricht der Soziologe Florian Butollo vehement. Er hat ein Buch vorgelegt, das heißt, Das knappe Gut Arbeit. Und dieses knappe Gut wird sich noch weiter verknappen, nämlich durch den demografischen Wandel und auch dadurch, dass diese Errungenschaften, die man glaubt zu erzielen durch die KI, doch nicht in der Weise eintreten, dass plötzlich weniger Arbeitskräfte benötigt werden. Ja, wir laufen tatsächlich auf sehr schwierige Zeiten zu, nämlich die Arbeiter werden gebraucht. Sie sind aber nicht in ausreichender Zahl zur Verfügung. Erhöht das möglicherweise ihre Macht im Arbeitskampf? Über all das diskutieren wir anhand dieses lesenswerten Buches im Neuen Salon.
Alles, was Wolfgang dazu sagt, ist richtig. Aber auch dieses Buch übersieht ein bisschen Realität, wozu vor allem gehört, dass die künstliche Intelligenz, ja intelligent ist, das haben wir jetzt alle gehört, aber sie ist vor allem fleißig. Und diesen Fleiß mal zu sehen und dann rücksichtslos auszubeuten. Können jetzt alle Kapitalisten sein, indem wir die KI ausbeuten. Das fehlt in diesem Buch. Also stimme ich dem Ergebnis voll zu. Aber dadurch, dass der Rechenweg nicht so richtig stimmt, verliert es leider politische Attraktion.
Wir springen jetzt zu einem Sachbuch, das ganz anderer Art ist, das jedenfalls keine Fachkräfte fordert für Deutschland.
Wir haben ein Buch vor uns.
Ja.
Du hast es ausgedruckt, ich hab's auch ausgedruckt. Und ich konnte sogar Verwendung finden, denn mein Fenster wehte im Wind immer zu, also hab ich das Buch ins Fenster gelegt, damit es nicht immer zu knallt.
Das ist vermutlich das Sinnvollste, was man damit machen kann. Lesen sollte man es eigentlich nicht, wir haben es aber dennoch gelesen. Es heißt links-deutsch, Deutsch links, herausgegeben von Pauline Voss und Julian Reichelt, also von Leuten aus dem Nios Verlag, die haben ein Autorenteam zusammengestellt aus Henrik M. Broder, Fürstin Gloria von Thurn und Taxis, Wolfgang Kubicki, Waldi Hartmann, Birgit Kelle, Norbert Bolz, Harald Martenstein, Mark Friedrich, Joachim Steinhöfel. Ja, um über das zu schreiben, was eigentlich, sagen sie, seit Jahrzehnten in Deutschland schiefläuft, nämlich dieser linke Diskurs, ist so dominant geworden, dass man jetzt ein Wörterbuch rausgeben muss, damit man auch gefeiert ist vor all dieser schrecklichen Sprache, die die Linken hineingebracht haben. Denn Sprache ist Macht. Damit beginnt auch gleich das Vorwort von Julian Reichelt. Nichts ist mächtiger als Sprache. Und die politisch-mediale Sprache in Deutschland ist links. Das können wir erstmal in Frage stellen, dass wirklich nichts mächtiger als die Sprache ist. Aber wir wissen, die Sprache ist mächtig. Dieses Buch war einige Wochen schon auf Platz 1 der Bestseller-Listen. Nun wissen wir, dafür muss man jetzt nicht irrsinnig viele Bücher verkaufen, aber doch schon einige. Vermutlich, um auf eine Bestseller Platz 1 zu kommen, ja, so 7.000, 8.000 wird man da schon die Woche absetzen müssen, damit das geschieht. Aber was wir hier vor allem vor uns haben, und ich finde, deshalb müssen wir über dieses Buch diskutieren, ist sozusagen ein Wahlprogramm, sollte es oder ein Koalitionsprogramm, sollte es eine Koalition geben, eine schwarz-blaue, aus AfD und CDU. Und das wäre ja dann nur ein Teil der CDU, der da mitgehen würde mit dieser Koalition. Dann wäre das wahrscheinlich die Programmatik auf der man aufbauen kann.
Denn so viel liest du daraus, Programmatik.
Ja, natürlich auch in all ihrer Dürftigkeit. So müssen wir es natürlich sehen. Aber um das ganz klar zu machen, wir reden hier nicht von einer Höcke AfD und einer Koalition mit der CDU. Das nicht, sondern eine Weide AfD und eine Weide AfD, die koalieren würde mit gewissen Teilen der CDU. Die sagen wir nicht Wüst oder Günter sind.
Dann nimmst du dieses Buch schon sehr ernst. Ich mache deswegen einen alternativen Einstieg. Denn klar, unter der Maxime, dass die CDU jetzt auch keine Programmatik hat, haben wir es dann mit einer neuen Nicht-Programmatik zu tun. Vorante kann man so natürlich machen. Was wir hier vor allem vor uns haben, ist ja so ein kalkulierter Joke. Also man macht sie einfach witzig. Und zwar über etwas. Also es ist ja ein politisches Sachbuch, das also auf eine politische Realität, und dann kommt der Reichelt gleich mit Gramsci um die Ecke und sagt, ja Worte, Bedeutung, Realität, das ist ja alles nicht handfest, aber ideologisch mächtig und manifest.
Wer die Hegomenie haben will, muss über die Sprache verfügen. Er tut hier so, als müsse man jetzt Gramsci lesen. Die Wahrheit ist natürlich, dass von diesen ganzen Rechten sich niemand mit Gramsci auseinandergesetzt hat, sondern vielleicht so eine Passage kennt und sagt, ja irgendwas mit Hegomenie.
Genau. Und unter Hegomenie-Gesichtspunkten ist ja für mich ein Ansatzpunkt zu sagen, das ist zumindest theoretisch, analytisch wahnsinnig interessant. Denn hier haben wir es ja mit einem Buch zu tun, bei dem fast alle Worte im Grunde nur von rechts verwendet werden, um die linke Seite zu markieren. Ja. Aber das sind jetzt keine Bekenntnisworte, mit denen die Linken sich zu erkennen gibt. Wir gehen nachher Worte durch, wo man sich so fragt, das sind keine Worte, die man hört im Alltag. Sich darüber lustig zu machen, ist schon allein das Wort zu benutzen, bedeutet, du bist halt rechts vom Spektrum und willst den Linken was unterschieben. Da denkt also jemand in diesem Spektrum. Und dann wird es noch inhaltlich aufgeladen, also ein angebliches Vorzeichen verkehrt, wo ich mir denke, es gibt ja schon das empirische Substrat des Wortgehaltes, nicht wie du es dir ausdenkst. Und jetzt wird es ein bisschen tricky. Wir haben es ja mit einem Wörterbuch zu tun. Wörterbücher stellen dir Erklärungen zu Worten zur Verfügung, bei denen man Fragen hat. Also im Alltag stellt man fest, in dem Text steht Inferenz, was heißt denn das eigentlich? Also schlägt man einem Wörterbuch nach. Und ich habe jetzt gerade argumentiert, diese Wörter begegnen einem im Alltag gar nicht. Und trotzdem kommen Erklärungen. Wir haben also schon bevor es inhaltlich relevant wird, es mit einer Formverletzung zu tun. Also einer Kalkulation mit dem Format, die ist jetzt müßig zu sagen, nicht aufgeht. Das ist typischerweise so. Aber eine der Erklärungen, warum wir es hier mit so einem Wörterbuch zu tun haben, ist ja auch und ich nehme mal deine Version jetzt, um sie in die Kamera zu zeigen. Man sieht hier in diesem Text, anders als bei Bibi, hier sind nicht nur Absätze, sondern hier beginnen einfach immer richtig Abschnitte. Hier ist so Fett geschrieben. Hier werden Begriffe.
Ja, man arbeitet mit Lämata. Genau.
Das bedeutet, wofür ist dieses Buch gedacht? Das liegt so rum. Man schlägt wahllos eine Seite auf und man weiß, aha, seit der 124, das Wort Queer wird vorgestellt. Ich muss also jetzt nicht zurückbleiben zum Thema Qualitätsmedien, weil es gibt keinen Zusammenhang. Und das Format kennen wir von dem sehr erfolgreichen Buch von Hoss & Hopf. Man guckt einfach auf die Uhr, 8. Februar. Na dann gehe ich mal zum 8. Februar, was soll ich denn heute machen? Und dann hat sich das auf einer Seite ergeben. Also wir haben es eigentlich gar nicht mit, also Wörterbuch hier zu sagen ist schon bescheuert. Buch dazu zu sagen ist genauso bescheuert.
Jetzt will ich nicht Nios verteidigen, aber diese Form finde ich gar nicht so uninteressant. Denn durchaus sind hier ja Begriffe drin, die man aus dem linken Diskurs kennt. Aber es sind nicht nur Begriffe aus dem linken Diskurs, sondern man muss hier hinzufügen, diese Autoren halten alles für links, was jenseits einer bürgerlich-schwarz-blauen Koalition wäre. Das heißt also alles, was über Dobrindt, Weidel, Spahn hinausweist, nach links geht, ist links.
Merz ist links.
Das heißt, wenn zum Beispiel die Rede ist von demokratischer Mitte, dann haben sie dafür auch ein Lämmer demokratische Mitte. Ein Linker, und da muss man auch nichtmal Marxist für sein, findet diesen Begriff demokratische Mitte sehr verdächtig und würde sagen, ja genau das sollte man nicht machen. Und wer das auch anfängt und so redet, wie er zum Teil stattfindet dann in einem Podcast von Heidi Reich in Neck mit Ricarda Lang und so, da bin ich dann als Linker der, der sofort sagt, bitte auf mit diesem Kram. Das heißt, was hier alles als links dargestellt wird, wenn zum Beispiel von unserer Demokratie die Rede ist, dann ist das etwas, was man von links eher kritisieren würde, weil man sagt, naja, also unsere, weiß ich es gar nicht, und über was darf ich eigentlich in unserer Demokratie nicht abstimmen, zum Beispiel über die Produktionsverhältnisse. Das heißt also, dass es eine linke Demokratiekritik gibt, also eine Kritik an der bürgerlich-parlamentarischen Demokratie. Das wird hier überhaupt nicht erwähnt, weil man will alles als links darstellen, was nicht blau-schwarz ist. Was ich aber jetzt dem Buch zugutehalten will, ist, dass es ja erst einmal sich in eine Tradition stellt. Nämlich, dass man sagt, es gibt also eine Hegemonie und wir müssen jetzt mal schauen, wie ist die denn geartet. Auch wenn das Ganze in dem Titel links, deutsch, deutsch, links ja eher etwas hat von dem Bestseller von Mario Bart. Manche werden sich erinnern, Frau, deutsch, deutsch, frau. Ja, damals ein unglaublicher Erfolg. Ist das ja hier doch eine andere Tradition. Und zwar gab es ja nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg gleich von Sternberger, Dolph Sternberger, von Storz und Süßkind ein Buch, das hieß Aus dem Wörterbuch des Unmenschen. Das war ein Buch, das in auch so kurzen Artikeln, allerdings theoretisch brillanter und auch besser geschrieben, sich mit Naziwörtern auseinandersetzte. Interessanterweise aber nicht mit den Wörtern, die uns als erstes einfallen würden aus der NS-Zeit. Ja, auch vielleicht mit verbotenen Parolen oder so etwas. Sondern mit folgenden Begriffen, ich habe das nochmal nachgeschaut, Betreuung, Einsatz, tragbar, durchführen. Und daran aufhängend beschäftigen sie sich dann mit der Ideologie der Nazis und wie die die Sprache verformt hat. Es gibt interessanterweise ein Lämmer in diesem alten Buch von Sternberger und anderen und in hier links-deutsch-links nämlich Kulturschaffende. Und da geht es in dem Buch von damals darum, dass man sagt, also, dass dieses zusammengesetzte Wort eigentlich folgendes sei. Und zwar von jener hybridischen Sorte, wie sie dann entsteht, wenn Zucht und Ordnung aufgehoben sind und im Interesse einer schrankenlosen Fruchtbarkeit, alles mit allem zusammengesetzt werden darf. Man stelle sich es ruhig im Bilder einer Oprigkeit, simulierten, geschlechtlichen Vermischung eines Lebensbornes vor. In der Sprachwissenschaft, die mit dem Vokabular des Unmenschen nicht zu Recht Schritt hält, bedeuten hybridische Wörter freilich etwas harmloseres. Kreuzungen aus zwei verschiedenen Sprachen wie Bürokrat oder Automobil. Das interessante ist nun, wie dieses Wort Kulturschaffende von den Nazis gebraucht wird. Nämlich den modernen Unmenschen dürfen wir zwischen dem Barbaren und dem Ungeheuer platzieren. Denn über das bloß Ungeschlachte und Fremde des Barbaren ist er in Richtung aufs Ungeheuerliche weit hinaus gelangt. Vermöge seiner übersteigerten Gebräuche, vom Nationalismus bis zum mechanischen Kulturvollzug. Denn ungleich dem naiven Barbaren legt er nicht nur die Merkmale und Amulets der Kultur äußerlich an, sondern er übt Kultur aus. Er macht in Kultur, er hält sie mit immer größerer Selbstverständlichkeit für einen Gegenstand, eine Sparte innerhalb der Lebensorganisation mit dem und dem Etat auszustatten, der und der Betreuung unterwerfen. Und dann geht das immer weiter. Ich will das jetzt nicht ausführen, wie sie denn weiter vorgehen. Was wir aber hier sehen können, ist, dass der Zugang ein völliger Tonistischer ist, mit ein bisschen Sprachwissenschaft. Dass man also versucht, jetzt daraus abzuleiten, was eigentlich das Kulturverständnis der Nationalsozialisten war, um damit auch zu sagen, hütet euch vor diesen Begriffen. Auch heute haben wir diesen Begriff Kulturschaffender, den wir aber interessanterweise nicht mehr so sehr mit den Nazis verbinden. Es gibt nur wenige Journalisten, die immer mal wieder darauf hinweisen, bitte verwendet nicht immer diesen Begriff. Hier in diesem Buch jetzt nachgelesen, was die Kulturschaffenden meinen, will ich nur sagen, deuten die das ja einfach so, ja alle Kulturschaffenden sind die, die Verrückten, die irgendwas Pro-Palästinensisches wollen.
Genau. Von daher, wir können uns jetzt ewig aufladen mit der Frage, was leistet typischerweise ein Wörterbuch und welche guten Beispiele gibt es? Und da gibt es ja einige. Ich kenne es nicht, aber die Nuzizen eines Philologen, Viktor Klemperer, LTI, 1947 erschienen, zu dem man, wenn man Wikipedia und so weiter folgt, ich habe mir Beispiele durchgelesen, würde sagen. Also das trifft auf jeden Fall zu. Begriffe werden erörtert. Er nimmt sich also die Begriffe, mit denen die Nazis wirklich Staat organisiert haben und deutet sie, ich will nicht sagen spekulativ, aber suchend, erörternd, für sich erklärend.
Er erläutert die Nazi-Sprache, geht da sprachwissenschaftlich vor, ja.
Publiziert eben auch für uns. Also jeder Begriff kriegt einen konkreten Fundort. Eine Rede, Zeitungsartikel, Plakate. Das fehlt hier komplett. Woher diese Begriffe kommen, erfahren wir nicht. Es hängt alles so ein bisschen in der Luft. Zweitens, es gibt keine Historisierung. Wann taucht ein Wort auf? Wer prägt es? Wie wandert es? Diffusion in die Gesellschaft. Genau hier verweigert sich ja sogar das Buch. Es wird ja genau nicht das erklären. Wir haben keine Selbstreflektion, sondern wir haben so eine selbstverklärende Sprachsammlung von Worten bei denen. Und da muss man halt jetzt, finde ich, so ein bisschen rein spekulieren. Wir haben hier autosynchronische Sprache von Leuten, die unter sich sind, die eigentlich keinen Kontakt zur Gesellschaft haben, sondern alles, was sie von der Gesellschaft sehen, in ihrer eigenen Sprache reformulieren und gar nicht mehr sich irritieren lassen und erst recht nicht neugierig auf Gesellschaft sind. Sondern wir haben genau diesen Einiegelungsprozess. Und nun haben wir ja noch ein paar Publizisten, die jenseits von dieser völlig abgeschlossenen Newsbubble sind. Ich will nur sagen Jan Fleischhauer und Ulf Poschert. Die kommen beide in diesem Buch nicht vor. Und das finde ich erstaunlich, denn ich will jetzt mal folgendes Argument machen. Wir haben einen Medienbetrieb, über den sich die lustig machen. Die bauen ihren eigenen Medienbetrieb. Julian Reichelt ist nicht freiwillig von Springer gegangen, aber er ist sozusagen von dem einen Milliardär zum nächsten Milliardär gewandert. Und man kann jetzt über Matthias Döfner schon viel Negatives sagen. Aber der neue Milliardär, den er gefunden hat, der macht ja nur noch diese Bubble. Matthias Döfner betreibt wenigstens noch ein paar Apps oder so in seiner Firma. Also ein bisschen in der Gesellschaft ist Springer noch. Der ist neue ja gar nicht. Und Jan Fleischhauer und Ulf Poschert, die jetzt selbst für diese Bubble sich nicht eignen, aber schon eigentlich komplett disqualifiziert sind, sind ja erbärmliche Gestalten. Und zwar beide auf ihre eigene Weise. Sie finden noch so im normalen Mainstream statt. Aber bei Jan Fleischhauer ist schon klar, der muss seine eigene Figur mittlerweile spielen. Damit das CDF sagt, ja, wir brauchen mal so einen Konservativen, aber wir finden nur noch einen, der sich selber nicht mehr so ernst nimmt, der eigentlich super wütend ist, aber der verpackt das immer so in Humor. Über Humor ist ein bisschen Anschlussfähig. Wir geben ihm mal einen Sendeplatz kurz vor Mitternacht. Ja. So.
Weil sie sich nicht trauen, Reichelt den Platz zu geben.
Ja. So. Wenn Fleischhauer diesen Kori doch verlassen würde, könnte er schon nicht mehr bei Maischberger mit am Kommentartisch sitzen. Und Ulf Poschardt ist ja mittlerweile, also er spielt ja nur noch für Matthias Döpfner. Wir sind ja alle nur noch Zuschauer von Ulf Poschards Spiel für das Ein-Mann-Publikum Matthias Döpfner. So. Das ist schon dramatisch und traurig. Dieses Buch steigert das alles. Also, hier haben sich sehr wütende und auch in so einer gewissen kulturellen Depression befindliche Leute einfach zusammengerottet und haben halt mit sich und den Wörtern, Worten und den Texten Spaß. Also, die schreiben sich das so hin und her. Dann voll toll, machen wir hier noch die Poente rein, wie auch immer. Man kann sich ja den redaktionellen Text so ungefähr Ablauf vorstellen. Ja. Aber wenn man hier einsteigt, inhaltlich, ich meine, dass die Pauline Voss schreibt hier Transfrau, die, dann wird in der Unterzeile aber substantiv maskulin geschrieben. Und die einzige Erklärung zu diesem Begriff ist Mann, Punkt. Ja.
Womit sie sagen wollen, es gibt keine Transfrauen.
Das ist doch lächerlich. Also, klar kann man jetzt hier so ein...
Das ist aber eine Sache, also worauf sich alle einigen können, ist, dass sie Trans-Leute hassen. Also, das ist ja was sie sehr unverblümt hier artikulieren, indem sie dann zum Beispiel das auch absprechen, Trans zu sein. Worauf sie sich auch natürlich einigen können, ist, dass sie gegen Migration sind. Aber das müssen sie ein bisschen besser verpacken.
Also, wir gehen es mal durch.
Ja, ich will was ich nur sagen will. Man ist immer noch so auf diesem Diskurs, dass man sagen kann, wir sind, also wenn man heute rassistisch argumentiert, dann unterscheidet sich das ja von Rassisten zum Beispiel aus der Zeit des Nationalsozialismus dadurch, dass man nicht eine Rassenlehre direkt mit als Grundlage bringen kann und darauf argumentiert man. Dann bekommt man ja ein Problem. Das heißt, der Umweg zum Rassismus geht immer über, die sind nicht qualifiziert als Arbeitskräfte, die stechen mit Messern herum, die machen dies und das. Das heißt, man muss heute, um den rassistischen Diskurs zu beflügeln, sozusagen tun, als sei man kein Rassist. Und das ist ganz interessant, während sie das zum Beispiel bei Transpersonen nicht tun. Da gehen sie nochmal anders damit um. Was ich nur sagen will, ist, dass wir ja tatsächlich gewisse Begriffe da wiederfinden, die ich auch furchtbar finde. Also die ich sage, wenn die Leute ständig von demokratischer Mitte oder unserer Demokratie reden, wird mir auch übel. Wenn ich den Satz höre, wir brauchen neue Narrative, dann will ich eigentlich auch sofort den Raum verlassen. Wenn irgendjemand nochmal ankommt mit Hass und Hetze, dann muss ich da ironisch mich drüber heben. Und da ist vielleicht ein Defizit, um das nur zu benennen, auf einer linken Seite da, dass man sich zu wenig eigentlich über diese Art des Sprechens lustig macht. Und das ist nämlich etwas, was, glaube ich, so eine Kerbe ist, wo die hier einschlagen können. Was interessant ist, ist, dass sie ja erst einmal ganz den Schritt...
Lass mich mal Schritt für Schritt, weil das ist... Du bist jetzt wieder abgebogen auf, da schreiben welche, ich habe die Blase beschrieben, ein geschlossenes Milieu, autosynchrotischer Sprache, die sich über Sprache lustig machen. Jetzt sagst du, da gibt es Worte drin über, da schlucke ich auch, muss man jetzt, hat ja Stefan in seinem Kommentar da auch angemerkt, muss man wirklich den Flüchtlingen Flüchtenden nennen. Und da denke ich mir, man steckt selber in einer Blabbel drin, wenn man auf dieses Buch reagiert, in dem man sagt, ja, was progressive weibliche Regierungskreise in ihrem Podcast in Berlin publizieren, ist ja auch wichtig. Da möchte ich ganz klar sagen, ist es nicht. Ist es nicht. Ich weiß, es gibt Leute, also du sagst das zu Recht, ich weiß, es gibt Leute, denen ist ganz wichtig, hier nochmal ein Hass und Hetze Argument zu machen und hier nochmal den Appell auf demokratische Einheit, was auch immer. Wir kämpfen jetzt hier die Demokratie. Ich weiß, dass es das in Berlin gibt.
Und über die muss man sich auch lustig machen.
Ja, über die kann man sich sehr gerne lustig machen, aber die finden halt in unserer Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Buch, würde ich sagen, jetzt mal keine Rolle.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich hätte so ein Buch, eigentlich hätte man das in Intelligent machen sollen, von links.
Ja, man kann alles möglich machen. Ich möchte anmerken.
Ich hätte eigentlich gerne ein Wörterbuch, Demokratie, Deutsch, Deutsch Demokratie oder so.
Ja, also ich will es mal so markieren. Dieses Buch unter der Kritik, die du jetzt gemacht hast, findet in Berlin ein Publikum, das sich ganz maßlos darüber aufregt und Podcasts macht und sagt, so geht es ja gar nicht. Ich will aber anmerken, dieser Podcast hier wird im Bahnhofsviertel Frankfurt am Main aufgenommen und die Nachbarstadt Offenbach hat die meisten Ausländer von ganz Deutschland und die AfD hat bei der Kommunalwahl 5 Prozent oder so erhoben. So, wenn wir mit dem Buch nach Offenbach fahren, machen sich alle darüber lustig, fragen sich was ist denn das, blättern kurz durch, schmeißen es weg. Das ist ein richtiger Umgang damit. Wir dürfen jetzt nicht immer nur alles, weil Heidi Reicheneck einen Podcast macht. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich wollte das nur einführen und dann aber den Schritt, der hier ja gemacht wird, dass Ideen gehen, das ist ja verräterisch. Es ist ja so, ich hatte es schon vorgelesen.
Wollen wir vorher Beispiele durchgehen? Ich habe Beispiele zusammengesammelt. Bevor wir so viele Urteile fällen, man weiß ja gar nicht, worüber wir reden.
Wir müssen noch den ersten Satz besprechen. Nichts ist mächtiger als Sprache und die politisch mediale Sprache in Deutschland ist links. Nehmen wir mal das erste. Nichts ist mächtiger als Sprache. Das ist ja interessant, dass hier von rechts etwas aufgegriffen wird, was die ganze Zeit von links so stark gemacht wurde, nämlich aus den Universitäten heraus. Seit dem Linguistik-Turn der 60er-Jahre hat man sich ja sehr darauf konzentriert, die Sprache zu verändern. Man hat sich sehr damit abgefunden, dass es die materiellen Bedingungen gibt und da ist wenig zu ändern. Das heißt, weniger Arbeitskampf. Kein auf die Barrikaden, sondern wir verändern die Sprache, denn Sprechen ist Handeln und wenn wir das Sprechen verändert haben, dann haben wir damit auch die Welt verändert. Interessanterweise ist diese, sagen wir, linksliberale Prämisse, die ich auch von links kritisieren würde, hier eine, die von rechts mitgegangen wird, nämlich von Julian Reichelt und da zeigt sich also schon, dass die gerne diesen ewigen Kampf um die Sprache wollen. Sie wollen nichts anderes als das, denn sie tun genau das, was ich jetzt auch linksliberalen vorgeworfen habe, die nur das Sprechen ändern wollen. Sie wollen irgendwelche anderen Begriffe und wollen auch mal wieder rassistisch sein dürfen und wollen nicht sich da gemassregelt fühlen durch irgendwelche Sprache, die eingefordert wird. Aber woran sie genau nichts ändern wollen, das ist die materielle Grundlage. Denn in diesem gesamten Buch wird nicht ein einziges Mal über die soziale Frage in dem Sinne gesprochen, dass man vielleicht über eine Umverteilung nachdenkt. Man spricht nicht über die wirtschaftlichen Schwierigkeiten, die sich ergeben haben aus verschiedenen globalen Entwicklungen. Man spricht nicht über das Verhältnis von Kapital und Arbeit, sondern wirft nur an einer Stelle sogar mal den Linken vor, die würden gar nicht mehr über das Verhältnis von Kapital und Arbeit reden, um es dann selbst nicht zu tun. Stattdessen lassen sie nochmal Wolfgang Kubicki aufschreiben, warum die Vermögenssteuer wirklich das Allerschlimmste wäre, wenn sie eingeführt würde.
Ja, also was mich an dem Buch interessiert ist nicht, wo es sich selbst als Beitrag in einem Diskurs positioniert. Also bitte seh mir nach, wenn wir jetzt die Liste der ich finde Worte interessant da drin durchgehen. Ich weiß, dass es eine linke Partei gibt, die irgendwo in Deutschland irgendwas publiziert und auch eine Meinung hat und so. Aber mich interessiert hier nicht. Das sind offensichtlich Rechte, also das Verhältnis von rechts und links. Mich interessiert jetzt das Verhältnis von rechts und Realität.
Ja, das wird man da kaum wiederfinden.
So, und da gehen wir jetzt mal die Worte durch. Also die Transfrau ist kein Mann. Also das ist einfach empirisch widerlegte Biologie, widerspricht dem komplett auch die ganze Binaritätsunterstellung, die da drinsteckt, Frau, Mann und so, ist einfach so nicht gegeben. Das kann man sich anders wünschen und dann viele Argumentationen dazu machen. Alle lager schlagen da über die Stränge. Aber die Realität hält ihm einfach nicht stand. Der Faktenchecker. Im Auftrag regierungsnaher Medien, Tätiger, Journalist, der stets nachzuweisen hat, dass die Kritiker, dass die Kritiker etwas falsches behaupten und die Regierung immer recht hat. So, also wenn wir jetzt Friedrich Merz einsortieren mit der Faktenchecker, gibt Friedrich Merz immer recht und die Faktenchecker sind aber immer linke, die das einfordern, listen to the signs, wie auch immer. Also es passt auch einfach nicht zusammen. Wir werden gerade nicht von Gregor Gysi regiert. Die Morddrohung. Im Pluralkampfinstrument der politischen Linken, um sich nach deftigen Reaktionen auf ihre Provokationen als Opfer gerieren zu können, gewissermaßen das Arschgewall der Hass-Kamarilla. Also ich habe auch viele Rechte im Ohr, die die ganze Zeit mit, ich kriege eine Morddrohung hier, ich werde angefeindet, bla bla. Es hält auch wirklich keine, also hier darf man einfach gar nicht drüber nachdenken. Nur dann kann man das überhaupt aufschreiben. Und es läuft natürlich alles auf eine Megapointe zum Thema, Friedrich schreibt über Framing hinaus, aber das Auto.
Ja, lass uns doch da gleich weitermachen. Wir diskutieren also jetzt ausführlich über dieses Buch und ich will es nochmal deutlich machen, für mich ist es schon so eine Art Gründungsdokument einer möglichen schwarz-blauen Koalition.
Aber erst gehen wir es inhaltlich durch.
Ja, ja, okay, aber ich will das schon sagen, dass man das so lesen muss. Denn nur weil es abgrundtief dumm ist, heißt es nicht, dass es nicht wirksam sein kann.
Ja, das Auto. Wir wissen, wer die Autofilchischisten sind. Wenn in Deutschland das Wort Auto fällt, dann versteht unser Gehirn und unsere deutsche Seele eben nicht einfach Karosserie, Verbrenner, viel Räder. Nein, jeder Mensch aus der Mitte unserer Gesellschaft versteht beim Wort Auto diese sagenhafte Wertschöpfungskette, die wie Kapillagefäße in die hintersten Winkel unseres Landes hineinreicht. Also, es gibt sehr viele Branchen, die größer sind als die Autoindustrie, inklusive Zuliefer und der Pommes-Booten-Betreiber am Werkstor. Das wird hier übersehen. Zweitens, das Auto für unter 40-jährige Großstadtbewohner spielt das Auto jetzt nicht so die sagenhafte Rolle. Viele Leute haben gar kein Auto. Also, sie kennen ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht so viele, die jetzt ein Auto haben. Und selbst wenn sie ein Auto haben, so unbedingt dranhängen sie auch nicht. Und man muss auch bei den Boomer sagen, wenn man die Boomerfrauen fragt, was fährst du denn für ein Auto?
Keine Ahnung.
Was hast du denn für eine Heizung? Keine Ahnung. Gas, Kohle? Keine Ahnung. Wo ist denn was vorhanden? Also, kommt da mal jemand mit zum Tank? Jaja, dann wird eine Ölheizung. Nonbinär, eingebildeter Bewusstseinszustand, kann man sich den Rest sparen. Am Ende steht hier der Satz, hartnäckig hält sich angesichts der klaren Zwiegeschlechtlichkeit des Menschen, die nicht stimmt, auf den Planeten Erde dazu die Theorie der Invasion einer außerirdischen Lebensform. Also wer sich als nonbinär sieht, ist ein Alien.
Und das ist ja doch so ein Prinzip dieser gesamten Texte, die wir finden, dass sie losrennen und garantiert immer beim größten Irrsinn ankommen. Also das ist ja egal was. Also manchmal gibt es ja sogar so Stellen, wo man denkt, ah jetzt kommt vielleicht wirklich ein interessanter Gedanke und nein, dann biegen sie ab und sagen und das ist die links-grüne Meinungs-Pache, die wir überall erleben. Oder es fängt gleich irrsinnig an, Aktivist. Person, die sich für die richtige Sache einsetzt. Eine richtige Sache ist beispielsweise Wohlstandsabbau zum Zweck der Wetterverbesserung. Denn Klima, Wetter, das unterscheiden wir nicht. Das machen nur Linke, die Klima und Wetter voneinander unterscheiden. Die Kategorisierung von Menschen in Opfergruppen gemäß Hautfarbe und Geschlecht. Oder die Verteilung von Steuergeld an andere Personen, die sich für die richtige Sache einsetzen. Entscheidende Trennlinie. Die richtige Sache kann kein Anliegen sein, das außerhalb des vom Zentralkomitee für linke Haltung vorgegebenen Rahmens liegt. Wo ist das Zentralkomitee? Also ich würde es einfach gerne wissen. Wenn es das gibt, dann könnte man das ja benennen. Aber ich habe nachgeschaut, es gibt es nicht. Und es ist niemals präzise, an keiner einzigen Stelle. Ich finde das so erstaunlich, wie man es schaffen kann, ein Buch zu schreiben, wo nicht ein einziger Beitrag funktioniert.
Ja, und das ist halt wutgetarnt mit Humor, um sich unangreifbar zu machen. Aber es ist halt einfach erbärmlich. Und sie machen eine klare Bekennung. Der, die geflüchtete. Migranten, die sehr häufig unter Missbrauch des deutschen Asylrechts illegal ins Land eingedrungen sind. Nein, also Missbrauch des Asylrechts, wenn sie nach Asylrecht da sind, ist es ja kein Missbrauch. Und dann sind sie auch nicht illegal. Steht aber hier einfach so drin. Um die Segnung des deutschen Sozialstaats zu genießen. Auch hier Realität. Overall kommen sie und bringen 7.000 Euro pro Jahr mit für die Sozialkasse.
Body Positivity ist ja ein Begriff, den du auch mitunter kritisiert hast. Das läuft aber hier darauf hinaus, dass man sagt, die Rechnung lautet in diesem Fall Zuckersteuer plus Body Positivity gleich sprudelnde Steuereinnahmen. Das heißt unterstellt wird, man hat Propaganda für Body Positivity gemacht, damit die Leute mehr Zucker essen, um dann eine Zuckersteuer zu erheben, damit man sprudelnde Steuereinnahmen bekommt. Also wer sich so einen Irrsinn ausdenkt, das schafft ja keine KI. Wenn du das ihr geben würdest, dann würde die sich einfach dem verweigern. Dann gibt es auch diese Sachen, wo man merkt, okay, jetzt geht es eigentlich mal in eine interessante Richtung. Und zwar gibt es da ein Lämmer zum Thema Debatte. Ich lese das mal komplett vor. Es ist nämlich von Ralf Schuler. Wir brauchen eine gesellschaftliche Debatte. Wann immer ein Politiker oder sonstiger Promi mit einer unpopulären, heiklen oder gar im Mainstream verpönten Meinung hinterm Berg halten will, fordert er eine gesellschaftliche Debatte. Wem der Mut fehlt, Migrationsstopp, Ende der CO2-Bepreisung oder Wehrpflicht zu fordern, der gibt sich Muster demokratisch diskursiv und fordert, von wem auch immer, eine allgemeine Selbstvergewisserung der mündigen Bürger. In den meisten Fällen ahnt man, dass der Debattenfreund eine shitstorm-trächtige Position vertreten würde, wenn er sie denn verträte. Doch anstatt einfach zu sagen, was er denkt und sich womöglich hart in den Sturm zu stellen, ist die Forderung einer gesellschaftlichen Debatte, der eigenen Hasenfüßigkeit, bekömmlicher, allemal wohlfeil und deutet, zudem noch gleich zu beginnen, die devote Bereitschaft an, sich dem Mehrheitsvotum am Ende der Debatte unterzuordnen, Bekenner Mut in homöopathischen Dosen. Alles daran ist falsch. Wenn Politiker oder auch Journalisten fordern, wir brauchen eine gesellschaftliche Debatte, dann meinen sie, lasst uns nochmal darüber reden, jeder darf nochmal was sagen, auch mal ein junger Mensch zum Thema Wehrpflicht, aber wir führen die Wehrpflicht ein. Die gesellschaftliche Debatte wird angeleiert, um eine Debatte zu simulieren. Das ist Partizipationstheater, um dann eine Entscheidung, die weh tut, besser verkünden zu können, denn wir haben miteinander debattiert. Und das ist ja auch diese Kritik, die von so Bundes-Schüler-Konferenzen oder so kommt. Deswegen finde ich die immer ganz besonders schrecklich, diese Leute, die dann sagen, wenn irgendwo Einschneidungen für junge Leute kommen oder werflich sind, sagen die, ja, wir wollen erst mal eine gesellschaftliche Debatte. Das heißt, die wollen einfach mal bei einer Debatte mitreden. Und dann können aber natürlich die Entscheider entscheiden. Und die gesellschaftliche Debatte, die gerufen wird, ist gerade nicht dazu da, jetzt nochmal irgendein anderes Mehrheitsvotum zu eruieren und sich dem dann anzupassen. Und so geht das nur.
Ich lese aus dem Gemeinwohl, denn hier wird es ja brisant, denn es hat ein ehemaliger Bundestagsvizepräsident geschrieben.
Ja.
Zudem von der FDP. Jeder, der diesen Podcast hier verfolgt, weiß, also Gemeinwohl gibt es da nicht. Sondern da werden particularistische Interessen und zwar ganz eindeutig ausformuliert und eingefordert. Und beim Gemeinwohl schreibt Kubicki sehr lang über eine Szenerie, bei der er jetzt definiert, was Gemeinwohl bedeutet. Aus einer Empirie heraus. Und zwar mir kommt dabei eine Auseinandersetzung in den Sinn, die ich mit Ralf Stegner in unserem gemeinsamen Zeit im Schleswig-Holsteinischen Landtag hatte. Und bei der ich seine linke Vorstellung vom Gemeinwohl, die vorher nicht definiert wurde, wir wissen also nicht, worum es geht, wieder auf die Füße stellen durfte. Das größere Problem ist jedoch, dass Linke meist überhaupt kein tiefergehendes Verständnis vom Gemeinwohl im Konkreten haben. Es gibt also ein Gemeinwohl im Konkreten. Das sieht so aus. In meiner Kontroverse mit Ralf Stegner ließ sich das schnell offenlegen. Ich schlug ihm vor, dass wir beide unsere Steuerbescheide veröffentlichen. Anhand der gezahlten Steuern ließ sich doch recht eindeutig bestimmen, wer mehr zum Gemeinwohl beigetragen habe. Er hat sich darauf selbstverständlich nicht eingelassen. Ja, also man geht als Politiker, ich frage mich so ein bisschen bei der Frage jetzt. Wozu haben wir verschiedene Ausschüsse auf verschiedenen Themen? Gibt es etwa in der Politik verschiedene inhaltliche Themen? Warum haben wir so viele Minister? Brauchen wir doch gar nicht. In der Logik reicht doch ein Finanzminister.
Ja, er schreibt ja dann noch weiter. Ich führe linken Diskutanten, die es regelmäßig am Beispiel der Vermögensteuer vor, die sie immer wieder unter dem Deckmantel vermeintlicher Gemeinwohlorientierung fordern. Angenommen, der Staat würde das Vermögen aller Bürger in der Bundesrepublik so umverteilen, dass am Ende alle gleich viel besitzen. Nach einem Jahr wird manch ein Bürger sein Reichtum durch Arbeit und Unternehmergeist vermehrt haben. Ein anderer wird das Geld eisern gespart haben. Und wieder ein anderer wird es mit vollen Händen für Rauschmittel und Reisen ausgegeben haben. Letzterer wäre nun erneut bereit, die scheinbar gerechte Umverteilung entgegenzunehmen. Der einfallsreiche und der sparsame Bürger, die anders als der verschwenderische über Vermögen verfügen, wären damit erneut Ziel neuer Umverteilungsüberlegungen. Das ist ja etwas, was man schon beim Marx lesen kann, wie er sich darüber lustig macht, dass wirklich die bürgerliche Ökonomie, die politische Ökonomie so gestaltet ist, dass man sagt, wie ist eigentlich der Kapitalismus entstanden? Wie konnten manche reich werden, andere arm bleiben? Na ja, es gab die Fleißigen. Und es gab die, die haben auf Konsum verzichtet, haben ein Unternehmen aufgebaut und deshalb sind sie reich geworden. Hans-Werner Sinn argumentiert auch bis heute so. Deswegen steht ihnen das zu. Und die anderen waren faul. Warum, also selbst wenn diese Prämisse stimmen würde, könnte man sich fragen, ja, um was kann ich dafür, dass dann vor 300 Jahren meine Vorfahren irgendwann mal faul waren? Müsste man schon so hinterfragen. Aber darüber hinaus wird ja einfach die kapitalistische Wirkungsweise, dass die, die Kapital haben, das natürlich mehren können und die anderen, die keins haben, es nicht mehren können und nicht alle Unternehmer sein können. Es wird überhaupt nicht thematisiert, sondern man geht allein darauf, dass man sagt, es gibt die faulen, die sparsamen und die mutigen, fleißigen, das sind die Unternehmer. Und so ist die Gesellschaft aufgeteilt. Jede Umverteilung gibt eigentlich den faulen bzw. rauschgiftabhängigen mehr Geld.
Ja, aber das ist halt Originallogik Friedrich Merz, in deren Lämmer geschrieben hätte zum Thema Armut, zu viel Alkohol gekauft.
Ja, die rauchen und trinken so viel.
Jetzt aber zu den zwei Pointen.
Deswegen sage ich, es ist natürlich frei von Ökonomie in dem Sinne.
Es ist frei von allem.
Aber es funktioniert als Gründungsdokument.
Absolut.
Ich meine, die AfD hat sich auf dem Irrsinn, wir müssen mal zu D-Mark zurückgegründet.
Warum soll man das nicht hier auf auch hinbekommen? Es ist reine virtuelle Politik. Deswegen ist das Programm auch ein Phantasmal. Das sieht man ja auch in Sachsen-Anhalt. So, zwei Worte. Eins, das drin steht und schön ist und eins, das nicht drin steht. Friedrich schreibt über Framing mit folgendem Satz.
Mark Friedrich ist das, ja.
Wenn der Gegenüber als Feind markiert wird, Ende der demokratische Diskurs fast zwangsläufig.
Ja.
Das ist Thema dieses Buches. Ja. Das ist schon witzig. Es ist Ihnen nicht aufgefallen, ne? Die hätten es eigentlich selbst für das Anliegen, das sie haben und für das blöde Publikum, das sie bespielen wollen, also, dass sie ernsthaft bespielen wollen, Mitnahmeeffekte gibt es natürlich. Ähm, selbst da würde ich sagen, ein ganz kleiner Gedanke mehr Raffinesse, um diese Einladung an uns, das genauso vorzulesen, wie ich es gerade vorgelesen habe, nicht zu geben. Aber sie waren zu blöd dafür. Und ein Begriff, der fehlt, ist das Opfer. Dann hätten sie einfach schreiben können, wir. Ja.
Ja. Was ja jetzt, wenn man mal so von den einzelnen Passagen absieht, auffällig ist, dass immer wieder der Verfassungsschutz thematisiert wird. Der wird kritisiert, sodass man fast denkt, ach, kommt vielleicht eine linke Kritik am Verfassungsschutz. Denn viele werden es vergessen haben. Es war ja mal so, dass es eine linke Forderung war, den Verfassungsschutz abzuschaffen. Inzwischen ist man da ja auf anderen Wegen unterwegs, die ich hier auch schon kritisiert habe. Jedenfalls ist die Kritik, die am Verfassungsschutz hier mehrfach geäußert wird, immer nur die, dass der Verfassungsschutz einfach ein linkes Organ geworden ist. Das heißt, sie wollen den Hans-Georg Maaßen-Verfassungsschutz wieder haben und sehen alles das, was der Verfassungsschutz jetzt tut, als links an, wo wir ja wissen, mittlerweile werden ja Schüler und so weiter observiert vom Verfassungsschutz wegen irgendwelcher kleinen Demonstrationen, die sie anstreben. Also dazu behaupten, das sei links, ist idiotisch. Und es wird aber immer so getan hier in diesen Beiträgen, als müsse der Verfassungsschutz wieder neutral werden, was aber meint, rechts sein. Das heißt, die Setzung, die sie vornehmen, ist, wir sind neutral und offen für Debatte, aber alle anderen nicht. Was sich ja dann auch daran zeigt, wenn sie AfD-Politiker zu Gast haben, wie Reichelt Alice Weidel oder so, dann machen sie ja genau das, was sie hier den politischen öffentlich-rechtlichen Shows vorwerfen, dass die mit Watte angefasst werden, dass die Journalisten sich in Robert Habeck verlieben. Sie selbst sind auch nicht in der Lage, irgendeine kritische Frage gegenüber Alice Weidel zu artikulieren. Und so sehen wir auch hier nirgends Selbstkritik. Lustig ist, dass immer wieder betont wird, dass die Linken nicht fähig seien zur Selbstkritik. Und hier in diesem Buch gibt es nicht eine einzige Passage, wo man sagen würde, ja, das ist vielleicht auch mal ein Problem von Rechten. Es ist absurd. Dann müssen wir auch über das geopolitische mal sprechen. Wodurch zeichnet sich eigentlich diese mögliche schwarz-blaue Koalition aus? Und da muss man wirklich genau sein, weil gerade so in diesem ganzen Antifa-YouTube-Markant macht ein Interview irgendwo mit Querdenkern auf der Straße. Da kommt man und Dara sagt auch nochmal was dazu, hat mal so den Eindruck, ja genau, die AfD ist ja so russlandfreundlich. Ja, es gibt noch so ein paar Leute, die sich noch an Putin da andocken würden. Aber eigentlich ist es ja eine transatlantische Ausrichtung. Diese Melonisierung der Partei findet ja längst statt. Und das ist etwas, was Nios unterstreichen will. Was man eigentlich möchte, ist, dass die transatlantische Partnerschaft, jetzt wo schon eine so rechte Regierung in den USA da ist, dass man diese jetzt fester wieder aufbaut, fester als sie jemals da war. Und das kann man in diesen Texten wunderbar lesen, nämlich dadurch, dass hier immer wieder behauptet wird, dass alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht in Israel, dass dort auch gar nicht die Zivilbevölkerung geschädigt wird, sondern man macht hier Präzisionsschläge. Man findet die Angriffe auf den Libanon gut. Man sieht in jeder pro-palästinensischen Demonstration eigentlich ein Klüngeln mit der Hamas. Das heißt, worum es hier geht, ist wirklich zu sagen, der Westen im Sinne von Zivilisationen wie Pete Hexes und die alle das sehen. Wir sind die, die den Anspruch haben, die Besten und die Guten zu sein. Und wir sind besser als all die anderen, vor allem als Muslime. Das ist die Grundlage für auch eine Außenpolitik hier. Weshalb sie sich auch vehement gegen alles, was eine postkoloniale Theorie so hervorgebracht hat, wehren. Sie wollen nichts damit zu tun haben, weil sie tatsächlich nur eigentlich einen Transatlantizismus wollen, der darauf hinausläuft, dass es zum Beispiel auch gar nicht mehr statthaft sein soll, über einen anderen Genozid zu reden, als über den Holocaust. Und wir sehen ja, wie jetzt gerade auch hier in Hessen das Recht wieder eingeschränkt werden soll bezüglich Kritik gegen Israel. Also da heißt es dann Genozid, das ist halt auf den auf den Zweiten Weltkrieg bezogen. Und dann kann man noch über den Sudan und Ruanda sprechen. Aber sonst ist einfach Gaza-Streifen, da ist das nicht. Wer dennoch in Talkshows und auf allen Social-Media-Kanälen behauptet, im Gaza-Streifen fände ein Genozid statt, zielt darauf ab, dem jüdischen Staat das Menschheitsverbrechen schlechthin anzulasten, um die Ziele der Boykottbewegung BDS auf allen Ebenen durchzusetzen und Israel vollständig zu isolieren. Schließlich wäre es ganz besonders verwerflich, wenn ausgerechnet die Nachfahren der Holocaust-Opfer selbst ein Genozid verüben würden. Weil die Unterstellung nicht belegt werden kann, arbeitet die Propaganda der Islamisten und ihrer westlichen Verbündeten der Linken allein mit Emotionen, zu denen massenhaft gefälschte Bilder und KI-Videos gehören, mit denen vor allem die sozialen Medien geflutet werden. Die bräuchten sie nicht, wenn es wirklich einen Genozid gäbe.
Wer schreibt da?
Das ist Claudio Casula. Der ist Autor bei Ach Gut, dieser Achse des Guten, dem Online-Medium-Magazin von Henrik M. Broder. Das heißt, das sind absolute Hardcore-Transatlantiker. Und sie müssen jetzt nur sehen, dass sie die AfD ganz auf diese transatlantische Seite bekommt. Das heißt also, die AfD, ohne Höcke, um es kurz zu sagen, ist das Ziel. Und dann ein Hardcore-Transatlantiker von der CDU. Da fällt einem Jens Spahn oder Philipp Amthor ein. Die haben ja beste Kontakte da in die Kreise, bis hin zu Peter Thiel. Und das wäre dann eigentlich das Ziel, worauf alles hinausläuft.
Also der Casula hat ja hier einige Dachen. Also der Geflüchtete kommt von ihm. Die Männergruppe, die Morddrohungen, der Südländer, Trump, Willkommenskultur und zwei Staatenlösungen. Da sieht man schon, wenn man in das Buch näher einsteigt, um so eine Analyse zu machen, sollte man sich nochmal genauer anschauen, wer...
Hallestina ist ein fiktiver Staat, wird hier nochmal betont.
Genau.
Es ist Parteien der Mitte, wollen die auch, also sie regen sich über diesen Begriff Parteien der Mitte auf, tun so, als sei das ein linkes Projekt. Dabei gab es ja gerade immer eine linke Kritik von Johannes Anjoli über Wolfgang Abendroth bis zu Chantal Muff daran, dass auf keinen Fall alles so in die Mitte tendieren soll. Was die ja einfach nur wollen, Jan Caron schreibt diesen Artikel, ist eine andere Mitte. Und wenn man sich fragt, wie hat sich denn das überhaupt auch so entwickelt? Du hast ja heute das Alter schon mal ins Spiel gebracht, weil die Hartmann schreibt ja ein Lema über rechts. Was ist eigentlich rechts? Und dann sagt er, vor 40 Jahren stand ich fest in der politischen Mitte. Heute werde ich als Rechter gehandelt. Sei es drum. Ich habe mich nicht verändert, die Parteienlandschaft allerdings schon. Also die...
Ja und die Realität.
Genau. Und das ist, das ist der Punkt. Den gehen sie nämlich nicht mit, diesen Schritt, dass die Realität sich verändert haben könnte, sondern es sind einfach nur die Parteien durchgedreht und sind nach links gewandert.
Ich meine, Waldemar Hartmann sitzt und das ist ja immer beliebt, das nochmal anzumerken, aber hier spielt es halt unter diesen Altersgesichtspunkten eine Rolle. Wenn er wirklich die vor 40 Jahren Realitäten haben will, kann er sich nicht in den YouTube-Fernsehstudio setzen. Ja. Denn das gab es vor 40 Jahren einfach nicht. Dann einfach die Methode zu aktualisieren. Aber jede andere Fortschrittlichkeit, nicht anerkennen zu wollen, das geht dann halt nicht. Also das sind halt auch psychologische Probleme, die man kriegt dann die Welt nicht bewältigt. Aber es liegt genau nicht an der Welt, sondern an Wally Hartmann, dem Weißbier, Tränker.
Ich meine, dieses Buch ist ja für ein Bürgertum geschrieben, das maximal noch so einen halben Gedanken denken kann. Wobei das eigentlich schon so viel gesagt ist. Und es soll ja nur so etwas Dumpfgefühltes nochmal aufgerufen werden. Möglicherweise schafft man es noch, das zu einer Pointe zu überführen. Und der Leser soll durch diese Pointe dann den Eindruck gewinnen, Mensch, ich bin ja gar nicht so dumpf, sondern meine Blödheit ist ja ganz schön clever. So sind die Linken wie verrückt. Haha, ich hab's endlich mal erkannt. Und die haben es auch erkannt. Und jetzt sagen wir uns das nochmal gegenseitig. Das heißt, dieses sich gegenseitig das nochmal mitzuteilen, ist auch interessant deshalb, denn würde man jetzt sagen, die Linke verschwindet morgen. Was würden die eigentlich machen? Sie haben ja kein einziges Projekt, das hier auch nur annähernd aufschimmert. Und auch sonst, wenn du Nios oder was guckst, wie du ja auch bei dem AfD-Programm das nicht findest, sie haben ja kein Projekt, das sie an die Stelle setzen würden.
Also meine Pornose zu diesem Buch ist wie folgt. Es beschreibt eine Utopie, in der ständig Vermögen umverteilt wird, der Verfassungsschutz die ganze Zeit Nazis jagt und sehr viel Töfte läuft, wir zu viele Menschen hier in Deutschland haben. Nur es wendet sich halt gegen all das. Und ich finde beides interessant. Zum einen, dass man die ganze Zeit so ein Phantasma aufbaut, indem ich sage, es ist eine Utopie, das ist schon für sich verrückt. Und das dann noch abzulehnen und die ganze Mühe in das Buch zu schreiben, um mir meine Utopie, die ja nicht mal da ist, auszutreiben, ist halt, ja, ich kann das nirgendwo verorten, dieses Buch.
Wir haben ja das Buch von Butollo ausführlich rezipiert und deswegen sollten wir noch das Lämmer zu Fachkraft vorlesen. Es stammt von Pauline Voss. Ausländischer Spezialist, der zur Optimierung Deutschlands und zum Ausgleich der demografischen Schieflage willkommen geheißen wird. Schon bei der Einreise setzen viele Fachkräfte ein starkes Zeichen gegen Bürokratie und lassen lästigen Papierkram auf der anderen Seite der Grenze zurück. In Deutschland angekommen, bespielen sie ihr Fach leidenschaftlich. Bundesweite Bekanntheit erregte 2023 etwa der eritreische Physikakongress in Gießen. Wir sollen jetzt lachen, weißt du? Dort mussten über 100 Physiker in Gewahrsam genommen werden, nachdem sich an der Frage, wie die dunkle Materie beschaffen ist, ein Konflikt entzündet hatte. Also verwiesen wird dann auf irgendeinen Fall. Noch engagierter debattierten syrische und afghanische Philosophen im September 2025 am Berliner Humboldt-Forum, wo sie spontan ein Symposium zum Thema illegale Wege in die Realität des Seins einberufen hatten. Ein zwanzigjähriger Philosoph bezahlte dabei mit seinem Leben. Immer wieder lösen derartige Fälle Empörung aus und lassen Zweifel am Konzept der Fachkräfteeinwanderung laut werden, wohl auch, weil die öffentliche Wahrnehmung sich lange Zeit auf den vorderen Teil des Begriffs Fach fokussiert, dabei die Verheißung des hinteren Teils Kraft übersehen hatte. Die Bundesregierung schafft nun mit der sogenannten Work-and-Stay-Agentur eine zentrale IT-Plattform, um noch mehr Fachkräfte ins Land zu holen. Es bleibt zu hoffen, dass sie dabei weniger auf hitzköpfige Akademiker setzt und stattdessen den akuten Voltfahrermangel endlich behebt.
Ja. Also, Mariam Lau würde jetzt sagen, da ist ja irgendwo was dran, aber man hat sich halt ärger wegen der Sprachwahl eingehandelt. Und ich sage, ne, das ist einfach fantastische Publikation. Das ist jenseits, das ist Fiction einfach.
Ja. Was heißt das aber, wenn wir das jetzt lesen und das ja zu Recht mehrmals als Fiction bezeichnet haben, was heißt das dann für eine künftige Politik, die so sehr im Fiktionalen stattfindet? Denn die materielle Realität und die wirtschaftlichen Probleme sind ja da und sie werden sich ja, wenn man so eine Auffassung von Fachkräften hat, noch eine Maße verschärfen, wo Butollo sich das noch gar nicht ausrechnen mag.
Ja, das ist eine zu Recht gestellte Frage und die Antwort ist düster, denn wenn wir sie im internationalen Vergleich beantworten, dann können wir einfach nur feststellen, Viktor Orbán wurde gewählt und wiedergewählt und wiedergewählt und wiedergewählt und das Land hat alle Fachkräfte verloren und die Wirtschaft ist abgeschmiert und Ungarn ist im Grunde, also findet jetzt nicht wirklich statt auf der Landkarte mehr, so sagen wir so. In England hat man den Brexit veranstaltet, hat sich das nie eingestanden. Zehn Jahre später liegt immer noch alles im Argen. Man schiebt so ein bisschen auf Corona nach wehen, was man erleidet. Es findet eine Kommunalwahl statt. Labor wird hart degradiert und das Land hat weiterhin kein Angebot. Man gibt jetzt Reform UK eine Chance, weil Nigel Farage das Angebot macht, das Pendel nicht zu Tory zurückschwingen zu lassen, was in Erinnerungen nicht gut war. Also versucht man es jetzt mit so. Und es ist einfach ein Abwärtsstudel, so insgesamt. Und der droht eben in Deutschland auch. Dass hier kein empirisches Korrelar da ist für politisches Denken und Handeln, ist leider kein Hinterungsgrund für diese Leute, sehen wir ja in der CDU, trotzdem Entscheidungen zu treffen. Ja, ja.
Und die Geschichte kennt viele Fälle von sehr irrationalen Entscheidungen, die aber sehr wirkmächtig waren.
Ja, die großen Reiche sind immer untergegangen.
Dabei wird ja auch die Wirklichkeit in einer Weise verblendet dargestellt. Zum Beispiel wird behauptet, Südländer sei ein linker Begriff.
Ja.
Also ich würde eher sagen, das wäre so ein Begriff, den man jetzt vielleicht ironisch noch verwenden würde, aber so Südländer, also ich sehe jetzt nicht auf linken Podien, dass da über Südländer gesprochen wird.
Das Boleide die ganze Zeit darunter.
Das ist Irrsinn. Dann wird einfach Technofaschismus aufgegriffen als Begriff. Ja, den gibt es ja auch als Begriff. Um dann zu sagen, stimmt alles nicht. Tech-Pros und so, alles falsch. Dann zählen sie sogar auf Curtis, Jarvin, Peter Thiel, Mark Antresen, JD Vance. Aber sagen sie, eigentlich ist das ein leidenschaftlicher Kettensägen-Sound, der da vorkommt. Eigentlich auch ganz cool. Das heißt, das ist ja wirklich ein Buch, Zwecksverdummung der Leser. Die Autoren sind ja immer noch ein bisschen klüger als die Leser. Das muss man ja hier nochmal sagen, außer vielleicht bei Wally Hartmann. Aber sonst sind sie, glaube ich, schon alle klüger als ihre Leser. Das heißt, sie müssen sie für maximal dumm verkaufen, damit sie sich einfach ganz däm ausliefern und auch gar nicht in Frage stellen. Könnte das vielleicht mit dieser Trump-Administration schlecht für mich sein? Könnte das vielleicht auch mit einem Peter Thiel, der mich überwacht, mit Palantir, schlecht für mich sein? Nein, die Fragen, wenn du sie dir stellst, bist du schon auf dem falschen Weg, und dann bist du in einer linken Argumentation gefangen. Daraus wollen wir dich erretten.
Ja. Also es gibt einfach Realität. Jetzt kann man unzufrieden sein mit Trump oder Merz oder nicht. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Aber wenn man sich dann konkret hinsetzt und man muss eine neue Heizung kaufen, trifft man halt eine Entscheidung. Und ob dann so ein Buch so wirkmächtig ist, also das Buch kann auf jeden Fall einwirken auf einen Wahlkampf. Weil die Publikumsunterstellung der Politik, die kopiert ja immer so ein bisschen, was im Journalismus als Publikum unterstellt wird. Also das heißt dann, das Buch war sehr erfolgreich, also gibt es da offenbar Wählerpotenzial. Das heißt, solange es so virtuell bleibt, Leute publizieren, Leute publizieren Wahlkampfreden, also ist es halt wirklich mit einer abgekoppelten Realität zu tun. Aber auch Leute, die dieses Buch lesen, können sich nicht vor dem Beratungsgespräch durch den durchaus technisch-versierten, der bringt deine Excel-Tabelle mit und rechnet dir die Stromkosten durch und so. Und dann musst du halt notgedrungen trotzdem eine Wärmepumpe kaufen. Und das finde ich immer, da steckt ja der eigentliche Humor drin. Die machen sich natürlich lustig über Sachen so, ne. Aber der eigentliche Humor ist ja gerade das Verhältnis von dem Quatsch zur Realität. Nur das erfordert halt nicht Investigation, das ist zu viel, aber Recherche.
Und ich freue mich schon darauf, wenn irgendein neues Abschreibungsprogramm für E-Autos kommt und der Milliardär Gotthardt seiner NIOS-Redaktion sagt, ich spare da jetzt nochmal ordentlich Geld, weil man das ja besser absetzen kann, das E-Auto. Und deswegen fahrt ihr ab morgen E-Auto. Und dann werden die alle in das E-Auto steigen, weil sie nun alle Lohnabhängige sind. Und fertig ist die Laube.
Ende des Monats will ich ankündigen auf diesen Hegemonn, an dem kein Weg vorbeiführt. Kommen wir zurück. Es ist wirklich amüsant eigentlich. Leute machen sich immer drüber lustig, dass ich über Bande und Einflugschneise und so. Aber die Realität ist so ein bisschen scheues Reh. Es gibt sie immer nur so punktuell, aber deswegen ist sie ja nicht weg. Da kann man noch so viel Zaubersprüche in so einem Buch schreiben, wie man will. Die Realität ist da. Kann die Augen zuhalten, aber die Realität ist immer noch da. Das ist schon witzig, wie krass das Fantasmer, das Fantomen, das virtuelle mittlerweile getrieben wird. Ja.
Noch einen Punkt will ich herausarbeiten, was ja auffällt, ist, dass man etwa nach 30 Seiten völlig ermüdet ist davon. Weil man dann alle Argumente, die vorhanden sind, die auch in Wahrheit keinen Sinn, schon gelesen hat. Aber sie müssen das ja ständig reproduzieren. Das heißt, das Prinzip der Wiederholung bestimmt dieses Buch. Sie haben dann was zu Gender, dann haben sie was zu Queer, dann nochmal zu LGBTQ, dann nochmal zu trans, dann nochmal zu nonbinär und dann kommt in all den anderen Artikeln auch nochmal irgendwas mit Queer und trans und so weiter vor.
Und dann ist der Flüchtling auch noch schwul.
Ja. So geht das ja fortwährend. Das heißt, es ist ja ein ganz, ganz kleiner Diskursraum, in dem sie sich überhaupt bewegen können und müssen das laufend recycelt. Es ist so ein bisschen wie die Sendung von Florian Silbereisen. Man hat halt nur noch Marianne Rosenberg, Roland Kaiser und Mireille Mathieu. Und die haben jeweils fünf Hits und die kann man immer wieder neu zusammen basteln. Und wenn man Glück hat, kommt nochmal Bonnie Tyler vorbei. Und das war's. Und so ist man in so eine endlos Schleife gefangen. Und hier ja auch. Mich wundert ja, dass das noch überhaupt bei einem Publikum resoniert, dass man nicht irgendwann über diese Wiederholung so übertrössig der Sache wird, dass sie sagen, ich werde jetzt darüber entweder depressiv oder ich steige aus. Aber wahrscheinlich entscheidet man sich dann lieber für die Depression.
Und deswegen rufen wir im Finale unsere Kameraden zum Boykott des Westend-Verlag auf.
Aber da war auch Patricks Buch drin. Weißt du, es erscheinen ja in diesem Westend-Verlag offenbar Bücher aus allen Himmelsrichtungen, um es mal so zu sagen. Jedenfalls rufen wir nicht zum Boykott auf, rufen auch nicht dazu auf, dieses Buch zu lesen. Aber man hat hier jedenfalls einen Eindruck davon gewonnen, wie sich ja irgendwann so eine Koalition bilden könnte. Dass sie inhaltlich nichts zu bieten hat, kann natürlich trotzdem dazu führen, dass sie gewählt wird. Dass hier alles Ökonomische in dieser Weise ausgeblendet wird, zeigt auch, dass man die Realität gar nicht zu Kenntnis nehmen kann. Weil man müsste, sobald man eine einzige Zahl hat, und sei es auch nur aus einer Schlagzeile vom Handelsblatt, müsste man sofort schweigen. Ja.
Statt dem Buch lieber einen Taschenrechner kaufen.
Ja.
Also ein insofern aufschlussreiches, fürchterliches Buch. Ich glaube, das ist so das Dümste, was wir je im Salon besprochen haben, oder?
Ja, neben dieser Eileitung von Markus Gabriel damals.
Stimmt. Die Nios Redaktion hat ein Buch veröffentlicht, links, deutsch, deutsch, links. Wir haben es gelesen, damit ihr es nicht tun müsst. Es ist grauenhaft dumm, aber in gewisser Weise aufschlussreich, denn ja, hier wird ein Programm, ein Koalitionsprogramm vorgelegt, für eine mögliche blau-schwarze Koalition. Es wird schrecklich werden. Man kann sich hier schon mal einen Eindruck verschaffen, deshalb, weil hier so getan wird, als würden wir in einem Land leben, das vollkommen beherrscht ist von linker Politik und linken Diskursen. Diese linken Begriffe müssen jetzt also alle, nach dem Prinzip der Wiederholung, wir sagen hundertmal dasselbe, aber in leichter Variation, auf die Schippe genommen werden, mit Pointen, die selten funktionieren, halbgaren Gedanken und Formulierungen, die sich wirklich von Zeile zu Zeile widersprechen. Aber es ist vielleicht ein Dokument einer fiktionalen Politik, die uns droht, die alles noch schlechter macht. Wir wissen jedenfalls jetzt schon, wohin die Reise geht.
Ja, Wolfgang beschreibt es als schwarz-blaue Regierungsfiktion, die uns als Programm droht. Ich sage, ich habe es als Utopie gelesen. Ständig wird mir in diesem Buch erklärt, dass Vermögen verteilt wird. Dass im Kanzleramt die Linke regiert. Und ich denke mir, ja, schade, dass es halt die Realität nicht standhält. Das ist natürlich das große Problem des Buches. Es hat keinen realen Bezug zu irgendetwas, sondern eine rechte Blase ist ganz idiosynkratisch unter sich. Ist sich nicht mal seiner Worte im Klaren, braucht deswegen dieses Wörterbuch. Also wie blöd kann man sein, frage ich mich. Von daher einfach nicht kaufen, nicht lesen und nicht weiter darüber reden.
Thomas Hettche ist ein sehr bekannter deutscher Schriftsteller, der jetzt so kühn ist, einen Roman vorzulegen mit dem Titel Liebe. Warum ist das kühn? Nun, wenn man das Wort einfach so hinschreibt, dann hat man damit ja Erwartungen geweckt. Kann dies tatsächlich ein Buch sein, das uns Substantielles über die Liebe erzählen, vielleicht auch erklären kann? Die Antwort ist ja, das ist ein großer Wurf, ein schmales Buch, 170 Seiten. Aber dieses Buch ist dicht. Es ist ergreifend. Es ist ungeheuer klug. Es ist poetisch. Dabei haben wir es mit einem Autor zu tun, der bereit ist, auch das große Gefühl in seiner Prosa stattfinden zu lassen, der dabei sich ja in Goethes Fußstapfen bewegt und darin nicht verirrt, der zu Hegel übergeht, der aber auch eigentlich eine ganz schlichte Geschichte erzählt. Nämlich da ist ein Mann, Max, Anfang 60, der hat schon Beziehungen hinter sich, hat auch Kinder und der lernt eine Frau kennen, auch Anfang 60, die in einer Ehe ist, eine Ehe, die nicht wahnsinnig unglücklich ist, aber die auch nicht glücklich ist und sie lernen sich kennen und sie verlieben sich ineinander und es ist die große Liebe. Mitunter wurde jetzt gesagt, dies sei ein Buch über die Liebe im Alter, da würde ich widersprechen. Ja, die Liebe, die beschrieben wird, ist sicherlich eine etwas andere als die zwischen 22-Jährigen, aber es ist gerade nicht jetzt ein Buch, das sagt ja und dann macht der Körper nicht mehr so mit oder was auch immer oder ja, jetzt mit der Reife kommt man sich nochmal anders näher. So Stellen mag man hier und dort finden. Das Interessante ist aber, dass er von diesem sehr konkreten Paar, Max und Anna, ausgeht, um von dort aus universelles über die Liebe zu erzählen. So beginnt auch das Buch schon mit dem Auftakt. Liebe ist eines jener seltenen Wörter, die uns auffordern zu tun, was sie bezeichnen, was viel über die Liebe sagt, aber nicht, was sie ist. Weshalb Max damals genau das fragte, nicht ganz im Ernst oder ohne lange darüber nachzudenken und eigentlich nur, um das Gespräch an ihrem Tisch in Gang zu bekommen. Was ist die Liebe? So könnte jetzt sein großer Roman von Wüte vielleicht beginnen. Wir denken möglicherweise auch an die Wahlverwandtschaften. Ja, das sind auch solche Einsprengsel, aber wir sehen dann, es wird viel mehr verdichtet. Es wird nicht viel geredet, sondern es sind sehr kurze Antworten, die wir dort finden. Einige sind sich direkt sicher am Tisch zu sagen, was die Liebe ist. Liebe ist Arbeit, Liebe ist das Gefühl, Liebe vergeht und so Sachen. Aber möglicherweise ist das ja nur Geschwätz. Und wie kann man eigentlich die Liebe durchdringen? Und man muss sie wohl auch erleben. Und an diesem Abend, da sieht Max eine Frau, nämlich Anna, und sie begegnen sich. Sie absentieren sich etwas von der Gesellschaft. Sie sehen sich kaum, weil es schon so dunkel geworden ist. Und doch ist da gleich ein festes Bann zwischen ihnen. Das Sehen ist auch ein entscheidendes Motiv in diesem an Motiven sehr reichen Buch. Nämlich, Max arbeitet als Okularist. Das heißt, er fertigt Glasaugen für die Menschen, die ihr Augenlicht verloren haben. Da ist eine Künstlichkeit also da. Das Auge wird ja nur imitiert, aber es ist ein Auge, das nicht sehen kann. Was macht uns eigentlich die Liebe sehen? Darum geht es in diesem Buch dann auch. Jedenfalls lernen sie sich dort bei dieser Tischgesellschaft kennen und sie treffen sich wieder. Ich lese mal eine Passage aus diesem Treffen vor. Das ist in Rückblenden erzählt, das Buch. Dabei gibt es auch mal wieder Einsprengsel aus Sprachen, aus Textnachrichten, die man sich gegenseitig schreibt. Die sind manchmal ganz lapidar. Manchmal haben sie aber auch eine aphoristische Größe. Das Wiedersehen, da heißt es, in jenem Moment, als er Anna zwischen Rathaus und Nikolaikirche auf den Marktplatz treten sah und sie ihm entgegenlächelte, wusste Max genau, was jetzt geschehen würde. Die ganze Fahrt über hatte er sich das gefragt. Über die Berliner Stadt Autobahn hinaus aufs Land, zunächst Richtung Hamburg, dann unter schweren Wolken strikt nach Norden und schließlich über die B 96 nach Stralsund hinein. Und jetzt war mit einem Mal alles ganz einfach. Wir sehen hier schon, das ist ein Autor, der kann das Geschehene ganz konkret verorten. Also wir gehen mit ihm diese Reise mit dem Auto. Wir sitzen dieser kurzen Passage mit Max im Auto und uns geht es auch durch den Kopf. Es ist wirklich eine unglaubliche Präzision, die dieser Autor an den Tag legt. Weiter heißt es, wir treffen uns auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt, hatte Anna geschrieben. Doch als er ankam, war dort niemand. Der Markt offenbar geschlossen. Radlos sah er sich um. Zwischen den verschlossenen Verkaufsbuden für Markenbrot, Quarkkäuschen und Liebesäpfel, ein Kinderkarussell mit weißen Plastikpferden und Dumbo, dem Elefanten mit den großen Ohren. Eine riesige bunt geschmückte Weihnachtstanne, die über den Platz ragte. Ihre Beleuchtung ebenso ausgeschaltet wie die Lichterketten an den Buden. Die bunten Kugeln wogten still im Wind. Überquellende Abfalleimer, vollweißer Pappschälchen mit Ketchup, eine Batterie leerer Prosecco-Flaschen am Fuß einer Straßenlaterne. Daneben eine Eisbahn mit einem meterhohen Stern aus Plastik, dessen Beleuchtung man vergessen hatte. Stumm wechselte seine Farbe von Türkis nach Rot, nach Weiß, hellblau und wieder zu Türkis. Im Licht dieses Sterns, und da haben wir die Künstlichkeit des Sterns, denn in der romantischen Literatur hätten wir ja einen echten Sternenhimmel gehabt. Im Licht dieses Sterns standen sie schließlich und ganz von selbst nickten ihre Köpfe zueinander. Und als seine Wange das erste Mal über ihre streifte, musste er die Augen schließen vor Überwältigung. Diese Überwältigung traut sich dieser Text zu. Er kann sie beschreiben. Er sagt uns dabei sehr viel über die Liebe, über die Vergänglichkeit auch der Liebe. Ja, es ist ein Text, der mit Figuren arbeitet, die über 60 sind. Und da ist die Vergänglichkeit ein anderes Thema als unter 20-Jährigen. Aber dass die Liebe eigentlich nach einer Ewigkeit strebt und das Lebendige so braucht und aber schon auch wir wissen darum, dass wir endlich sind, liegt auf der Liebe auch eine gewisse Traurigkeit. Und das ist etwas, was diesen Roman durchzieht. Was ich herausragend finde, ist, dass er es sogar schafft, einen philosophischen Diskurs mit einzubringen, ohne dass man denkt, naja, das ist jetzt so reingeschrieben, das ist jetzt eigentlich ein vermurkster Essay geworden. Dieser Max trifft sich mit einem Freund, Christoph. Sie kennen sich noch von der Hochschule der Künste von damals. Und dieser Christoph bringt einen Text mit. Und zwar hat der frühe Hegel einen Text geschrieben, Fragmente über Liebe und Religion. Diesen bringt er mit. Er schob das Reklam-Heft über den Tisch Max Namens und blättete darin zu einem, zum einen mit Bleistift unterstrichenen Satz. Eigentliche Liebe las er da und Christoph hatte an den Seitenrand noch ein Ausrufezeichen gesetzt, findet nur unter Lebendigen statt, die an Macht sich gleich und also durchaus füreinander Lebendige von keiner Seite gegeneinander Tote sind. Das ist verrückt, dass füreinander Lebendige von keiner Seite gegeneinander Tote. Völlig verrückt. Christoph nickte. Verstehst du es? Nein, aber es kommt mir so vor, als wüsste ich genau, was gemeint ist. Wie alt sagst du bei Hegel, als er das geschrieben hat? Ich glaube 25, 1795 müsste das entstanden sein. Als wäre es gerade eben gedacht worden. Verrückt. Max spletterte weiter. Immer wieder ging es in dem Text um das Trennende und seine Überwindung in der Liebe. Dieses Trennende, schrieb Hegel an einer Stelle, die Christoph ebenfalls markiert hatte, macht den Liebenden Verlegenheit. Es ist eine Art von Widerstreit zwischen der völligen Hingebung, der einzig möglichen Vernichtung, der Vernichtung des Entgegengesetzten in der Vereinigung und der noch vorhandenen Selbstständigkeit. Jene fühlt sich durch diese behindert. Die Liebe ist unwillig über das noch Getrennte, über ein Eigentum. Dieses Zirnen der Liebe über Individualität ist die Scham. Was das bedeutet, das erzählt uns Thomas Hettche mit diesem wunderbaren Roman, den ich sehr empfehle.
Stell dir vor, da ist Liebe, aber keiner geht hin, weil keiner da ist. Davon handelt ein wissenschaftlicher Text, der von Henrik-Alexander Schubert des Max-Planck-Institut für demografische Forschung in Rostock zusammen mit Forschern, die bei der UN in den entsprechenden Referaten und so arbeiten, der jetzt im April 26 erschien und ein bisschen herausfordernd ist, weil es im Grunde mit einer statistischen Spielerei zu tun haben, die aber eine Realität für uns ausrechnet, sprechbar macht. Masculinization of Populations, also die Vermännlichung von Bevölkerungen, reverses, verdrehen also die Sex Difference in Fertility. Plötzlich haben Frauen mehr Kinder als Männer. Das mathematische dazu ist gar nicht so schwer zu verstehen. Wir nehmen die 50er Jahre, statistisch gesehen kommen auf 10 Frauen genau 10 Männer. Die bekommen 20 Kinder. Die Gesellschaft ist stabil. Die Fertilitätsrate der 10 Frauen ist genau 2. Und der 10 Männer ist auch genau 2, weil alle haben genau 2 Kinder. Jetzt gibt es aber auch Gesellschaften, die haben Männerüberschuss. 10 Frauen, 12 Männer.
China, glaube ich, oder?
China, da gibt es ja vor allem eine Sex-, also eine Gender-orientierte, eine geschlechtsorientierte Selektion. Da schlägt das also richtig rein. Wir haben aber auch im nahen Osten Länder, in denen es ein bisschen merkwürdig zugeht, jedenfalls mathematisch gesehen, wenn zehn Frauen jeweils zwei Kinder bekommen, aber in der Grundgesamtheit zwölf Männer dafür zur Verfügung stehen, dann ist die Fertilitätsrate der Frauen immer noch zwei, also zwei Kinder pro Person. Und bei den Männern, da wir von der Grundgesamtheit zwölf ausgehen, aber nur zwanzig Kinder haben, liegt sie bei 1,67. Damit rutscht also die Fertilitätsrate der Männer unter die der Frauen. Wenn wir acht Frauen und zwölf Kinder haben, bekommen diese acht Frauen in diesem mathematischen Modell 16 Kinder. Diese Frauen sind dann weiterhin bei einer Fertilitätsrate von zwei und die Männer bei 1,33. Sehr viele Männer kommen nicht zum Zuge. Und dieses Papier, das uns diese Mathematik vorstellt, hat jetzt abgeglichen, wie es in der Realität bei den echten Frauen und Männern aussieht auf der Welt und markiert für 2024 eine Zäsur. Sie schreiben, wir identifizieren 2024 als das Jahr, in dem die globale weibliche Fertilitätsrate erstmals die männliche überschreitet. Projektionen bis 2100 deuten darauf hin, dass eine Rückkehr zur Parität unwahrscheinlich ist. Männer kommen also nicht mehr so sehr zum Zuge. Und hier ist ja das Kinderkriegen Schiffre für, ob überhaupt Matching stattfindet.
Naja, also so muss man es begreifen.
Genau. Es ist sozusagen ein direktes Liebesthema. Findet man überhaupt noch jemanden, mit dem man auf einem verlassenen Weihnachtsmarkt Wange an Wange sich begegnen kann oder nicht? Diese Verschiebung geht nicht in Richtung Parität, sondern reflektiert eine wachsende Disparität, die durch den wachsenden Männerüberschuss im reproduktiven Alter getrieben wird, welcher Druck auf die männliche Fertilitätsrate im Verhältnis zu den der Frauen ausübt. 1950 haben 96% der Länder eine höhere männliche als weibliche Fertilitätsrate. 2025 sind das eben jetzt nur noch 47,5%, also unter 50. 2100 gibt es nicht mal mehr 10% der Länder, bei denen das so ist. Ab 2030, also nahe Zukunft, lebt die Mehrheit der Weltbevölkerung in Ländern mit mindestens 5% niedriger männlicher Fertilitätsrate. Also das ist das Ostdeutsche. Alle Frauen ziehen, gehen Westen. Die Männer bleiben zurück, suchen Anschluss, finden den nur unter anderen Männern und alles, was das eben bedeutet.
Und kaufen dann das Buch von Nios.
Und schreiben selber Briefe an ihr Ministerpräsidenten, was sie alles so nicht okay finden, oder dann aufgezählt. Ja, so, das bedeutet nun. Und hier geht es natürlich im globalen Maßstab um Korea, China, Indien, auch ein sehr genderselektives Land. Wusste ich so gar nicht. Katar, ich verstehe das gar nicht. Völlig anderes Bild, gleiches Ergebnis im Ranking. In Katar, Vereinigt Arabische Emirate, Malediven, Oman, Maldives, was auch immer. Oman liegt die männliche Fertilitätsrate heute bis zu 60 Prozent unter der weiblichen. Also ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt, aber in Spezialfällen schreiben sie hier wie Katar, führt männlich dominierte Arbeitsmikration zu sich ändernden Bevölkerungsstrukturen, aber nicht zu sich ändernder Fertilitäten. Also es gibt Länder, in denen es gibt krasse Schieflagen. Und jetzt ist hier die große Frage. Ein Überschuss an Männern im reproduktiven Alter wird wahrscheinlich zu höheren Niveaus männlicher Kinderlosigkeit mit einem steileren sozioökonomischen Gradienten der Kinderlosigkeit führen. Wenn es also mehr Männer als Frauen im reproduktiven Alter gibt, muss rein rechnerisch ein Teil der Männer kinderlos bleiben. Die Frage ist jetzt, welcher? Wir können uns ungefähr vorstellen, welcher. Da Frauen typischerweise nach oben daten wollen oder zumindest.
Und höhere Bildungsabschlüsse inzwischen erzielen in vielen westlichen Staaten als Männer.
Also für Frauen wird es grundsätzlich schwierig, nach oben zu daten. Ja. Und jetzt gerät das ganze Gefüge noch so unter Druck.
Das knappe Gut Mann. Nee, ist eigentlich nicht das knappe Gut Mann. Das knappe Gut Frau.
Das knappe Gut Frau.
Aber ein knappes Gut ist da, wenn man den gebildeten Mann sucht.
Dann ist das auch.
Den Hochschulabschlussmann, der ist wieder unknapp.
Das knappe Gut Frau trifft es sehr gut. Die sozialen Konsequenzen, die im Text angeschnitten werden. Höhere Kriminalität und Gewalt. Hier muss man einfach wirklich politisch im Budget jetzt denken. Jedes eine Prozent mehr Fertilitätsrate und so weiter führt zu so und so viel mehr Gewalt im Bahnhofsviertel. Also es ist wirklich eins zu eins. Schnellere Ausbreitung sexuell übertragbarer Krankheiten. Instabilere Ehepartnermärkte, was eben auch bedeuten kann, wenn Frauen nicht ins Bodenlose fallen nach einer Trennung, weil genug Männer rumrennen, die als Reservearmee für Ersetzungen sorgen. Ich finde das eben auch zur Dynamik. Politische Radikalisierung junger unverpartneter Männer. Also dieser Text verweist als wissenschaftlichen Fundamentbeitrag sozusagen. Versagen dabei, den Bedürfnissen dieser Männer zu begegnen, birgt das Risiko eines kulturellen Backlashs gegen Geschlechtergleichheit und gesellschaftlicher Konflikte. Ich würde sagen, das ist genau das, was wir sehen. Wir haben Inseldiskussionen, wir haben Mennosphere-Diskussionen, wir haben rechtsradikale Diskurse unter diesen Genderbeobachtungen, vor allem Männer. Ein paar bringen dann Frauen mit und so weiter und so fort. Also hier geht es sozusagen ans eingemachte Vorschläge der Autoren, Position der Frauen stärken, um sechs selektive Abtreibungen zu verhindern. Das betrifft natürlich die asiatischen Länder mehr als uns. Bildung und Arbeitsmöglichkeiten für Kinderlose und Alleinstände Männer verbessern. Ich würde ja sagen, wir brauchen jetzt schon mal eine Bewegung, mit dem wir uns lange um die Mädchen in der Schule gekümmert haben. Wirklich aggressive. Wir gehen jetzt auf die Jungs in der Schule. Was ist da eigentlich los? Technische und institutionelle Lösung für Alleinstände und Kinderlose. Freundschaftsgruppen, also das große Thema männliche Einsamkeit. Also alle Themen, die wir diskutieren, finden wir schon. Also wir sehen schon, ja, hier liegen diese Autoren also nicht daneben. Außerdem Infrastruktur für Eltern, damit diejenigen Männer, die Kinder haben wollen, es auch schaffen. Da frage ich mich so ein bisschen, okay, mein Buch zum Thema ist klar, Perspektive für alle bieten. Das ist natürlich auch, ich habe es ja sehr markiert, mit dem Bekommen in Deutschland auf 1,4 Kinder pro Frau, wollen aber eigentlich, wenn man den Kinderwunsch abfragt, 2,4. Also es gibt durchaus eine Lücke, die zu füllen wäre. Was auch betrifft, Frauen, die aus einer Ehe mit Kindern kommen und noch im gebärfähigen Alter sind, brauchen sich dann mit neuen Partnern nicht noch ein drittes Kind zu, zum Beispiel, oder ein zweites. Also selbst da liegt wieder eine Hürde drin. Also da kommt wieder auch ein Mann nicht zum Zuge. Und das ist eben hier der Punkt, nicht nur das Matching, sondern, und das markieren sie ganz deutlich in den Texten, das halte ich auch für sehr wichtig. Fertilität wurde grundsätzlich, das ist der Standard in dieser Forschung, an Kinderzahlen, Geburtenziffern, was auch immer, pro Frau gerechnet. Und auch in der Land-Sendung, bei der ich war, bei Peichl und wie hieß er da, vom Bevölkerungsinstitut, der hat ja kurz angemerkt, wir wissen eigentlich nichts über den Kinderwunsch der Männer. Gibt da keine Erhebung dazu. Jetzt sehen wir aber, dass in Ostdeutschland sehr viele Männer schon so ein, das ist ein sehr großer Teil des blockierten Lebens, das immer diagnostiziert wird. Dass man eigentlich gerne Familie hätte, als Großvater vielleicht auch und so weiter. Und man sieht, wie andere leben und selbst wurde einem verwehrt. So und dazu gibt es einfach überhaupt gar keine Forschung, gar keine politischen Programme und gar nichts. Und ich würde sagen, dass hier liegt ein Fundament für, das kann das Jahrhundert jetzt prägen. Also das sehen wir in Amerika, das sehen wir in Deutschland, im asiatischen Raum exorbitant, der arabischen Raum dadurch, dass wir da diese Arbeitsmigration haben, die natürlich vor allem brauchen wir Gerüstbauer, Männer, wie wir es eben aus Katar gehört haben. Das erschließt sich ja sofort einfach, was hier das Problem ist. Der Ansicht ein sehr wichtiger Text, der natürlich wahrscheinlich nur von mir gelesen wurde und von denjenigen, die sich mir darauf hingewiesen haben. Aber ja, es findet noch relevante Forschung statt. Mit anspruchsvoller Statistik, das muss man auch sagen. Also bei dem Thema, bei dem man eigentlich keine Grundlage hat, aus den Daten, die einem die UN und so weiter zur Verfügung stellen, dann sowas herauszurechnen, um zumindest mal für folgende Forschung zumindest das Problem zu markieren, finde ich auch gar nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Noch eine Literaturempfehlung. Philipp Schönthaler hat eine Novelle geschrieben mit dem Titel Mysteria Hysteria. Eine Novelle zeichnet sich ja dadurch aus, dass es eine unerhörte Begebenheit gibt. Was ist die unerhörte Begebenheit hier, von der erzählt wird? Wir haben es mit einem namenlosen Protagonisten zu tun, der in der Verlagsbranche arbeitet als Lektor. Allerdings ist die KI-Technologie schon sehr weit fortgeschritten. Man optimiert, wo man nur kann, die Literatur. Er findet dort aber plötzlich eingesandt ein Manuskript, das er eigentlich gar nicht näher betrachten müsste, denn zunächst einmal macht ja die KI einen Test. Aber irgendetwas hält ihn dann doch davon ab, gleich von diesem Manuskript zu lassen. Es heißt da, eigentlich hätte ich das Manuskript, in dem ich auf den Satz gestoßen war und das ich Routinen mäßig in unser Programm hochgeladen hatte, gar nicht anschauen dürfen. Schon auf den ersten Blick war klar gewesen, dass der Text eklatante Mängel aufwies. Sämtliche Bewertungen lagen im Negativbereich. Denn so ist das nun jetzt in der neuen Welt der Bücher, wo die KI schon so weit ist, dass erst einmal alles der KI vorgelegt wird und die legt ihre Muster darauf an. So kommt heraus, alles rot oder orange. Keine Kategorie grün. Die Zahl der potentiellen Leserinnen war bei einem 2-Plus-Marketing mit lächerlichen 300 beziffert worden, was sogar zu der Meldung geführt hatte, dass kein geschlechtsspezifischer Schlüssel bereitgestellt werden könne. Dabei hatte die sprachliche Komplexität nicht einmal 100 Prozent erreicht. Der Innovationsgehalt war mit hoch, aber nicht sehr hoch bemessen worden. Ich hatte automatisch das Absageschreiben generieren lassen, das einschließlich Analyse und kostenfreien Tipps zum autonomen Textenhancement. Wir hatten das Feature aus juristischen Gründen eingepflegt und damit gute Erfahrungen gemacht, innerhalb einer Sekunde an die Autorin versendet worden war. Aber irgendetwas scheint ihnen doch an diesen Manuskript interessiert zu haben. Er löscht es nicht gleich von seinem Computer, sondern er blickt noch einmal drauf und stellt sich die Frage, ist das nicht der Text von einer Person, die mir mal wichtig war? Ist das nicht meine Jugendliebe Elektra, die Schriftstellerin werden wollte, die ich dafür bewundert habe und die mir eigentlich auch erst durch ihre Liebe zur Literatur mir das Reich zur Literatur erschlossen hat, weshalb ich jetzt dort arbeite? Es ist ein Text, der intelligent gebaut ist, deshalb weil einmal diese Sehnsucht nach der vergangenen Liebe aufgerufen wird. Aber die Frage sich jetzt stellt, kann es sein bei einem Text, der gar nicht außergewöhnlich ist, dass man darin die Person lesen kann? Oder ist eigentlich Textproduktion generell schon so generisch, dass man das nicht mehr von ableiten kann? Das ist eine Frage, die würde sich jetzt ein Profiler stellen, aber hier wird sie nochmal auf so einer emotionalen Ebene gestellt. Ob ich den Stil um eine Einheit in Richtung Komplexität drehe oder nicht doch lieber drei Einheiten zurück? Ob ich die Texttemperatur um drei Grad wärmer schalte oder um zwölf Grad nach unten justiere? Ob ich mit einem Zielpublikum von 17 oder 47 arbeite, einen Hesse- oder Heldfilter über das Ganze lege? Und mit diesen Entscheidungskompetenzen bewege ich mich nur an der Oberfläche. Denn du kannst an jedem Punkt tiefer gehen. Sehr tief. Heißt tief wie in den Abgrund. Er beschreibt hier seine Arbeit als Lektor, die sich verändert hat. Also plötzlich nimmt man die KI mit dazu. Man versucht eigentlich, die Texte so zu optimieren, dass sie ein möglichst großes Publikum erreichen. So werden Datenbanken erst einmal erhoben. Welche Publikationsorgane die Literaturkritik abtrocknen, würden sich wie zu welchem Roman unterverhalten? Was muss man tun, damit in der Rezension, die dieser Roman dann hervorbringen könnte, nachher steht, der Roman, der auf keiner Romreise fehlen darf. Oder ein Satz wie Der Jahrhundertroman, Ein Donnerschlag. Das heißt, das ist ein Text, der sich kritisch mit der KI und auch der Verlagswelt auseinandersetzt, dabei aber immer diese persönliche Komponente mit hineinbringt. Was ist das eigentlich, wenn da jemand so funktionalistisch über einen Text nachdenkt? Gibt es dann doch noch so etwas wie das Subjekt in einem Text oder ist alles verschwunden? So reist dieser namenlose Protagonist an einen Ort, der geschildert wird dort, nämlich nach Rügen, um zu schauen, ob er dort vielleicht Elektra findet. Möglicherweise war das ja eine Botschaft. Angekommen auf Rügen heißt es, ich schlüpfte aus meinen Schuhen und lief nahe der Brandung, den Strand hinunter, fragte mich erneut, was machst du hier? Ist es wirklich Elektra, die du suchst? Dabei muss ich noch hinzufügen, er arbeitet sehr häufig in seinen Sätzen mit Schrägstrichen. Die können mal andere Positionen eröffnen. Also ich blicke so oder anders auf die Sache. Oder sie stehen für ein Beziehungsweise oder ein und einfach. Und es war in diesem Moment eine leichte Prisegriff in meine Haare, in meiner Nase der dezente Geruch des Meers, dass ich zum ersten Mal dachte, damals Elektra am römischen Brunnen ihr Schreiben, das mich so unversehens getriggert und den Wunsch zu lesen geweckt hatte. Schrägstrich wieder, also dann wechselt der Satz die Richtung. Das Lesen selbst war das also, wie wir zusammengekommen waren, nicht alles eine fundamentale Verwechslung, wobei ich natürlich nur für mich sprechen konnte. Hast du damals, fragte ich mich Elektra, mit ihren Texten verwechselt die Intimität, die du von außen in ihrem Schreiben zu sehen meintest? Also die Frage, eigentlich der doppelten Kontingenzen, sowas sehen wir eigentlich, welche Kommunikation wird da gemacht? Eine sehr clevere Novelle von Philipp Schönthaler, kurzer Text, 43 Seiten. Aber mal eine literarische Diskussion zum Thema KI.
Sehr gut, passt wirklich wunderbar zum Folgenden. Und wer bin ich, einen Papst zu kommentieren? Ich lese einfach vor. Leo, der war also vor Jugendlichen und hat im Januar beim Welttag der sozialen Kommunikationsmittel geredet. Das fand schon zum sechzigsten, also der sechzigste Welttag der sozialen Kommunikationsmittel. Könnte man jetzt nochmal nachforschen, ist jetzt nicht mein Gebiet. Kommunikationsmittel, da würde ich so denken, okay, das gab eine Notwendigkeit, genau, als man dann so ein Smartphone hatte. Aber anscheinend gibt es da Tradition. Naja, jedenfalls ist das der für uns heute vörtergründige Text. Ich komme aber nachher noch auf den etwas größeren vom letzten Jahr zurück. Das Gesicht und die Stimme, sagt er. Da wissen wir schon, in welche Richtung das geht, KI-Fakes und so. Das Gesicht und die Stimme sind einzigartig unverwechselbare Merkmale jedes Menschen. Sie zeigen die eigene, einmalige Identität und sind wesentlich für die Begegnung mit anderen Menschen. Gesicht und Stimme finde ich schon mal gut und er leitet das her mit So verwendeten die alten Griechen zur Benennung der menschlichen Person das Wort Gesicht, also Prosopon, wie es hier heißt, das etymologisch das bezeichnet, was dem Blick begegnet, den Ort der Gegenwart und der Beziehung. Da dachte sie mir, ja das ist nicht verwunderlich, dass die damals in Rom einfach wirklich die Büste mitnehmen mussten, wenn sie selbst nicht anwesend waren. Also jemand aus dem Haushalt hat dann bei öffentlichen Veranstaltungen die 10 Kilo Büste unter den Arm genommen und hat gesagt, er ist heute auch hier. Man bringt ein Gesicht einfach mit. Der lateinische Begriff persona, von per sonare, beinhaltet hingegen den Klang. Nicht irgendeinen Klang, sondern die unverwechselbare Stimme eines Menschen. Also hier sind jetzt Pflöcke eingeschlagen, bei denen ich mich natürlich frage, ich habe mir ja gesagt, ich unterwerfe mich, ob ich meine Mitarbeiterinnen wirklich weiter Alcina, Sophie und Chiara und so weiter nenne, oder doch wieder Clon 1, 2, 3, 4 durchzähle. Aber ich bleibe erst mal bei den Namen. Wobei wir jetzt ja hören, Olivia hat auch schon eine Stimme bekommen. Sie hat ja einen eigenen Podcast. Ja. Gut, also hier wird ganz viel anthropologisch und nicht technologisch formuliert. Durch die Simulation menschlicher Stimmen und Gesichter von Weisheit und Wissen, Bewusstsein und Verantwortung, Empathie und Freundschaft, greifen die als künstliche Intelligenz bekannten Systeme nicht nur in Informationsökosysteme ein, sondern dringen auch in die tiefste Ebene der Kommunikation ein, nämlich in die der menschlichen Beziehung. Er markiert also das Problem. Hier rutscht ein Werkzeug aus der Assistenzfunktion heraus und schreibt für mich den Brief und macht für mich das Telefonat und so weiter und so fort. Die Herausforderung, die sich hier stellt, ist also nicht technologischer, sondern anthropologischer Natur. Die Gesichter und Stimmen zu bewahren, bedeutet letztlich, uns selbst zu bewahren. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist eben nicht nur der Arbeitsdiskurs, im Sinne von, wir verlieren hier etwas, also der Mensch entfremdet sich nicht nur von der Arbeit, sondern er findet gar nicht mehr im Arbeitsprozess statt. Man hat nur noch mit Produkten zu tun. Und da würde ich sagen, Algoritmenethik oder Kritik. Es gibt seit langem zahlreiche Belege dafür, dass Algoritmen, die darauf ausgelegt sind, die Interaktion der sozialen Medien zu maximieren, was für die Plattform profitabel ist, schnelle Emotionen belohnen und zeitaufwändigere menschliche Reaktionen, wie beispielsweise die Suche nach Verständnis und das Nachdenken benachteiligen. Hier würde ich sagen, ja, Butollo ist jetzt empirische Beobachtung von Nöten um punktuell in Arbeitsprozesse zum Beispiel einzugreifen. Denn es gibt ja diese Bereiche nicht nur auf Seiten von Unternehmen, die halt so eine Technologie herstellen, sondern grundsätzlich die Profitlogiken unterworfen sind. Also Ökonomie zur Unternehmenswelt. Und hier kann man ja durchaus jetzt mal ein Wort des Papstes Geltung verschaffen. Er bleibt aber noch im Felde der Kommunikationsmedien. Wenn wir durch unsere Feeds scrollen, wird es immer schwieriger zu erkennen, ob wir mit anderen Menschen oder mit Bots oder virtuellen Influencern interagieren. Dadurch wird uns die Möglichkeit genommen, anderen Menschen zu begegnen, die immer anders sind als wir selbst. Ohne Annahme des Andersseins kann es weder Beziehung oder Freundschaft geben. Das ist natürlich reformuliert. Filterbubble, Echo-Kammer und so weiter. Jemand begegnet zwar über Social Media auch, sozusagen nur noch dem eigenen Selbst. Man ist im Grunde in einem Selbstgespräch und versucht dann trotzdem, Gesellschaft damit zu machen. Das ist das Problem von diesem Newsbuch. So, und jetzt kommt dieser spektakuläre Gedanke. Ein Großteil der menschlichen Kreativwirtschaft läuft somit Gefahr, demontiert und durch das Label Powered by AI ersetzt zu werden, wodurch die Menschen zu bloßen passiven Konsumenten und nicht gedachten Gedanken anonymen Produkten ohne Urheberschaft und ohne Liebe werden. Also der nicht gedachte Gedanke, finde ich wirklich ein Megabild. Es sind Gedanken in der Welt, die kein Verhältnis zur Realität haben. Sie sind nicht gedacht worden. Geist und Körper haben, diese Definitionen hören wir gleich von Franziskus, keine intelligente Entscheidung getroffen, sondern es sind einfach so Sachen da, weil sie da sind. Weil die Mathematik das ergeben hat, weil ein Computer gearbeitet hat, Strom verbraucht hat, wie auch immer. Also der nicht gedachte Gedanke als Problem, den halten wir hier mal für später fest. Obwohl die KI-Unterstützung bei der Bewältigung kommunikativer Aufgaben bieten kann, birgt die Vermeidung eigenständigen Denkens und die Zufriedenheit mit einer künstlichen, statistischen Zusammenstellung langfristig die Gefahr, dass unsere kognitiven, emotionalen und kommunikativen Fähigkeiten nachlassen. Also wir ersetzen menschliches Denken durch Gedanken, die keinen Bezug mehr zur Realität haben, sondern nur noch eine Eigenlogik aus der Maschine sind. Und nicht nur bauen wir diese Kapazität auf, sondern im Zuge dessen auch unsere Kapazität ab. Sehr gut. Aber, und das finde ich halt erstaunlich, hier wird jetzt nicht gegen KI angekämpft, sondern Leo formuliert, die vor uns liegende Aufgabe besteht nicht darin, die digitale Innovation zu stoppen, sondern sie zu lenken und uns ihrer Ambivalenzen bewusst zu sein. Es ist an jedem einzelnen von uns, seine Stimme zur Verteidigung des Menschen zu erheben, damit wir diese Werkzeuge wirklich als Verbündete für uns gewinnen können. Mehr Versöhnung war noch nie im KI-Diskurs. Also wirklich finde ich sehr gut. Bildung, ihm natürlich wichtiges Thema, zieht darauf ab, unsere persönlichen Kompetenzen zu stärken, die es uns ermöglichen, kritisch zu denken, die Zuverlässigkeit von Quellen und die möglichen Interessen hinter der Auswahl der Informationen, die uns erreichen, zu bewerten, die psychologischen Mechanismen zu verstehen, die sie auslösen. Also das ist ja sowieso ein therapeutischer Diskurs, die Leute in die Reflektion reinzubringen. Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass er sagt, jeder der an dieser Kommunikation mithilfe von KI oder Computer Allgemein teilnimmt, muss immer reflektieren, während wir gleichzeitig von den großen Investoren, Marc Andresen und so gehört haben, Retrospektion gibt es hier nicht. Ich habe noch nie über mich selber nachgedacht, also über sich selber, als Recht nicht in Kommunikation mit, weil das sind ja Milliardäre, warum sollen die reflektieren?
Ja, das ist ja das, was wir jetzt in Davos so wunderbar beobachten konnten, dass niemand dort sitz, der selbst reflektiv ist.
Genau. Also in Ansicht sind wir hier schon sehr weit. Klar, das ist jetzt alles Papstsprache, das müsste man sozusagen ausarbeiten, aber das ist wirklich eine Einladung, das auszuarbeiten. Und auch sehr interessant, jetzt nehmen wir aber einzelne Anmerkungen von Franziskus damals. Dieser Text von vor einem Jahr war zehnmal so lang wie der eben. Also der jetzt war 2000 Worte, das ist so ein bisschen mehr als ein Zweispalter in der Fazit. Kann man also gut so zusammenfassen, wie ich es jetzt gemacht habe. Jetzt gehen wir mal ganz punktuell hier rein. Papst Franziskus allein schon, und hier wird, es ist ja nicht, also es ist ein Text des Vatikans, in dem selber auch Papst Franziskus referiert wird, im Sinne von da stehen Autoren drunter aus seinen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das dann nennt, Direkteriums oder so, die das für ihn aber arbeiten. Aber es ist ja am Ende eine Kommunikation des Heiligen Stuhls, in dem also der Franziskus selbst als benannte Referenz immer auftaucht. So, also Papst Franziskus wird jetzt zitiert. Allein schon die Verwendung des Wortes Intelligenz in Bezug auf KI ist irreführend. Intelligenz, aus dieser Perspektive sollte die KI nicht als eine künstliche Form der Intelligenz gesehen werden, sondern als eines ihrer Produkte. Also mach dir die Welt untertan, so wie ich. Nur Probleme lösen, die du wirklich hast. Nicht die KI des Ruders übernehmen lassen. So, denn die Intelligenzdefinition. Geist und Materie sind in der menschlichen Person nicht zwei vereinte Naturen, sondern ihre Einheit bildet eine einzige Natur. Die Seele ist nicht der immaterielle Teil der Person, der im Leib enthalten ist, so wie der Leib nicht die äußere Hülle eines Kerns ist, sondern es ist der ganze Mensch, der gleichzeitig materiell und geistig ist und ist die Quelle der Intelligenz. Nicht ohne Körperdenken. Die menschliche Intelligenz ist keine isolierte Fähigkeit, sondern wird in Beziehungen ausgeübt und findet ihren vollen Ausdruck im Dialog, in der Zusammenarbeit und in der Solidarität. Wir lernen mit anderen, wir lernen durch andere. Da würde ich sagen, das ist eine ganz wichtige Sache. Auch für Autoren wie Butollo, die glauben, ich bin ja intelligent, also setze ich mich mal schweigend an den Schreibtisch und schreibe ein Buch. Das ist nicht aus Gesprächen entstanden und das merkt man dem Buch auch an. Da war niemand unterwegs und hat noch mal eine Frage formuliert, sondern da hat man einfach Texte rezipiert und dann reformuliert. Und das ist, also grundsätzlich, ja, steckt hier noch ein bisschen mehr drin als Nocaid-Diskurs. Die menschliche Intelligenz ist letztlich ein Geschenk Gottes zum Erfassen der Wahrheit. Es ist eine angeborene Eigenschaft, also man muss schon geboren werden, sich nach dem Ursprung der Dinge zu fragen. Die Vernunft wird gleichsam überwältigt von der Feststellung, dass ihre Fähigkeit immer größer ist als das, was sie tatsächlich erreicht. Und jetzt kommt ein Satz, ich habe ja häufiger gesagt, auch in der Politik und so mächtig sein ist ja schön und gut, aber wenn es keinen Spaß macht, ist blöd. Papst Franziskus lässt sich wie folgt Gedankenwelten aufmachen. Mit den Worten Paul Claudels, und jetzt kommt der Satz, Intelligenz ist nichts ohne Freude. Wir haben bei Julia Enners auch gehört, man kann so intelligent sein, wie man will, die Ratio, aber solange sie nicht in der Assistenzrolle für die Emotionen ist, bringt es nichts. Dann ist man unglücklich, ungesund, was auch immer. Und dieser Satz, Intelligenz ist nichts ohne Freude. Der ist wirklich stark. Weil hier könnte man wirklich eine Intelligenzdefinition ableiten, bei der ich sage, ja, nehmt auch den Begriff Fleiß. Die Maschine ist unendlich fleißig, aber sie denkt sich nichts dabei, sie beklagt sich nicht, sie hat keine Freude. Trotzdem hilfreich. Ja, selbst Dante bezeugt, dass der Höhepunkt intellektuellen Vergnügens im Licht der Erkenntnis ganz erfüllt von Liebe zu finden ist. Kann man jetzt natürlich unendlich weit treiben. Ich würde nur mal sagen, Liebe ist auf jeden Fall ein Verweis auf Emotionen.
Aber es ist interessant, dass Franziskus dann jetzt hier nicht auf Philosophen, ja doch, bei Claudel, also eher auf Autoren, Schriftsteller zurückgreift. Er ist ja der, der auch das Lesen so hochgehalten hat von Literatur. Weil der ja genauer, wir hatten das mal in einem Sommersalon, auch das Gespräch mit dem anderen wirklich stattfinden kann, weil das Subjekt der Autor ja schreibt für einen. Und das ist nicht, das ist genau nicht der das Gedankenlose. Ja, oder das, das, wie war das der der gedankenlose Gedanke? Genau, der nicht gedachte, der nicht gedachte Gedanke, sondern es ist der gedachte Gedanke, der zu Papier gebracht wird.
Genau. Und Franziskus hat ja sehr auf das kommunizierende Dialog abgestellt, um überhaupt Intelligenz und so in Stellung bringen zu müssen. Wir nehmen noch vier Gedanken mit. Zum einen, um mit die KI in die Schranke zu weisen, eine zu starke Gleichsetzung von menschlicher Intelligenz und KI birgt die Gefahr, eine funktionalistischen Sichtweise zu erliegen, nach der Menschen nach den Aufgaben bewertet werden, die sie erledigen können. Das ist natürlich das Bild des Wir machen aus dem Menschen schon mal ein Teil der Maschinerie, den wir dann einfach auswechseln können gegen einen echten Maschinerieteil, sobald er so fortentwickelt ist, also die menschliche Hand und so. Der Wert einer Person hängt jedoch nicht vom Besitz einzigartiger Fähigkeiten ab. Also viel auch zu Butollos, ja, das Substitut von nach ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten zuteilen ist eben nicht mehr nach ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten, sondern darüber hinausgehend, wo wir brauchen wir Menschen, sondern von der ihr inne wohnenden Würde.
Klar, Kirchensprache, sie bleibt auch bei Menschen, die ihre Fähigkeiten nicht ausüben können, Rücksicht auch auf die erhalten, sei es bei einem ungeborenen Kind, klar, einem bewusstlosen Menschen oder einem leidenden alten Menschen. So, Arbeit und Bildung. Wir kommen nachher bei Mary's Text darauf zurück. Während die KI verspricht, die Produktivität zu steigern, indem sie ungewöhnliche Aufgaben übernimmt, sind die Arbeitnehmer oft gezwungen, sich an die Geschwindigkeit und die Anforderungen der Automaten anzupassen, anstatt das Letztere so konzipiert sein sollten, dass sie den Arbeitenden helfen. Das ist also das Infermezzo. Die Menschheit, die KI benutzt, fällt mittlerweile der KI zum Opfer, weil man alle so in diese, ich beobachte jetzt nur noch, ich steuer nur noch nach, aber meine eigenen Gedanken darf ich hier nicht einbringen, es bringt nur die KI durcheinander. Wir müssen mit der Vorstellung von Erziehung brechen, wonach Erziehung bedeutet, den Kopf mit Ideen zu füllen, so erziehen wir Automaten. Aber die haben wir ja jetzt. Makro-Kopf-Menschen nicht Menschen. Erziehung oder Erziehen heißt, die Spannung zwischen Kopf, Herz und Händen zu riskieren. So und jetzt aber, und das hat Franziskus eben schon gesehen und dazu wünsche ich mir dann auch den großen Text von Leo. Die Anmaßung, Gott durch ein Werk der eigenen Hände zu ersetzen, ist Götzendienst, soweit so bekannt. Die KI kann noch verführerischer sein als die traditionellen Götzen. Im Gegensatz zu jenen, die einen Mund haben und nicht reden, Augen und Sehen nicht, Ohren und Hören nicht, kann die KI sprechen oder zumindest den Anschein erwecken. Hier wurde das, was ich gerade so komisch von gelesen habe, sind Zitate aus kürzten Diskursen und so weiter. Und das ist ein Novum, das die Kirche hier durchaus erkennt. Die KI wird nicht einfach nur angebetet und dann wird gedeutelt, was der Blitz bedeutet oder so.
Das goldene Kalb kann ich jetzt sprechen.
Genau. Wir kriegen jetzt eine Antwort, wenn wir der KI eine Frage stellen. Und das macht sie sehr verführerisch. Und wenn man alles, was ich jetzt vorher vorgetragen habe, ernst nimmt, bedeutet das, das ist eine große Baustelle. Und Scott Galloway verweist ja immer wieder auf, wir brauchen KI-Reglementierung, die das mit diesen Beziehungen wirklich in den Blick nimmt. Während wir aber gerade sehen, naja, das gehört schon diesem universalen Charakter. Wir können jetzt nicht der KI sagen oder ihr System prompten. Wenn es nach Beziehungsgestaltung aussieht, sage ich, antworte jetzt nicht, weil man ist halt in der Beziehung mit einer kommunikativ responsiblen Technik. Das muss nicht erst explizit ausformuliert werden. Also in deren Sicht große, große Baustellen, die hier vom Heiligen Stuhl markiert wurden.
Caren Miosga hat Friedrich Merz eine Stunde lang interviewt. Ich habe mir das transkribieren lassen, habe es mir dann angehört, habe die Antworten von Friedrich Merz rausgenommen, um auch gleich vorwegzunehmen. Es ist nichts interessantes vorgekommen. Man hätte, glaube ich, nicht einen einzigen Clip aus der Sendung machen können. Aber dieser...
Das hat er noch nie einem Kanzler das widerfahren ist.
Nee, das hat er im Spiegel gesagt. Wurde hier aber auch nochmal aufgegriffen. Mir geht es jetzt darum zu sagen, es ist fundamental falsch, wie diese Talkshows angelegt sind und wie politischer Journalismus funktioniert. Wir werden jetzt hier nicht von mir den Vorwurf finden, sie hätte ihn aber härter befragen müssen, sondern mein Vorwurf ist, wo sind die Inhalte? Können wir überhaupt noch über irgendetwas lesen? Wir haben jetzt Butollo hier im Salon gehabt mit entsprechenden Zahlen, die dramatisch sind. Wir haben Bücher, die uns so viel Auskunft darüber geben, welche enormen Entwicklungen sich durch passieren. Ein Unternehmen entscheidet sich, kleine Elektrogeräte in China zu produzieren, Apple nämlich in China, und agiert damit wie ein Staat für sich und schafft dort eine völlig andere Arbeitswelt. Das sind alles radikale Verwerfungen und Veränderungen, über die man reden müsste. Wenn man einen Kanzler hat. Wir haben eine Deindustrialisierung, 10.000 Arbeitsplätze jeden Monat gehen seit 2024 verloren. All das müsste man ansprechen, aber wirklich als Strukturproblem, als eine grundsätzliche Systemkrise. Das wären die Anknüpfungspunkte, wenn man irgendwas erfahren will. Stattdessen folgendes. Ich habe heute nur einen Gast, den wir zum Jahrestag der schwarz-roten Koalition fragen wollen. Einjahrkanzler, wie schwer ist Regieren, Herr Merz? Wie schön, dass Sie da sind. Schönen guten Abend und wie schön, dass Sie zugucken. Ich begrüße auch unser Live-Publikum. Herzlich willkommen. Herr Bundeskanzler, am kommenden Mittwoch sind Sie genau ein Jahr im Amt. Wir sehen hier noch einmal ein Foto von 6. Mai 2025 von Ihrer Vereidigung. Hätten Sie damals schon ein bisschen geahnt, wie schwer das Regieren zuweilen sein kann? Was macht das Regieren besonders schwer? Also dazwischen gibt es immer Antworten. Was macht das Regieren besonders schwer? Gibt es einen Rat, den der Friedrich Merz von heute, dem Friedrich Merz von vor einem Jahr geben würde? Das Kabinett hat diese Woche eine Gesundheitsreform beschlossen und die Eckwerte des Haushalts verabschiedet. Wir werden über beide sprechen. Das wird man am Ende nicht richtig tun. Aber weil wir den Eindruck haben, dass sich Ihre Koalition sich beim Regieren besonders schwer macht, möchten wir ihnen zu Beginn der Sendung einen Satz sagen, den sie damals als Kanzlerkandidat hier in dieser Sendung gesagt haben. Da kommt was von Friedrich Merz, der dann sagt so und so. Damals meinten sie die Ampelregierung. Warum ist dieser Satz heute noch zutreffend? Sie wollen noch weitere Reformen umsetzen. Aber zuweilen drängt sich der Eindruck auf, dass ihr Koalitionspartner nicht dieselben Dinge will oder beziehungsweise nicht denselben Weg gehen will wie sie. Wir hören einmal die Arbeitsministerin von der SPD, die gestern gesprochen hat auf einer Kundgebung in Duisburg am 1. Mai, auf der sie sich große Sorgen gemacht hat über die Beschneidung von Arbeitnehmerrechten. Dann hören wir Bars, die dann sagt, dass es menschenverachtend, dass man das alles zusammenkürzen will. Herr Merz, Sie haben auf dem Landesparteitag Nordrhein-Westfalen im August letzten Jahres den Satz gesagt, wir können uns den Sozialstaat in seiner jetzigen Form nicht mehr leisten. Und wenn Frau Bars jetzt sagt, wenn der Sozialstaat nur als Ballast dargestellt wird, den wir uns nicht mehr leisten können, dann ist das zynisch und menschenverachtend. Dann meint sie Sie, oder? Aber nur noch mal die Vokabeln, zynisch und menschenverachtend. Das ist keine SPD-Volklore. Aber ist das die Basis, Herr Merz, auf der man wirklich eine Rentenreform auf den Weg bringen kann? Das ist immerhin der Verantwortungsbereich der Ministerin und der größte Brocken im Haushalt. Aber erwarten Sie Mut von einer Frau, die so spricht? Wie gesagt, wie diese Rentenreform gestaltet wird, da gibt es kein Wort dazu, nur kommen sie noch miteinander klar, geht so weiter. Deswegen muss es auch zwischen Ihnen und Lars Klingbeil gerumst haben. Dann wird dann erzählt, dass da irgendein Konflikt war. Was ist da passiert? Sie haben ein echtes Vertrauensverhältnis noch? Gibt es das noch, Vertrauen in der Politik? Gibt es das wirklich? Aber wie tauschen sie sich aus gemeinsam, wenn sie über solche Berichte in den Medien lesen? Wenn wir jetzt dem Nios Buch Fiktion vorwerfen, dann haben wir hier einfach eine andere Fiktion. Also es geht nur noch um, wie kommen sie miteinander klar und können wir ihnen vielleicht noch helfen, dass wir besser miteinander klarkommen? Dann wird Christian von Stetten zitiert, der sagt, das mit der Koalition, das hält nicht mehr lange. Sie fragt dann darauf, aber ist das Verhältnis inzwischen so zerrüttet, dass man in ihren eigenen Reihen um den Fortbestand der Koalition fürchtet? Obwohl sie jetzt im Interview im Spiegel gesagt haben, dass sie selbst Zweifel haben, ob es ihnen gelingen kann, diese Regierung wieder auf Kurs zu bringen. Woran haben sie genau Zweifel? Haben das alle begriffen inzwischen, dass man nur gemeinsam überleben kann?
Ah, so.
Also wir sind jetzt 20 Minuten, haben wir jetzt bald rum. Und reden immer noch, wie ist die Gefühle?
Also ich halte es nicht aus.
Wieder Christian von Stetten, hat er irgendwas gesagt? Kann das sein, dass sie dadurch selber so hohe Erwartungen, ach nee, ich lese es dir ganz vor, weil das würde ich sehr freuen. Hier, pass auf. Kann es sein, wenn Christian von Stetten diese Kritik äußert, dass er ausspricht, was vielleicht viele denken, dass sie Zweifel daran haben, dass sie diese beiden Parteien nicht richtig zusammenführen? Sie sind der Mann, den man als Oppositionsführer kennt, als links ist vorbei Merz. Und jetzt sind sie natürlich in einer anderen Rolle und müssen Kompromisse machen. Kann das sein, dass sie dadurch selber so hohe Erwartungen geschürt haben, die sie praktisch enttäuschen mussten? Liegt darin auch der Grund für einen Vertrauensverlust? Aber trauen ihnen noch genug Leute, auch in den eigenen Reihen zu, diese beiden Pole zusammenzubringen?
Alter Schwede.
Wo schon Vertrauen ist, da ist die Hoffnung nicht weit. Und sie haben Grund zur Hoffnung, dass die Kollegen Bärbel, Bas und Lars Klingbeil, nach dem, was wir da vorhin gehört haben, auch fröhlich weiter an die gemeinsame Arbeit gehen. Wir wollen noch einen Moment beim Thema Vertrauen bleiben und ihnen ein paar Stimmen zeigen, die wir gesammelt haben. Dann werden also Bürger eingespielt, die irgendwie sagen, ja, das ist ja alles ein bisschen komisch. Die machen ja gar nicht die Reformen. Man erfährt noch nie, welche Reform genau und wie sie aussehen sollte.
Reform halt.
Danach macht sie das nachdenklich. Ich würde gerne auf ein Beispiel kommen, weil der Herr gerade sagte zum Schluss das Zitat mit der Rente. Da wollen wir die Zuschauer nochmal mitnehmen. Da geht es um die Rede, die sie beim Bankenverband am 20. April gehalten haben. Und da haben sie über die drei Säulen der Altersversorgung gesprochen und haben einen Satz gesagt, der dann anschließend über den gestritten wurde. Den hören wir mal. Dann kommt das mit dieser Basisabsicherung. So und danach brach ein Sturm der Entrüstung los. Und verstehen sie inzwischen warum? Nur, ich will ja ergründen, warum die Leute danach so sauer waren. Also auch hier keine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung damit, mit Rentenpolitik nämlich. Möglicherweise haben sie nicht gesagt, dass es die Rentner der Zukunft betrifft. Und viele hatten das Gefühl, es betreffe sie selbst, sodass sie anschließend auch richtigstellen mussten, dass es nicht um Kürzungen ginge. Also das Problem ist gar nicht, dass man jetzt Kürzungen für die nächste Generation vornimmt, sondern nur, dass die, die jetzt gerade Rente haben, nicht eine Kürzung nehmen.
Die hätte sich durchaus eine Referenz auf die gerade Zuschauenden machen können.
Ja. Gerade im Osten gibt es Menschen, die nur die gesetzliche Rente haben und die waren natürlich sorgenvoll, dass das jetzt sie betreffen könnte. Sind sie da gar nicht selbstkritisch? Weiter heißt, also ich überspringe jetzt mal so ein bisschen, es geht dann nochmal um, und da haben sie das gesagt, die Umfragen, also die Leute sind nicht mehr zufrieden. Was denken sie manchmal darüber? Sie haben es ja auch schon ein bisschen angedeutet. Sind wir Weltmeister im Jammern? Oder nehmen sie den Missmut ernst? Nochmal Thema SPD, die Reform jetzt kommt, die Mitversicherten von nicht erwerbsfähigen Ehepartnern, die Mitversicherung soll wegfallen. Das müsste man ja inhaltlich thematisieren. Die Frage ist nur für Kare Miosga, wie groß wird der Widerstand der SPD sein? Was macht sie glauben, dass das durchkommt? Das heißt, was wir hier eigentlich haben, ist betreutes Regieren. Herr Merz, können wir sie an die Hand nehmen? Wir haben gesehen, sie können das alleine nicht. Oder müssen wir uns mal mit Lars Klingbeil zusammensetzen, damit wir uns wieder vertragen, was der Bevölkerung zugemutet wird, was das bedeutet. Wird gar nicht thematisiert. Es ist völlig verrückt. Dann geht es darum, aber es bleibt das Gefühl, dass das eine Gerechtigkeitsfrage ist, dass fast nur die gesetzlich Versicherten für die Grundsicherung aufkommen. Also hier zum ersten Mal wird man überlegt, wie mit Beamten umgehen. Aber auch das wird nicht weitermachen. Dazwischen wieder, wie groß ist die Hoffnung? Dann wird gesagt, aber sie wollten noch keine Steuern erhöhen und jetzt kommt die Tabaksteuer. Dann würde ich sagen, na gut, also das, was er damals zum Thema Steuerhörungen sagte, war, zog sich auf Einkommen und nicht jetzt auf irgendeine Tabaksteuer. Das ist ja nun wirklich unsinnig. Wenn sie weiterhin streiten, Herr Merz, mit der SPD, werden sie an der Durchsetzbarkeit von echten Reformen ihr eigenes politisches Schicksal knüpfen? Aber wenn sie sich so weiter streiten und wenn der Vertrauensverlust in ihren eigenen Reihen größer wird oder zumindest die Hoffnung, dass das noch etwas wird, wären sie auch bereit, die Vertrauensfrage zu stellen?
Ja, hätte man ja sagen wollen.
Dann kommt eine Kurzfragerunde. Ja, eben, also was erwartet man von der, weil sie ja sagen, ja, ich werde nächste Woche die Vertrauensfrage stellen. Natürlich. Dann Kurzfragerunde. Was er davon hält, dass Söder keine Pratwurstbilder mehr posten will bei Instagram, irgendwas zu Schalke 04. Dann geht es wieder weiter zu Iran. Die müssen über den Iran-Krieg sprechen. Also jetzt was Inhaltliches. Vielleicht? Nein. Und ihr Verhältnis zu Donald Trump, das sich seit Beginn des Iran-Krieges verändert hat. Beunruhigt sie das, dass Donald Trump plötzlich so unfreundlich über sie spricht? Was soll er darauf antworten? Und dafür lassen sie jetzt diese ganze Woche jeden Tag sich so hämisch beleidigen? Glauben sie, dass sich jetzt gerade was verändert hat bei den Amerikanern mit Sicht auf die Deutschen?
Nein.
Oder ist er denn so böse und so sauer geworden wegen ihrer Wortwahl, dass sie gesagt haben, die Iraner demütigten die USA? Haben sie schon mit Donald Trump gesprochen? Aber in der letzten Woche nicht? Und warum sie es auch in diesem Umfeld gesagt haben? Sie haben es in einer sauerländischen Schule gesagt, diesen Satz, von dem ich gerne wissen würde, ob sie ihn heute immer noch sagen würden. Er hat das jetzt zu einem großen diplomatischen Störfeuer geführt. Aber so wie sie jetzt reden, kann man sich ja ein bisschen wundern, dass sie so deutlich Kritik üben. Weil eigentlich wollte ich sie fragen, ob sie mit dieser deutlichen Kritik, sie ist ja wirklich deutlicher zuvor, ihre Strategie im Umgang mit Donald Trump und dieser Administration ändern wollen. Das heißt, alle sinnvollen Fragen, die man zum Iran stellen müsste, zum Beispiel Rammstein, werden nicht gestellt. Und alle Fragen, die hier gestellt werden, kann ein Friedrich Merz, ich will hier nicht den Schutz nehmen, aber die kann er nicht beantworten. Er kann nicht in einer Talkshow sitzen und sagen, ja, der Donald Trump ist verrückt geworden, ich habe den den Kampf angesagt, das wiederhole ich jetzt gerne nochmal hier. Meinen Sie, es ist übermorgen wieder vorbei?
Ja, da habe ich ja die Vertrauensfrage gestellt.
Aber man könnte auch den Eindruck haben, dass er sich jetzt sehr ärgert und dass das auch Folgen haben kann. Denn Donald Trump hat angekündigt, 5000 sogar mehr als 5000 US-Soldaten aus Deutschland abzuziehen. Es gibt keinen Zusammenhang. Dann wieder Fragen darum, wie machen wir das denn, wenn wir diese Tomahawks nicht bekommen? Können wir das kompensieren? Ist der Zug abgefahren? Was bedeutet das? Was bedeutet das für die Verteidigung? Wann ist das Ziel erreicht? Dass die Amerikaner ihre Streitkräfte jetzt abziehen, war geplant. Aber womöglich geht das schneller. Und dass die Mittelstreckenraketen womöglich nicht kommen. Wie wird wohl Vladimir Putin darauf gucken? Man könnte ja auch jemanden fragen stellen, braucht man überhaupt diese Art der Abschreckung? Aber nein. Nachfrage? Aber freut er, also Putin, sich gerade, oder? Ich weiß, aber über den Konflikt innerhalb der NATO wird er sich freuen, dass die Amerikaner sagen, die Europäer sind nicht verlässlich. Trump hat auch noch was anderes getan. Er hat wieder mit höheren EU-Zöllen gedroht. Haben sie das Gefühl, Trump will Deutschland besonders treffen, weil wir besonders betroffen wären? Sie können ihn sogar ein bisschen verstehen. Wie sollten wir reagieren oder die EU? Wann werden sie mit ihm sprechen? Und mal sagen, hör mal, reg dich nicht so auf. Immer meine Sätze in der Schule. Laden sie ihn noch nach Deutschland ein in diesem Jahr? Und vielleicht könnten sie ihn auch bei der Fußball-WM treffen. Die ist ja in den USA und Kanada. Sollten wir die USA aus dem Turnier fegen, müssen wir dann auch mit Strafzöllen rechnen? Das war jetzt eine witzig gemeinte Frage.
Ja, habe ich rausgelesen.
Wie sehr hoffen sie insgeheim, dass diese Weltmeisterschaft die Stimmung anschieben kann, die wir hier aus eigener Kraft gerade nicht schaffen? Hier ist die Sehnsucht nach dem politischen Lagerfeuer, das Mariam Lau wollte. Vielleicht kann es die Nationalmannschaft uns bringen. Aber wenn die Deutschen weit kommen, dann welches Ziel gibt der Kanzler aus? Wohin müssen wir es mindestens schaffen? Herr Bundeskanzler, vielen Dank für Ihren Besuch.
Ich möchte was anmerken. Caren Miosga arbeitet pro Woche genau diese eine Stunde. Sie sitzt da und stellt Fragen. Wenn der Bundeskanzler kommt, weiß man, es ist eine sehr einfache Kiste, weil inhaltlich haben wir es ja gehört. Da gibt es dann auch nicht mehrere Gäste. Da muss man nichts koordinieren, gar nichts. Man muss einfach abwarten, bis er kommt. Und Caren Miosga verdient in dieser eine Stunde 40.000 Euro. Und sie kriegt damit ein höheres Gehalt als der Bundeskanzler, dem sie da gegenübersetzt. Und das, was du jetzt vorgetragen hast, ist das Resultat der kompletten Arbeit von Caren Miosga. Sie macht sonst nichts anderes. Es gibt kein weiteres Werk, kein weiteres Artefakt. Nichts weiter bleibt hängen von ihrer Arbeit. Nur diese Fragen.
Plus noch so 20 Prozent, die ich jetzt rausgelassen habe. Denken sie wirklich?
Ja, die hast du bestimmt rausgelassen, weil die so klug waren, diese Fragen.
Ja, die Zuckersteuer wollen sie aber auch noch erheben. Aber sie wollten auch noch die Tabaksteuer. Aber sie wollten ja keine Steuern erheben.
Wollen sie Steuern erheben? Das ist wirklich ganz schlimm. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Ich verurteile das sehr.
Ja, also wir brauchen wirklich keine Diskussion mehr über Podcaster, die keine kritischen Fragen stellen. Das ist gar nichts. Also diese Fragen, so ein Gespräch, kann man übrigens auch mit jedem Oberhaupt auf der Welt führen. Ja, weil das ist ja einfach nur glauben Sie, denken Sie, haben Sie noch Hoffnung.
Ja, absurd. Mein letzter Text heute kommt von Mary, also hier aus diesem Büro. Er handelt vom Infermezzo. Das ist ihr neues Substack. Akkupalypse. Also wer sich jetzt das anhört, nicht Apokalypse, sondern Akkupalypse, C und P, vertauscht. Dieser Text bettet sich ein. Also es ist ja selber sozusagen der premiären Text, aber er bettet sich ein in mehrere Texte zu ähnlichen Phänomen plus ein Wörterbuch. Also wir sind ja ganz nah am soziokulturellen Techniktagebuch, das so geführt wird. Und das Infermezzo wird wie folgt beschrieben. Wir haben es mit allem substantiv zu tun, dass die Pause, die die Nutzerinnen erleben, so schreibt sie, während die KI an einer Aufgabe arbeitet. Also man schreibt ein Prompt. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass wir im Chat hängen, sondern wir machen ja richtige KI Arbeit. Die braucht also eine Weile, die also keinen unmittelbaren Output erzeugt. Das ist ein Kofferwort aus oder ein Mashup aus der Inference. Also das Modell, die KI arbeitet gerade, zieht Schlussfolgerungen, macht das, was man ihr gegeben hat. Und dem Intermezzo, das kennen wir natürlich, das Zwischenspiel zwischen den Akten, bevor das Stück weitergeht. Es ist nicht so richtig eine Pause, aber es ist kurz Ruhe und ich weiß nicht so genau, darf man jetzt was sagen, wie auch immer. Ein Intermezzo ist keine Ruhepause. Die Hauptaufführung hat pausiert, aber backstage geschieht weiterhin etwas. Die Bühne wird umgebaut, der nächste Akt vorbereitet, das Publikum sitzt da, weder ganz beteiligt, noch ganz frei. Man wartet halt, weil gerade was passiert im Computer. Man weiß nicht genau wann, aber umso schneller man das sieht, also wendet man seinen Blick auch nicht ab, sondern bleibt dran, um dann diese Zeit zu nutzen. Sie zitiert hier Pablo Stanley, Agenten brauchen zwei bis drei Minuten, lang genug, um etwas anderes anzufangen, aber kurz zu kurz, um es zu Ende zu bringen. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt genau das, was wir alle beobachten, worunter wir auch alle leiden. Jeder findet so eigene Strategie. Also ich höre nebenbei Podcasts. Es ist der Durchrauschprozess für die künftigen Inhalte des Podcasts. So früher habe ich mir feste Zeitblöcke, Zeitblöcke für die Konzeptarbeit reserviert. Ich recherchierte, las Aufsätze und ordnete sie zu Argumenten, suchte Konkurrenzmodelle heraus und nahm sie auseinander. Ich gestaltete Sätze, Narrative, Formen und Texte zusammen. Ich präsentierte, arbeitete die Konzepte um, damit andere sie verstehen konnten. Das war Arbeit. Und es war meine wichtigste Quelle des Lernens. Wenn jetzt alles in die Maschine wandert, wissen wir, okay, das passt da nicht so gut. Dadurch, nimmt sich hier die Mintzberg-Poante, rutschen wir alle in die Rolle des Managers rein, weil wir ja jetzt jemanden haben, an den wir delegieren. Manager leben in flüchtigen Begegnungen. Sie fangen Unterbrechungen ab, sitzen in Meetings, die teils zeremoniell sind. Sie müssen Informationen auf der Stelle verarbeiten. Mintzberg nennt sie Sklaven des Augenblicks. Wir werden alle Sklaven des Augenblicks. Also das ist sozusagen im großen Rad der Maschine. Immer warten, bis der nächste Zahn vorbeikommt, an der man sich dann dranhängen kann. Sie sind strukturell von der eigentlichen Arbeit am Stoff entkoppelt. Also die Manager, die jetzt auch zunehmen. Und das untergräbt die Fähigkeit, zu beurteilen, ob das, was ihnen berichtet wird, überhaupt wahr ist. Man macht ja nicht jedes Mal eine Forensik von Zuarbeitungen, die einem im Meeting dann präsentiert werden.
Weshalb man dann wieder Unternehmensberater braucht, die das nochmal nachprüfen.
Genau. Genau. Also das ist im Grunde die externe Supervision, die dann punktuell hinzukommt, um nochmal die Form dieser Arbeit zu hinterfragen.
Und sich dann auch in die Prozesse ein, um sie verstehen zu können.
Genau. Sie zitiert hier Jerry Muller. Sobald KPIs, also Key Performance Indicators, zu Steuerungszielen werden, entwickeln sie ihre eigene Schwerkraft. Das findet dann in der Maschine statt. Entscheidungen folgen den Zahlen, statt die zugrunde liegende Tätigkeit zu verbessern, die die Zahlen abbilden sollten. Metriken und ich ergänze, frameworks sind ein Substitut für Bewertungen. Mein gesamtes neues Lernen dreht sich gerade um Tech. Neue Methoden, neue Tools, neue Arbeit zu orchestrieren, das ist real und wertvoll, aber es ist Methodik und nicht inhaltliche Arbeit. Während die KI die inhaltliche Arbeit übernimmt, entkoppel ich mich zu sehr von meiner eigenen Fachexpertise und dann die finale Frage, würden mir meine Frameworks das je sagen? Machen die natürlich nicht. Die KI präsentiert keine Methode, die sagt, einfach Ergebnis ist da, bitte. Und dann geht es halt weiter. Also in deren Sicht nicht unbedeutend. Und hier gibt es im Ausblick zur Unterwachung. Ja, das ist auch ein großes Thema. Bislang hatte man ja immer die Möglichkeit, im Management über die Gestaltung der Beschlussvorlage, obwohl man gar nicht selber der Chef ist, die Entscheidung, Effekte, die später auf einen hereinbrechen, so ein bisschen mitzusteuern. Wenn wir jetzt alle Manager werden, werden wir dann eigentlich alle unterwacht. Also diese neuen Fragestellungen. Dann da wünsche ich mir, dass dann solche Theoretiker wie Butollo oder so so kleinteilig werden. Weil das ist jetzt nicht, da kann man mal drei Seiten drüber schreiben.
Zum Schluss noch Musik von der großartigen Geigerin Anne-Sophie Mutter, die ihr 50. Bühnenjubiläum jetzt feiert. Sie ist ja mit 13 Jahren in die Öffentlichkeit getreten, hat mit Kara Jan zusammen gespielt. Sie ist aber nicht nur in der alten klassischen Musik zu Hause, sondern war auch immer eine Geigerin, die der zeitgenössischen Musik viel Aufmerksamkeit gewidmet hat. Und so ist es wunderbar, dass nun eine Reihe beginnt mit zeitgenössischer Musik, die für sie komponiert wurde, die sie einspielt. East Meets West heißt das erste Album. Darauf sind Kompositionen von Thomas Adès, Jörg Widmann, Aftab Darvishi und Unsuk Chin. Das sind beeindruckende Einspielungen. Schon deshalb, weil die technische Brillanz ja unbestritten ist bei Anne-Sophie Mutter. Aber wie locker ihr Zugriff darauf ist, wie intensiv sie das spielen kann. Es ist wahnsinnig beeindruckend, vor allem auch, weil es so unterschiedliche Stücke sind. Da ist von der niederländisch-iranischen Komponisten Aftab Darvishi ein Stück, das heißt Liko, ein Solo für Violine. Bei dem Solo für Violine muss man bis hin an Johann Sebastian Bach denken. Aber man denkt auch, und das ist bewusst aufgerufen, an iranische Volkslieder, die hier miteinander kombiniert werden. Das sind auch sehnsüchtige Rufe der Geige, auch Rufe der Einsamkeit. Wir haben fast so eine Art Bolero-Thema in der Komposition von Unsuk Chin, dass da zwei Violinen miteinander in einen Dialog treten. Das wird wirklich ganz herausragend gespielt von Anne-Sophie Mutter und Nancy Zhou. Jörg Widmann orientiert sich bei seinem Sechsten Streichquartett an Beethoven. Er ruft also die Beethoven-Stimmung auf, durchsetzt sie dann aber mit seinen atonalen Klängen, geht immer wieder zu einer Harmonie und zu einer Schönheit zurück, die dann durchbrochen wird. Allerdings nie, um dann unschön zu werden, sondern um schroffer zu werden, um eine andere Kälte reinzubringen, eine Erschütterung reinzubringen, die aber auch sozusagen in einer Beethoven-Tradition zu sehen ist. Großartig gespielt, das spielt Anne-Sophie Mutter mit ihren Stipendiaten ein. Sie kümmert sich ja auch sehr darum, junge Spitzentalente zu betreuen. Und ein ganz besonderes Werk, vielleicht kann man das als zweites hören. Also ich würde mit Likoo anfangen und dann als zweites den Thomas Sardes zu hören. Das ist ein Violinkonzert von Thomas Sardes, das eine Hommage an Sibelius darstellt. Und wer Sibelius schon mal gehört hat, der weiß, das sind ja diese nordischen, flörenden Klänge. Man sieht die gleißende Sonne. Man sieht diese Luft in der Höhe, wo sie dünner wird. Es ist ja eine ganz besondere Erfahrung, die da drin liegt. Und diese Stimmung eigentlich von Sibelius nimmt Thomas Adès wieder auf, indem er ganz hohe Töne Anne-Sophie Mutter spielen lässt. Und das ganze Orchester muss, also die Streicher müssen ganz hoch anfangen. Und man hört erst gar nicht die einzelne Geige. Und daraus, aus diesen fast sphärischen Klängen, löst sich diese Solistin Anne-Sophie Mutter dann heraus und spielt mit dem Orchester, dem London Symphony Orchester zusammen. Diese Hommage an Sibelius, hinreißend schön. Also diese Verneigung vor der Schönheit, die in all den vier Werken liegt, ist was, was mich hingerissen hat. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie diese Reihe jetzt fortgesetzt wird. Denn es zeigt hier ganz klar, ja, neue Musik, die kann mitunter sehr, sagen wir, abweisend wirken. Hier aber eigentlich gar nicht, sondern es ist wirklich eine Musik, die auch das Zeitgenössische in sich trägt. Also wir haben es hier auch nicht zu tun, einfach nur mit La-Pu-La-Spielereien, sondern wir haben nun auch eine andere Zeit, in der dann doch auch ein anderer Klang sein darf. Nicht einfach nur, um zu experimentieren, sondern um vielleicht auch nach heutige Stimmung auszudrücken und zugleich aber auch in einer Tradition zu bleiben, sei sie jetzt von Beethoven oder Sibelius begründet. Und da hat wirklich Anne-Sophie Mutter diesen wunderbaren Bogenschlag. Und was ich ja bei ihr so faszinierend finde, ist, dass sie den Ton produziert, dass man gar nicht merkt, wie er entsteht. Also man hat fast den Eindruck, der Ton entsteht schon, bevor sie überhaupt die Geige berührt hat. Und das ist hier so wunderbar auf diesem CD, auf diesem Album zu hören. Ja, nicht nur als CD, sondern selbstredend auch über die Streamingdienste.
Ja. Wie stellt man sich das jetzt vor? Also da wird sammelbandartig Komponisten zusammengesucht, unter der Maßgabe, wir schreiben jetzt für?
Naja, das sind ja oftmals Auftragskompositionen, dann auch für Aufführungsorte, für Festivalreihen. Das heißt, das sind ja jetzt Kompositionen, die nicht alle nur entstehen für das Album, das dann produziert wird, sondern Anne-Sophie Mutter gibt ja regelmäßig Uraufführungen auch und ist ja auch in einem sehr regen Austausch dann mit Komponisten aus verschiedenen Generationen und über ja alle Länder auch hinweg. Das ist das beeindruckende bei ihr.
Also jetzt nicht neue Musik, sondern mehrere Jahre wurden Stücke zusammengesammelt, die für sie geschrieben wurden.
Richtig, ja.
Sehr gut, dann hören wir das.
Ja.
Und sehen uns Ende des Monats.
Ja. Wir wissen noch nicht, was wir dann lesen, aber wir werden es ankündigen. Nochmal zum Schluss, am 22. August kann man uns in der CES, nicht in der CES, sondern im Saal Bornheim erleben. Die Tickets gibt es online, neu20er.de. Wir freuen uns, euch dort zu begrüßen. Jetzt aber erstmal einen schönen Monat.
Bis denn.